Hallo, ich bin Chris Ehrenberg, ich bin 38 Jahre alt, ich lebe in Kulmbach in Oberfranken und ich kandidiere in diesem Jahr für das Amt zum Aufsichtsrat des 1. Für mich ist zum Beispiel die Bilanz des 1. FC Nürnberg genauso spannend, wie wenn die Kickernoten am Montag rauskommen oder die Aufstellung drin steht oder das Spiel anfängt.
Gewählt wurden erneut Peter Schmidt, Nürnbergs Oberbürgermeister Ulrich Marli, neu dabei sind Christian Ehrenberg und Radiolegende Günter Koch.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum 16. Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und neben mir sitzt derjenige, den ihr da schon gerade im Intro habt, sprechen hören. Es hat ihn einigermaßen amüsiert. Wir sprechen heute darüber, wie es eigentlich ist, Aufsichtsrat bei einem Bundesligisten zu sein. Deshalb begrüße ich hier bei mir Chris bzw. Christian Ehrenberg. Hallo.
Hallo Max, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Danke, dass du gekommen bist. Du bist Aufsichtsratmitglied beim 1. FC Nürnberg und wirst mir heute mal erklären dürfen, was man da eigentlich so macht und wie das alles so kam. Aber wir müssen noch nicht gleich reinstarten. Wir haben noch jede Menge Zeit. Bevor wir loslegen, danke ich ganz herzlich den Rasenfunk-Supportern Marian Sievers, den lieben Sebastian atcurious und dem Janik. Alle drei unterstützen uns seit einer grauen Weile. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Wer ebenfalls den Rasenfunk unterstützen möchte, kann das tun unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und jetzt würde ich sagen, Chris, erklär mir doch mal, wie wird man denn Aufsichtsrat beim 1.
Also beim 1. FC Nürnberg wird man das durch die Wahl der Mitgliederversammlung. Und wir beim 1. FC Nürnberg haben seit 2010 ein System, in dem neun Aufsichtsräte jeweils drei turnusmäßig für jedes Jahr auf drei Jahre gewählt werden. Das klingt jetzt, so wie ich es sage, ein bisschen kompliziert, aber tatsächlich ist es so, jedes Jahr werden drei neue gewählt und die werden dann auf drei Jahre festgelegt.
Das heißt, es gibt eine beständige Rotation im Aufsichtsrat?
Richtig, ganz genau.
Ist das typisch für die Bundesliga oder hat der FC N da seinen eigenen Weg?
Ich glaube, typisch oder untypisch gibt es, wenn man sich die Satzungen und vor allem die Zusammenstellungen der anderen Kollegen oder der anderen Vereine anguckt, eigentlich so wirklich gar nicht. Es gibt ganz viele Vereine, die mit weniger Aufsichtsräten arbeiten. Es gibt auch Schalke zum Beispiel, die mit mehr arbeiten, die aber viele sogenannte kooptierte Mitglieder haben, zum Beispiel aus der Fan-Abteilung, was ja jetzt auch nicht…
Was heißt das dann?
Kooptiert bedeutet, dass der Aufsichtsrat oder diese jeweilige Person entweder von einer bestimmten Abteilung innerhalb eines Vereins bestimmt wird für den Aufsichtsrat oder der Aufsichtsrat selbst noch Mitglieder benennen kann, wo er zum Beispiel sagt, okay, in den Kernkompetenzen ehemalige Spieler oder so, da fehlt uns vielleicht noch ein bisschen was, da holen wir noch jemanden von Extern dazu. Das heißt also, kooptierte Mitglieder, unabhängig bei Schalke und gibt es auch bei vielen anderen Vereinen, müssen sich nicht in der Mitgliederversammlung zur Wahl stellen.
Also es gibt viele verschiedene Modelle. Du wirst uns heute auch noch erklären, was man eigentlich als Aufsichtsrat so macht. Da, glaube ich, gibt es viele Klischees unter Fußballfans und vielleicht auch Journalisten. Und vielleicht weicht davon die Wahrheit ein bisschen ab. Das werden wir gleich noch erörtern. Jetzt ist aber ja das Aufsichtsrat-Dasein nichts, was man studieren könnte. Ansonsten würden, glaube ich, viele karriereorientierte Menschen das studieren. Wie bist du denn dazu gekommen?
Ja, also ich bin 2011 zum ersten Mal für drei Jahre gewählt worden. Und dazu gekommen bin ich zum damaligen Zeitpunkt über eine sehr aktive Gruppierung, Mitgliedervereinigung, dem Bündnis Aktiver Clubmitglieder, das im Vorjahr 2010 auch einen Fanvertreter, den Ralf Peisel, rein gewählt hat und 2011 dann eben überlegt hat, ob es sinnig ist, auch noch mal einen weiteren Kandidaten dort aufzustellen. Und das bin ich geworden und wurde dann auch tatsächlich gewählt. Das heißt also, der Werdegang oder wie es passiert ist, das ist relativ unspektakulär. Aber natürlich war es damals schon eine Überlegung, kann man das überhaupt, wie verhält sich das dann, was muss man überhaupt wissen, wie du schon sagst. Man kann das nicht studieren, man geht da relativ blauäugig auch rein. Und dadurch, dass ich aber immer jemand war, der wenn er was macht, 100 Prozent macht und auch ein sehr aufgeschlossener und interessierter Mensch und wenigen Dogma oder Dogmen unterliegt, sondern sehr aufgeschlossen bin, ist es schon so gewesen, dass es dann auch relativ einfach war, da reinzukommen, weil – wir kommen vielleicht später noch drauf – die Fußballwelt mit all ihren Facetten eine unheimlich spannende ist, auch schnell begeistert, die auch ihre Schattenseiten hat und die viel Moderation zwischen einzelnen Anspruchsgruppen benötigt. Das war etwas, wo ich mich schon immer wohlgefühlt habe.
Das heißt aber, du bist quasi als Fan-Vertreter hier an den Aufsichtsrat gekommen?
Ja, richtig. Als einer der Fan-Vertreter. Da habe ich auch keine Probleme, mich auch heute noch so zu nennen, auch wenn ich die Sitzungen beim Bündnis Aktiver Klubmitglieder und so nicht mehr mitgestalte, aber noch immer ein sehr gutes Verhältnis zu allen Fan-Gruppierungen haben, die irgendeine Relevanz haben, viel bei Fanclubs draußen bin und mich auch nicht so scheue, mit den Ultras zum Beispiel zu reden, ein gutes Verhältnis zu haben, weil für mich ist das einfach wichtig auch zu sagen, dass man diese Kommunikationswege immer braucht, immer offen hat, auch manchmal viel Mut und Kraft erfährt, wenn es mal nicht so läuft. Also da gibt es auch ganz viele Situationen. Gerade am Anfang musste ich da sehr knabbern, also das kann ich kurz mal einschieben. Nach meiner Wahl haben wir unterm damaligen Trainer Dieter Hecking acht Spiele nicht gewonnen. Und das ist jetzt heute lustig, aber damals war es für mich eine unheimliche, nervliche Belastung, das nicht auf das Wirken als Aufsichtsrat irgendwie zurückzuführen, dass es da jetzt eine Negativ-Serie gibt. Das klingt jetzt unheimlich komisch und die Verbindung erschließt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht sofort, aber es war einfach eine ganz harte Schule mit dieser Emotionalität, die dort herrscht, auch umzugehen, weil im anderen Bereich, in meinem Hauptberuf – ich komme aus der Musik- und Medienbranche – diese Emotionalität etwas weniger eine Rolle spielt, vor allem die negative Emotionalität nach einer Niederlagenserie. Und da haben wir auch gerade so einige Fanclubs und Fans, die inzwischen viele richtig gute Freunde geworden sind, haben mir da auch sehr geholfen und mich sehr unterstützt in so einer Zeit. Und heute ist mir das relativ egal, weil ich weiß, ich kann es nicht beeinflussen. Es war ein unheimlicher Lerneffekt, der für mich heute selbst sehr banal klingt. Damals hat es mich extrem beschäftigt, hat mich teilweise auch nicht schlafen lassen. Wenn wir wieder, also zwischen Spiel fünf und sechs, wieder nicht gewonnen haben. Und das war schon eine Sache, die ich wirklich lernen musste, damit umzugehen.
Aber woher kam denn dieser Druck? Wurdest du dann direkt von Journalisten oder vielleicht auch Vereinsmitgliedern gefragt, hey, warum läuft das nicht? Oder weil eigentlich, du hast es ja selber schon gesagt, die Verbindung erschließt sich nicht so direkt. Warum man dann in dem Moment, wo man Aufsichtsrat wird, sich dann sofort mitverantwortlich fühlt?
Also diesen Druck habe ich mir mit Sicherheit sehr stark selbst gemacht, aber zur damaligen Zeit. Ich habe ja schon gesagt, Ralf Peisel war ein Fan-Vertreter. Plötzlich kam noch ein zweiter Fan-Vertreter hinzu. Und da gab es schon den einen oder anderen Zeitungsbericht, der dann lautete, oh Gott, oh Gott, ja, jetzt zwei Fan-Vertreter im Aufsichtsrat. So, ich glaube, eine Schlagzeile war so ultra-affin oder so ultra-nahe war der Club noch nie. Ja, das hat alles ein bisschen reingespielt und tatsächlich, ich bin ein Mensch, der sich nicht unbedingt von solchen Dingen beeinflussen lässt. Ich habe mir diesen Druck schlicht selber gemacht, weil der Umgang, wie gesagt, ich kann es nur noch mal sagen, der Umgang mit dieser Emotionalität im Sport, mit Niederlagen umzugehen und vor allem als Aufsichtsrat ja vor allem das maßgebliche Gremium für mittel- und langfristige Planungen in einem Verein zu sein und sich nicht von den Kurzfristigkeiten des Sports ablenken und verleiten zu lassen. Das ist etwas, was man einen langen, harten Weg lernen muss. Da bin ich heute dankbar, dass das in den ersten acht Spielen bei mir passiert ist, weil danach war es vorbei. Das war wirklich dann durch. Ich habe heute eine Musikkollege aus Berlin. Die haben mich neulich zwei besucht, die aus dem Hip-Hop-Bereich kommen. Das war zum Pokalspiel gegen Wolfsburg. Die haben wirklich mitgefiebert, obwohl sie eigentlich gar keine clubaffinen Leute sind, sondern die haben sich anstecken lassen von dieser Pokalstimmung. Ich saß ganz ruhig da und dann sagte eine so, Mensch, was ist denn los mit dir? Du hast dir voll die Funktionärsruhe weg. Und dieses Wort, das finde ich so großartig, weil es genau das ist, was ich mir ein bisschen antrainiert habe.
Also muss das so sein, dass man sich davon distanziert?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich davon distanziere. Ich distanziere mich mit Sicherheit nicht von dem Spielgeschehen. Ich koppel mich jetzt nicht total aus im Sinne von, ist ja eh alles egal, was da unten passiert. Sondern ich nehme diese Kurzfristigkeiten des Sports – Tore, Gegentore – wesentlich gelassener hin. Und ich glaube, Funktionärsruhe trifft es da wirklich ganz gut, wenngleich ich schon zugeben muss, dass da die Emotionalität ein bisschen auf der Strecke bleibt. Also so diese Fanenthusiasmus.
Und wo schaust du denn jetzt dann die Spiele? Auch in der Funktionärsloge natürlich?
Es gibt keine Funktionärsloge. Wir haben unsere Plätze draußen, aber tatsächlich gibt es eine Lounge, wo wir uns dann alle treffen. Da bin ich richtig. Da bin ich auch auswärts. Also ich verpasse – naja, also letztes Jahr habe ich mein 34er plus die Pokalspiele vollgemacht. Dieses Jahr wird es nicht ganz klappen, aber so 30 Spiele werde ich immer gucken. Dadurch, dass ich auch sehr taktisch und ganz allgemein am Spiel interessiert ist, muss man auch gestehen, das sind die allerbesten Plätze, wo man sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gut sehen kann und sehr, sehr gut auch das Spiel so verfolgen kann. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es wirklich auch so, dass man als Aufsichtsrat inzwischen sehr viele Aufgaben administrativer Art und das Klassische mal Hände schütteln, mal hier Hallo sagen, mal da hat, die ich schon auch war und die ich auch wahrnehme und die ich auch sehr ernst nehme, muss ich ehrlich sagen, weil das ganz kleine Dinge sind, die halt auch dem Verein auf gewisse Art und Weise helfen. Ich mache aber auch sehr gerne meinen Rundgang immer durchs Stadion. Also wir haben – kann ich so erklären – wir haben seit zwei Jahren Arbeitskarten, wo ich mich frei im Stadion bewegen kann. Da laufe ich auch mal rüber in die Kurve, laufe mal zum Container vom Fanprojekt, laufe mal zum Supportersclub, sage überall mal Hallo. Und der ganz große Vorteil, das habe ich erst in dieser Saison rausgefunden, ich kann auch in den Gästeblock. Das heißt also, da wird dann die FCN-Vereinsnadel mal schnell versteckt und kann dort Freunde von anderen Vereinen besuchen. So geschehen zum Beispiel jetzt gegen Dresden oder gegen Union Berlin, wo liebe, gute, alte Fußballfreunde da waren und das war, das nehme ich mit, das ist für mich ein ganz großer Bonus, muss ich sagen.
Und was wird in dieser Aufsichtsraut-Lounge gesprochen während des Spiels? Du hast schon gesagt, du bist sehr taktikinteressiert, du bist allein dadurch schon überqualifiziert, weil du den Rasenfunk erkanntest und immer mal wieder reinhörst. So ist auch der Kontaktzustand gekommen. Aber worüber wird sich da unterhalten? Haben da auch alle die Ruhe, die du inzwischen hast?
Nein, nein. Und das fordere ich auch gar nicht ab und das wäre auch ganz schlimm. Also, es ist schon ein emotionales Treiben auch auf der Haupttribüne. Man mag das, wenn man sich grundsätzlich im Stadion woanders aufhält, Fan-Kurve, Gegengerate oder sonst irgendwo mag man das immer gar nicht so glauben, weil das ja genau die sind, die bei steht auf, wenn ihr – whatever seid – ja immer sitzenbleiben.
Ja, aber das macht ihr doch, oder? Ihr steht doch bitte auf. Oder bleibt ihr sitzen?
Na, bei uns natürlich stehen alle auf. Meistens wird das ja auch von der Haupttribüne aus initiiert. Nein, es geht dort genauso emotional zu. Am Ende ist es wirklich Fußball. Und am Ende ist es das, was uns alle an diesem Sport begeistert, das unten auf dem Rasen passiert. Und egal, wo man sitzt und egal, wie man das aufnimmt, ich glaube, von der Magie, wenn so ein Spiel plötzlich in die richtige Richtung schwappt, kann sich keiner befreien. Da ist es bei mir dann auch mit dem Muss-Funktioniers-Ruhe vorbei.
Aber gleichzeitig weißt du ja inzwischen viel, viel mehr Dinge, als du früher wusstest, wo du vermutlich noch in der Kurve standest. Ich kenne das ja selbst von der Transition vom Fan hin zum Journalisten, wo man dann auch so ein bisschen näher an die Mannschaften rankommt und auch schon Trainingseindrücke und so weiter hat. Und meinen Blick auf das Spiel hat das verändert. Und ich fand es auch immer sehr interessant, auf den Journalistenplätzen zu sitzen und zu hören, wie andere Kollegen über das Spiel sprechen und Kolleginnen. Nicht immer im Positiven, aber manchmal war es auch sehr bereichernd. Du wirst ja noch viel mehr wissen. Ändert das dann nicht auch den Blick, dass du dir denkst, ja, bei dem Spieler, wo wir jetzt die ganze Zeit schon drüber reden, ob wir den nicht abgeben wollen im Winter, und jetzt auf einmal dreht er so auf, wer hätte das gedacht?
Das war jetzt ein Fallbeispiel. Ja, natürlich verändert der Einblick in das Vereinsleben, in die Vorgänge des Vereins, und diese Gesamtheit dieser Einblicke. Das heißt also, dass dir ja gewahr ist, dass was auf dem Platz passiert, hängt mit dem, was abseits des Platzes passiert ist, zu sagen, die wirtschaftlichen Verhältnisse spielen immer rein in die Kaderplanung, die spielen immer rein in ganz banale Kleinigkeiten-Dinge, wo sind deine Scouts gerade unterwegs, wie wird die Jugendabteilung gerade koordiniert, alle diese Dinge. Die digitale Transformation spielt eine ganz große Rolle, gerade beim 1. FC Nürnberg, wo wir uns wirklich zur Prämisse gemacht haben, da ganz weit vorzukommen in allen Bereichen. Vielleicht ist das auch später jetzt nochmal ein Thema. Und das gibt einen Gesamtblick, der schon – sagen wir mal so – das, was gerade auf dem Platz passiert, zu einem Teil dieses gesamten Blickes macht. Und ich glaube, dass man sich denen auch als Funktionär, egal in welcher Position man ist, ehrenamtlicher Aufsichtsrat oder dann vielleicht auch irgendwo im Verein beschäftigt, dass man sich denen auch zu eigen machen sollte. Weil dieser Gesamtblick erlaubt eben auch ein richtiges und gutes Gesamturteil. Und das ist für mich eigentlich das Elementarste und Wichtigste, wo man auch immer noch viel lernen kann, viel dazulernen kann, sich durchaus auch innerhalb des Vereins fort- und weiterbilden kann. Und wo man immer gut daran tut, nicht immer alles gleich oder vielleicht sogar besser zu wissen, sondern auch mal zuhört und sich auch mal eingesteht, dass man nicht alles weiß. Ich weiß, das fällt manchen Leuten im Fußballgeschäft extrem schwer.
Das wäre schon mal eine nächste Frage gewesen, denn genau so geht es auf den Journalistenplätzen häufig zu. Da wussten es alle immer schon vorher, zumindest sehr viele. Wie ist es denn da bei den Aufsichtsräten?
Also, über meine Kollegen kann ich da jetzt nichts Negatives bescheinigen.
Wie könntest du?
Nein, natürlich, um Gottes Willen.
Aber du darfst gerne über andere Aufsichtsräte von anderen vereinbaren. Das ist doch sicher kein Problem.
Ich sag's mal so. Lustigerweise hast du jetzt – welchen Satz hast du – ich habe es schon immer geahnt, ich habe es schon immer gewusst – diese Richtung. Das ist noch nicht lange her, dass wir genau über diese Sache immer gesprochen haben, dieses Ich habe es schon immer gewusst und ich habe es schon immer gedacht. Das ist zum Beispiel eines der Themen, das an Aufsichtskrafttischen dann während eines Spiels gesprochen wird. Und dann habe ich gesagt, na das ist doch eigentlich ein ganz blöder Spruch, der eigentlich verboten gehört, weil ich habe es schon immer gesagt und ich habe es schon immer gewusst, wird im Fußball immer irgendwann richtig sein. Übermorgen, überübermorgen. Ich habe schon immer gesagt, dass der irgendwann mal daneben langt und dann Gegentor fällt. Und deshalb ist dieser Spruch für mich ganz, ganz schrecklich und ich versuche den also nie zu verwenden und ich würde ihn tatsächlich auch verbieten im Fußballgeschäft, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Natürlich lebt das ganze Spiel davon, dass man immer auch mal was besser weiß oder dass man schon immer mal was gesagt hat. Aber für uns als Funktionäre hat das oder für mich ganz persönlich in meiner Wahrnehmung dieses Andes zum Beispiel hat dieser Satz keine Relevanz und ich messe dem auch bei anderen relativ wenig Relevanz vor, weil für mich ist gar nicht wichtig, dass ich zum Beispiel mal anderer Meinung war als – wir nehmen jetzt ein sehr fiktives Beispiel – dass ich mal anderer Meinung bin als der Vorstand. Und der Vorstand dann aber sagt, nein, wir müssen das so machen und so, dass ich dann sage, okay, wenn es denn dann so sein soll, ich habe ja da eh keine Befugnisse, in irgendeiner Form einzugreifen. Und es würde sich dann herausstellen, dass es dann doch vielleicht nicht ganz der richtige Weg wäre. Wie gesagt, das ist ein sehr fiktives Beispiel, das ich jetzt heranziehe, mir fällt jetzt tatsächlich keins ein. Ja, ja, tatsächlich. Und ich dann hingehen würde und würde sagen, aber ich habe es doch schon immer gesagt. Mir reicht es, wenn in der Entscheidungsfindung, in dem Moment, wo eine Entscheidung getroffen wird, die oftmals nicht leicht zu treffen sind, weil sie oftmals sehr viel binnen einer kurzen Zeit entscheiden. Manche Dinge, gerade wenn es aufs Transferfenster zugeht, sind Dinge, die wirklich relativ schnell und wirklich relativ, wo du sehr entscheidungsfreudig sein musst. Und wenn jemand, der etwas zu entscheiden hat, in genau diesem Moment, in diesem Entscheidungsfenster das richtige Gefühl dafür hat, alle Abwägungen getroffen hat, die er in diesem Moment treffen kann, alle Chancen, alle Risiken für sich abgewogen hat, gesagt nein, dann wird die Entscheidung fallen, so oder so, dann ist das für mich wesentlich wichtiger, als wenn ich in zwei oder drei oder vier Wochen sagen kann, ich habe es schon immer gewusst. Und das ist für mich auch wesentlich wichtiger, als wenn dann ein Vorstand irgendwann mal drauf hören würde. So auf Strömungen und Windungen, wie komme ich da durch irgendwie, weil das ist meistens dann eine Phase oder eine Situation, in der ich dann glaube, dass Entscheidungen nicht richtiger werden in Zukunft.
Das ist vielleicht genau der richtige Punkt, um mal drüber zu sprechen, was der Aufsichtsrat eigentlich macht und in welchem Verhältnis er zum Vorstand steht. Das ist unterschiedlich von Verein zu Verein. Erklär mal, wie es beim Club ist.
Ja, also der Aufsichtsrat ganz generell ist wahrscheinlich einer der überschätztesten oder eins der überschätztesten Gremien, wenn es um die Wirkmacht in das aktuelle… Ja, das macht doch Kurzpass draus.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Siehst du, ich bin gebrieft im Rasenfunk. Also in seiner Wirkmacht, was das tagesaktuelle Geschäft betrifft, ja, weil man da auch ab und zu mal eine E-Mail kriegt oder in Fanveranstaltungen. Ja, der und der und warum habt ihr denn nicht mit dem und dem Spieler? Weil es nicht in meinen Aufgabenbereich fällt tatsächlich.
Was ist denn dein Aufgabenbereich?
Aber – und da komme ich jetzt drauf, genau – in der tatsächlichen Auswirkung, was der Aufsichtsrat wirklich beschließen kann, oftmals auch unterschätzt wird. Und das ist nicht mehr und nicht weniger als den Vorstand zu bestellen. Das heißt, der Aufsichtsrat bestellt die leitenden Personen, die beim 1. FC Nürnberg 2 sogar laut Satzung 3 sein könnten. Momentan haben wir mit Michael Mieske und Andreas Bornemann zwei Leiter Finanzen, Marketing und den rein sportlichen Bereich abgedeckt. Und das diese Kandidaten bestimmt, verpflichtet, verlängert die Verträge oder aber auch entlässt der Aufsichtsrat. Das ist also so eine der maßgeblichen Punkte, die im personellen Bereich der Aufsichtsrat entscheidet. Und das ist vielleicht auch ganz wichtig, mal zu erklären, alles, was unterhalb des Vorstandes passiert, darauf haben wir keinen Einfluss. Das sind Personalentscheidungen, die dann der Vorstand oder die jeweiligen Abteilungsleiter nach unten hin treffen.
Nur auf dem Papier keinen Einfluss oder auch in der Praxis? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, ein Vorstand, wenn er vom Aufsichtsrat bestellt wird, ist ja immer von der Gunst des Aufsichtsrats abhängig. Da wird jetzt nicht bei jeder Entscheidung sagen, was denkt ihr alle Neuen, bitte helft mal kurz die Hand, ob ich das jetzt so oder so mache. Aber da werden doch schon auch Gespräche stattfinden und man versucht ja gemeinsam in eine Richtung zu gehen als Verein.
Also für das Vereinswohl und für die Idee, die man mit einem Verein hat, ist es sehr selten der Fall, dass man einen Vorstand bestellt, der dann, wie sich nach einer Woche rausstellt, völlig konträrer auf Ideen hat, wie er sich die Vereinsführung vorstellt zum Beispiel. Tatsächlich wird sehr viel kommuniziert, wird sehr viel gesprochen und für einen Verein, gerade wie den 1. FC Nürnberg, ist es extrem wichtig, dass das Umfeld auch das Gefühl hat, dass hier ruhig und sachlich und organisiert und strukturiert gearbeitet haben. Deshalb ist das Binnenverhältnis zwischen Vorstand und Aufsichtsrat nicht anders als bei großen Firmen zum Beispiel, schon ein sehr wichtiges, dass bei aller Abhängigkeit, in Anführungsstrichen, durch die Kontrolle und die Bestellung des Aufsichtsrats immer ein sehr vertrauliches und ein sehr vertrautes Verhältnis sein muss, dahingehend, dass man sich über Gesagtes, Gesprochenes oder auch Dinge, die nicht gesagt oder gesprochen werden sollen, durchaus vertrauen kann.
Also es ist wichtig, dass das Binnenverhältnis zwischen Aufsichtsrat und Vorstand ein gutes ist, weil es auch eine Außenwirkung hat für den gesamten Verein. Jetzt stelle ich mir die Frage, wenn du mir jetzt sagen würdest, nenn mir drei gute Sportvorstände oder wer soll denn jetzt bei Verein XY Sportvorstand werden, dann würde ich sagen, ja puh, weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht, vielleicht müsste ich da 2-3 Anrufe tätigen. Jetzt ist er aber Teil deiner Aufgabe, dass du irgendwann ja auch schon in deiner Amtszeit mal einen Vorstand berufen musstest. Wie macht man sich denn da kundig? Wie laufen da die Verfahren, Auswahlverfahren? Darf ich mir das vorstellen, wie wenn ich ein Bewerbungsgespräch habe und mit einer Präsentation dann irgendwo sage, guck mal, so würde ich Unternehmen XY führen und so läuft es dann auch, wenn ihr einen Vorstand bestellt?
Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, in meiner Amtszeit musste ich das noch nicht. Noch kein einziges Mal. Weil der Wechsel des alten Vorstands auf den neuen in mein sabbatical year quasi gefallen ist und dass die Kollegen alleine übernommen haben. Tatsächlich ist es aber so, da verrate ich auch nicht so viel, dass das wirklich auch ein Verfahren ist, das man zum Beispiel vergleichen könnte, wenn in der freien Wirtschaft eine Führungsposition frei wird, wo man eventuell A. Kandidaten im Kopf hat, aber B durchaus auch Bewerbungen und Ideen dann von außen kommen. Also wenn in einem der top 36 Vereine ein Topplatz frei werden sollte, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, wird kein Verein an Kandidatenmangel oder Kandidatenarmut leiden, selbst wenn er keine einzige Person anrufen würde.
Und trotzdem stellt sich die Frage, wie man dann auswählt. Würdest du sagen, das ist jetzt auch hypothetisch, könnte ein Aufsichtsrat eines Fußballvereins bestehen aus Leuten, die noch nie mit dem Fußballgeschäft zu tun haben? Oder ist es zwingend notwendig, dass man da Leute hat, die eben auch mal die Innensicht des Fußballs erlebt haben, als Spieler, Funktionär?
Also könnte ist gar nicht mal so hypothetisch, sondern wirklich theoretisch könnte auch der Aufsichtsrat des 1. FC Nürnberg aus neun Personen bestehen, wenn sie denn turnusmäßig immer hintereinander gewählt werden, die noch kein einziges Mal im Stadion waren. Das ist jetzt natürlich eine irre Annahme, dass das wirklich passieren könnte, weil die Mitglieder ja auch durchaus ihre Fragen stellen bei den Wahlen. Aber das könnte auch passieren.
Hättest du neun gute Redner im Aufsichtsrat, denn das ist ja der nächste Punkt. Diese Aufsichtsratwahl, das ist sehr schön, dass die Mitglieder das bestimmen dürfen. Und es geht dann auch nicht anders, als dass man sagt, hier bei dieser Mitgliederversammlung, jetzt kriegt jeder mal seinen Timeslot, sagt kurz, wer er ist, und dann wird er gewählt. Aber ich habe das jetzt oft genug, zum Beispiel beim FC Bayern erlebt, da haben wir aktuell jemanden mit oben drinsitzen, der hat eine sehr, sehr launige und lustige Rede gehalten, weil man aber ganz genau hingehört hat und sich überlegt hat, was hat er denn jetzt eigentlich gesagt, außer dass er FC Bayern-Fan ist und ein lustiges Produkt herstellt? Nicht allzu viel, aber es hat gereicht, um im Sturm der Massen bestanden zu haben.
Ja, um dem vielleicht mal vorzugreifen, das ist ja auch ein Argument der vielen Kritiker, die an solchen Auswahlverfallenden, gerade wenn es um IV und Ausgliederungen und so geht, die da ja auch immer daran festhalten, dass es so ein Argument ist. Ja, da kann ja eigentlich jeder rein. Es gibt auch noch einen ganz interessanten Fall beim HSV, wo jemand wohl während der Rede sich ausgezogen hat und dann ein uraltes HSV, 80er-Jahre-Trikot noch anhatte. Und der wurde dann wirklich auch gewählt.
Und dann hast du halt neun Entertainer im Aussichtsrat.
Das kann dir grundsätzlich passieren. Aber ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, jeder, der sich zur Wahl stellt – ich kann das über meine Kollegen in Nürnberg sagen – die haben schon eine sehr deutliche und sehr klare Vorstellung, was sie da erwarten könnte. Und sie sind auch in der Form nicht so, dass sie sagen, ich weiß schon alles, das wird schon alles so laufen, sondern die auch wirklich ein hohes Maß dran haben, zu sagen, okay, wir sind da jetzt in diesem Fußballgeschäft vielleicht auch teilweise neu, aber wir haben auch ganz große Lust. Und wir haben vor allem auch den Elan und zeigen auch das Engagement, uns da reinzuarbeiten und reinzuvertiefen. Und tatsächlich war das ja für mich auch ein Grund, 2015 dann andere Wege einzuschlagen, weil ich eben auch für mich gemerkt habe, dass was ich mitbringe und dieses klassische Netzwerken, dass ich aus einem normalen Beruf kenne, dieses Vernetzen, dieses Ah-hier-mal-Hallo-Sagen, ohnehin Fußball interessiert zu sein, dass es durchaus passieren kann, dass man mich dann mal bei Duisburg gegen Preußen Münster auf der Tribüne trifft, weil ich gerade da oben in der Nähe bin. Das passiert 20 bis 25 Mal abseits der Clubspiele ohnehin. Und das ist dann schon was, wo ich aber für mich gesagt habe, ich habe einen anderen Anspruch an mich selber und an dieses Amt, dass ich auch da einen anderen Weg einschlage. Und das habe ich ja dann später mit dieser Fortbildung oder mit diesem Studium gemacht.
Genau. Lass uns mal ein bisschen chronologisch durch deine Zeit als Aufsichtsrat durchgehen, weil wir beide einen Wissensvorsprung haben gegenüber den Hörern und Hörern. Deswegen sollten wir da nicht zu sehr springen. Wie kam es denn eigentlich, dass du, du warst eben im Bündnis Aktiver Clubfans mit dabei, BAK genannt.
Clubmitglieder, ja.
Genau, Clubmitglieder. Wie kam es denn überhaupt, dass du dann derjenige sein solltest, der sich als Aufsichtsrat aufstellt, als zweiter Fanvertreter nach Ralf Preisel?
Oh, das ist eine interessante Frage. Also, ich glaube, das hat man mir irgendwann so gesagt, dass man wohl vermutet, dass ich vielleicht auch ein ganz guter Kandidat sein könnte. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe mich eigentlich schon immer sehr stark für diese Dinge abseits des Platzes interessiert. Und das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch bei den anderen Hängen geblieben, weil ich kann mir jetzt keinen anderen Grund vorstellen. Und das muss man auch dazu sagen, es muss ja immer erst mal einer Ja sagen zu so einer Kandidatur, die damals noch, sagen wir mal, schon so anders war als zum Beispiel meine letzte. Also mit transparent vor dem Stadion stehen, Infostände machen, Flyer verteilen und alles drum und dran. Das war wirklich so klassische Wahlkampf. Wahlkampf, Fanarbeit. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, ein anderer Kandidat ist damals mit so einem – also wenn ich das heute erzähle, ich habe das verdrängt, aber danke, dass du das nochmal gekommen hast. Ein anderer Kandidat ist mit einem Auto bei diesem besagten Spiel. Ich weiß, das ist ein Heimspiel gegen Mainz. Das letzte Spiel vor der Mitgliederversammlung ist er mit einem Plakatwagen außenrum gefahren. Also das war wirklich ein anderer Kandidat, hatte dann Bierfilzchen. Wenn man es heute sieht, würde es keiner von uns, die sie damals kandidiert haben, wahrscheinlich heute nochmal so machen. Aber es war 2011 wirklich State of the Art. Und im Sinne von, man hat es ja nicht besser gewusst.
Und dann hast du dich quasi vor Startung gestellt mit Infozetteln und hast jedem das…
Es haben mir ganz viele Menschen geholfen, wirklich ganz viele Fans haben mir geholfen. Wir waren Gruppen von 30, 40 Mann, genauso wie es ein Jahr vorher bei meinem Kollegen Ralf Peisel war, wo wir genau dasselbe gemacht haben und einen durchschlagenden Erfolg. Ralf wurde mit zweimal hintereinander, wo er sich zur Wahl stellte, mit den meisten Stimmen von allen gewählt, die, ich glaube, sogar immer doppelt so hoch waren, wie der zweite Steißer. Also das war schon etwas, was auch in der Nürnberger Fußball- und Fan-Kultur durchaus verankert ist, dass das schon vielleicht auch ein bisschen Sinn macht, wenn da jemand, der ein bisschen einen anderen Blick hat, vielleicht da oben mitmischt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch immer noch so, dass man das auch schon durchaus anerkennt.
Und dann hast du eben Wahlkampf gemacht. Wir haben vorhin im Intro Auszüge aus einem Video gehört. Da hast du sehr lange darüber gesprochen, warum du kandidieren möchtest. Unter anderem habe ich da das Zitat rausgepackt, dass du Bilanzen so spannend findest wie eine Mannschaftsausstellung. Und dann hast du dich ja vermutlich auch für die Mitgliederversammlung selbst vorbereitet. Kommt man da mit einer fertiggeschriebenen Rede hin? Habt man da ein paar Stichpunkte? Wie oft übt man das vor dem Spiegel?
Das muss ich jetzt wirklich überlegen. Also dadurch, ich muss sagen, ich mache ab und zu in meinem normalen Job aus der Musikbranche, habe ich damals auch immer so ein bisschen so grob Interviewtraining. So was sagst du, was machst du? Das heißt, dieses vor Leuten reden oder so, das war für mich nicht das Problem. Also das ist auch was, was ich relativ gerne mag. Wenn ich dann immer Videos von mir selber angucke, also die zweite Wahlrede, die ist da auch irgendwo noch auf KlubTV, dann wundere ich mich manchmal selbst, wie teilweise auch unsicher ich wirke. Dieses Gefühl habe ich tatsächlich selber immer nicht, aber gut, man ist mit sich selber immer kritischer. Geübt vor dem Spiegel habe ich, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht. Aber natürlich hat man sich eine Rede aufgeschrieben, man hat die eine Woche vorher, man hat den Freunden vom Bündnisaktiver Klubmitglieder natürlich mal vorgetragen, was die so sagen. Und am Morgen vor der Wahl schmeißt man sie weg und schreibt sie komplett um. Das ist mir tatsächlich schon zweimal passiert. Und dann war das ein handschriftlicher Zettel, der irgendwie stichpunktartig aufgelistet hat, was mir irgendwie wichtig ist, was ich in diese zwei Minuten reinpacken sollte. Dann, ich glaube, ich war auch der erste Redner vom Alphabet her. Es wurde alphabetisch durchgehen, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube, ich war beim ersten Mal der erste. Und plötzlich sagt der Versammlungsleiter, der Herr Lederer, übrigens, wir haben die Redezeit von zwei auf drei Minuten für die Kandidaten erhöht. Und er hat gesagt, super, Mist, jetzt habe ich alles, was ich zu Hause rausgestrichen habe, weil es nicht reinpasst, jetzt habe ich den Zettel nicht. Und so um Gottes Willen. Und dann habe ich erst mal eine halbe Minute dem Herrn Sitzungsleiter, dem Versammlungsleiter gedankt, dass er die Redezeit erhöht hat. Und dann hatte ich meine Minute fast voll. Und dann habe ich mit meinem Vortrag dann weitergemacht. Und ich kann mich an die Inhalte tatsächlich wirklich nicht mehr erinnern. Und das ist schön. Also ich hätte die Anekdote jetzt vergessen. Aber tatsächlich, das war so. Und dann fiebert man dem Ergebnis tatsächlich entgegen.
Genau. Es waren zehn Kandidaten damals 2011. Sechs davon durften eben in den Aufsichtsrat.
Das muss ich dazu erzählen, weil ich vorhin ja gesagt habe, es wird turnusmäßig gewählt. Es war damals so, dass die Besonderheit war, dass 2010 das erste Mal gewählt wurde und 2011 dann quasi dieser neuner Aufsichtsrat neu aufgefüllt werden musste, dass man dann später die turnusmäßige Variante 3-3-3 einhalten kann. Somit wurden dann 6 für 4 und 3 für 3 Jahre gewählt. Genau. Das war also eine Ausnahme, dass da sechs Kandidaten reinkommen.
Genau. Und dann hast du es geschafft auf Platz Nummer 4, damit sei der Chronistenpflichtschuldigkeit getan. Knapp hinter Günter Koch nur elf Stimmchen, haben dich getrennt vom Kultreporter, wie wir gehört haben.
Der hat auch überzogen.
Alles andere. Hätte mich auch schwer verwundert.
Es war eine leidenschaftliche Rede.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Von Günter Koch findet man auch noch einige Schnipse bei YouTube, habe ich auch noch mal reingeguckt. Und dann kommst du als Fanvertreter, als der zweite von zwei Fanvertretern in den Aufsichtsrat. Wie wurdest du da aufgenommen? Wie war die erste Sitzung?
Die erste Sitzung ist in der Regel eine sogenannte konstituierende. Das heißt, da wird noch ohne Themenkomplex besprochen, sondern da wird quasi festgelegt, wer wird der Vorsitzende, wer für zum Beispiel Protokoll später. Die ist in der Regel nach drei Minuten erledigt. Also ich war damals schon auch in einem…
Das ist nicht wie in einem Elternabend, wo sich keiner meldet und dann dauernd das nicht mehr…
könnte in drei Minuten erledigt sein. Entschuldigen, bitte. Aber bei Elternabenden und beim Fußball gestaltet sich das bisweilen anders. Und ich kann mich nur noch erinnern, dass ich mit… also es mag ein Gefühl gewesen sein, aber ich glaube, ich wurde mit sehr großer Skepsis beäugt. Weil man konnte sich unter mir so rein gar nichts vorstellen. Der Kollege Ralf Peisler…
Konntest du schon jemand von denjenigen, mit dem du dann…
Ja, den Ralf Peisler und natürlich den Günter Koch, mit dem man sich ja auch vorher schon öfters mal getroffen hat und mal ein bisschen ausgetauscht hat. Und so natürlich. Da ist auch eine ganz gute Verbindung entstanden, also im Sinne von, dass man sich wirklich über so clubaffine Dinge auch unterhalten hat. Aber ansonsten bin ich da reingekommen und hatte eigentlich wenig Vorstellungen. Ich kannte natürlich die Namen. Darüber informiert man sich ja natürlich vorher. Ich hatte so dieses Gefühl, dass man der ganz großen Skepsis obliegt. Was aber auch, wie ich später gemerkt habe, schnell verfliegt, wenn man sich dann auch wirklich einbringt. Wenn man sagt, okay, dass man wahrscheinlich keiner der Menschen ist, die Woche für Woche irgendwie in andere Städte einfallen und irgendwie in die Fahne wegnehmen oder so.
Jungen Müttern, die Babys entreißen.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Das ist dann auch relativ schnell passiert, dass über die Sach- und Facharbeit, glaube ich, da schon eine Situation entstanden ist, dass man sagt, okay, mit dem kann man ja arbeiten. Das hat mir dann ein leider verstorbener, inzwischen verstorbener Aufsichtsratskollege auch mal gesagt, ich habe immer gedacht, ihr seid die Wilden, aber mit euch kann man ja reden. Und daraus ist, glaube ich, auch eine bisweilen sehr fruchtbare Arbeit und Tätigkeit geworden. Aber ich kann mich an eine Situation erinnern, und das ist wahrscheinlich dem Wahlkampf vorher geschuldet, wie wir ihn geführt haben, dass einer der damaligen Aufsichtsratskollegen gesagt hat, ja, ihr kommt hier rein und denkt, ihr wisst alles besser. Denkt ihr, wir sind Vollidioten? Wirklich mal salopp gesprochen, hemsärmelig, und ich stand da so, ja, hier auf eurem Flyer, hier, ich mach da den und den Punkt und hier, und er so, Gott, Gott, Gott, ja, so. Ich würde auch den Wahlkampf so nicht mehr anlegen, muss ich sagen, aber das war von Skepsis geprägt, dass sich aber relativ schnell in der Tages- und Sacharbeit aufgelöst hat.
Und wie sieht dann die Tagesarbeit aus?
Ja, also, nehmen wir es mal vom zeitlichen Ablauf her. Wir treffen uns einmal im Monat zu normalen Sitzungen. Das ist im Vergleich zu anderen Aufsichtsräten in der freien Wirtschaft extrem viel. Da hat man vielleicht mal Vierteljährlich-Turnus und dann so, ja, vielleicht außerordentlich mal wegen Geschäftsbericht oder irgendeinen solchen Dingen, aber das ist schon ein sehr hoher Turnus. Und dann kommen dem Aufsichtsrat aber auch immer zu pass die jeweiligen Regeltermine, wenn es darum geht, Lizenzierung vorbereiten, Lizenzierungsunterlagen, Nachlizenzierungen, die dann alle im Kalender fix stehen, dann Vorbereitung, Jahreshauptversammlung ist auch so ein Punkt, Bestimmung des Versammlungsleiters und so, was ja teilweise schon im Juni, Juli passiert, wenn sie dann im Oktober ist. Und das ist dann immer sehr ordentlich strukturiert. Das heißt also, da verrate ich glaube ich auch nicht so viel, dass wir zu Beginn jedes Jahres, weil ja dann immer manchmal auch drei neue Kollegen da sind, einen DIN A4-Bogen bekommen mit vier, fünf Blättern über die Regeltermine und was an den Regelterminen alles wann und wo und wie besprochen werden muss. Die markantesten und die wichtigsten sind dann immer natürlich Jahresabschlussbestellungen. Das, was dann auf der Jahreshauptversammlung vorgestellt wird, dann die Lizenzierungsunterlagen rechtzeitig und korrekt einreichen. Das ist natürlich in der Verantwortung des Vorstandes, aber das ist natürlich auch was berichtpflichtig und was quasi auch vom Aufsichtsrat mitgetragen werden muss. Das ist vielleicht auch noch mal ein ganz eigenes Thema. Und dann, was für Vereine wichtig ist, ist zum 31.12. die Stichtagsregelung, umgangssprachlich negatives Eigenkapital, das immer abgebaut werden muss. Ich finde das immer großartig und spannend, wie oft man von, in Anführungsstrichen, normalen Fans darauf angesprochen wird, auf diese Themen, weil die tatsächlich in meiner Jugend – also ich bin jetzt 44 – als ich 20, 21 war, spielte das irgendwelche Klauseln, irgendwelche Lizenzerteilungen, irgendwelche Detailfragen zum Eigenkapital überhaupt keine Rolle. Und da muss ich sagen, dass das ein Wolfman und das Interesse der Fans unheimlich gewachsen. Und das freut mich auch tatsächlich, wenngleich ich nicht immer alle Fragen beantworten darf. Ja, und um das und das abzuschließen, also das negative Eigenkapital, das in der ersten Liga dann um 10 Prozent abgebaut werden muss, immer von 31.12. zu 31.12. in der zweiten Liga um 5 Prozent. Das heißt also, negatives Eigenkapital, eine bilanzielle Überschuldung. Wenn ich alles zusammenschmeiße, was mir gehört, und alles zusammenschmeiße, was anderen in meinem Verein gehört, dann kommt ein Ergebnis raus. Und wenn das ein Minus vor der Zahl hat, dann muss man immer diese prozentualen Sätze abbauen, pro Jahr.
Man bekommt auch so ungefähr einen Eindruck, dass du dich wirklich gerne in Bilanzen reinschmeißt. Wie lange würdest du denn sagen, hat das gedauert, bis du so das Gefühl hattest, jetzt fühle ich mich hier im Aufsichtsrat angekommen? Ich habe jetzt verstanden, wie die Abläufe sind. Ich habe verstanden, wo ich mich einbringen kann. Ich habe aber vielleicht auch ein paar Dinge gesehen, wo ich jetzt erst mal anderen dabei zugucke, weil die das schon länger machen.
Anderen dabei zugucken und wie gesagt, sich auch mal so Zeit nehmen, sich da reinzulesen, das ist eminent wichtig. Das sollte auch jeder tun, der von mir aus aus einem großen Wirtschaftsunternehmen kommt. Das sind aber grundsätzlich Dinge, die du, wenn du so ein Amt annimmst, auch wissen solltest, die du mitbringen solltest, weil die Fußballbranche, das lernt man relativ schnell, ist eine völlig andere als die freie Wirtschaft. Also selbst auch das Controlling in Fußballvereinen ist am Ende ein völlig anderes, als wenn ich das in der freien Wirtschaft mache.
Also bei vielen Dingen hätte ich gesagt, absolut logisch, aber so etwas wie Controlling sollte das nicht sein.
Weil es ein paar Besonderheiten gibt, grundsätzlich ja. Es gibt aber in der Betrachtung, in der Buchhalterischen, da mag ich jetzt nicht so tief ins Detail gehen, grundsätzliche Unterschiede. Zum Beispiel einen Fall, dass man zum Beispiel vieler Spieler in die Bilanz schreiben kann. Also wenn man die mit Transfer-Ausgaben geholt hat, kommen die in die Bilanz. Das ist ja auch inzwischen, das weiß das ja auch schon jeder Fan.
Dann schreibt man schön ab über die Vertragslaufzeit.
Ganz genau, und schreit die über die Vertragslaufzeit ab. Was passiert aber mit einem Spieler, den der Verein umsonst holt, der vielleicht auch ein Leistungsträger und ganz toll ist. Der steht nämlich nicht drin, weil, also milchmädchenhaft gerechnet, weil nur die, die wirklich Bilanzaufwand haben, haben für unbekannte Kosten. Richtig. So. Und das sind so kleine Besonderheiten, wie man dann damit umgeht. Dann haben, was in der freien Wirtschaft auch gar keine so große Rolle spielt, die stillen Reserven natürlich eine völlig andere Gewichtung. Weil ein Spieler, den ich umsonst hole, der ist dann doch was wert, wenn ich ihn möglicherweise weitertransfuriere. Also wir haben ja heute, Stand heute, einen sehr prominenten Neuzugang beim FC Bayern. Genau.
Das sind alle, die wir aufgezeichnet haben, wenn du nachguckst.
Ja, richtig.
Das ist eine stille Reserve gewesen.
Aber eine extreme, ja. Und das ist halt auch etwas, wo man sich da noch ein bisschen reinfinden muss. Aber ich habe noch keinen meiner Kollegen erlebt, der da gesagt hat, das weiß ich alles schon. Im Endeffekt sind das Leute, die das schon wissen, die das mitbringen. Und dass man sich da ein bisschen reinfuchsen muss. Am Ende ist es dann auch wirklich gar nicht so schwer. Wenn man aber sagt, wie lange es dauert, sich da reinzufinden in den Aufsichtsratsposten, was ja die Ausgangsfrage war, dann habe ich bei mir ganz persönlich eine andere Sache sehr zu knabbern gehabt. Und zwar die emotionale Schiene. Das heißt also, dieses mittel- und langfristig angelegte Denken für den Verein als Aufsichtsrat zu arbeiten, abzukoppeln oder weitestgehend abzukoppeln von sehr kurzfristigen Ereignissen. Und die kurzfristigen Ereignisse sind im Endeffekt immer die Spiele, die am Wochenende stattfinden. Und da den Switch hinzukriegen, das hat sehr, sehr lange für mich gedauert. Weil ich muss dazu sagen, ich wurde damals Aufsichtsrat, wie gesagt, mit Günter Koch zusammen. Und die ersten acht Spiele nach unserer Wahl haben wir nicht gewonnen. Und ich kann das, also heute lache ich auch ein bisschen drüber. Oder ich sehe es entspannter als damals. Aber ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe mir das extrem zu Herzen genommen.
Das waren die schlaflosen Nächte von dir zuvor.
Schlaflose Nächte, wirklich. Also heute kann ich es selber nicht mehr begreifen, weil ich ja überhaupt keine Möglichkeit hatte, da einzuwirken. Und selbst wenn mir Dieter Hecking damals Fußballschuhe gegeben hätte und sagt, zieh dich um, ich hätte ja auch schwerlich helfen können. So ehrlich muss man ja auch sein.
Von wie verbucht man dann bitte ein Aufsichtsratmitglied, was dann auf einmal im Spielermaterial mit drin ist? Ist das eine stille Reserve oder ein Verlustvortrag?
Also Verlust könnte richtig sein. Vornehmlich erst mal beim Ergebnis, ja. Und das hat mir unheimlich zugesetzt zu schaffen gemacht. Das haben auch meine Arbeitsgelegenheiten damals gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, was ist denn los mit dir? Du wirst immer unerträglicher. Ich glaube, dieses Amt tut dir nicht gut. Es war auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich das heute überlege, eine unheimlich gute Schule zu wissen, das darf dich nicht berühren, auch wenn das manchmal kalt ist oder kühl oder entemotionalisiert. Aber diese Dinge, diese kurzfristigen Sachen dürfen dich, wenn du eine Idee hast und wir als Aufsichtsrat, als gemeinsamer Verein eine Idee tragen, die diesen Verein aus einer sehr schwierigen Lage in die Zukunft führen soll, dann darf dich das nicht belasten, dann darf dich das nicht irritieren. Und das hat wirklich nicht nur diese acht Spiele gedauert. Wir haben dann ja auch irgendwann mal wieder gewonnen. Das hat auch ein bisschen länger gedauert, aber es war eine unheimlich gute Schule.
Und wie war das mit den Themen, die du da platziert hast? Als Fanvertreter bist du ja, du bist ja nicht nur für dich im Aufsichtsrat, sondern als Vertreter der Mitglieder, die dich gewählt haben. Und bestimmt hattest du ja auch einige Punkte auf der Agenda, mit denen du reingegangen bist in die ersten Sitzungen. Standst du da gleich mit dem Bengale und hast gesagt, Pyrotechnik ist kein Verbrechen?
Oh, da hast du jetzt für einige Lacher gesorgt, gerade bei den Ultras, die zuhören, weil die nämlich wissen, dass ich selbst an Silvester kein Feuerwerk anfasse.
Okay, also das nicht.
Ja, das war – ne, ich glaube, das wäre auch blöd gekommen, irgendwie geschlossene Räume und so. Das wäre schwierig gewesen. Nein, tatsächlich hört man da erst mal zu. Tatsächlich findet man sich da erst mal rein. Tatsächlich kriegt man dann die erste Tagesordnung. Man weiß dann, okay, wie kann man Punkte auf die Tagesordnung setzen. Man kriegt ja eine interne Geschäftsordnung, die nicht öffentlich ist, die quasi den internen Verkehr, Prozesse regelt innerhalb des Aufsichtsrats, aber auch mit Vorstand zum Beispiel. Und da hört man dann erst mal zu. Und die Fan-Meinungen, die habe ich ja bis heute ehrlich gesagt nicht abgelegt. Ich habe sie vielleicht in Teilen differenziert, weil indem du dich in diesem Fußballbereich bewegst, nicht nur in dem Fan und das, was das Spiel ausmacht, sondern in dem, ja, ganz, ganz, wirklich so gesagt das Fußballgeschäft. Und wenn ich Fußballgeschäft oder Fußballbusiness, dann meine ich immer so diese wirklich geschäftige Seite, die wirtschaftliche Seite, die Vermarktungsseite. Und je mehr man da rein sich versetzt, je mehr man da auch Lust hat, sich reinzuarbeiten, desto differenzierter sieht man etwas, was tatsächlich auch im Laufe der Zeit dazu geführt hat, dass ich durchaus auch sehr kritische Nachfragen von Fansite immer mal bekommen habe, wo ich mich denn ja irgendwie jetzt mal von irgendwelchen Positionen verabschiedet habe. Das ist tatsächlich bis heute nicht der Fall gewesen, aber diese differenzierte Sichtwege, die taugt halt nicht für radikale oder irgendwie einseitige Ansichten.
Ja, das ist ja immer so, dass auf dieses Phänomen alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und – Hörer stoßen. Ich hoffe auch in jeder einzelnen Sendung, dass die Differenzierung es schwieriger macht, eindeutige Positionen zu beziehen. Aber trotzdem stelle ich mir das so vor, wenn ich jetzt beim FC Bayern im Aussichtsreis säße, ich hätte sofort fünf, sechs Themen, wo ich sagen würde, bitte erklärt mir jetzt erst mal, warum macht der Verein das, und dann hört mir bitte mal fünf Minuten zu, warum ich finde, dass man zum Beispiel nicht nach Katar ins Trainingslager fahren muss, dass man nicht nach jedem Tor bei 140 Dezibel eine Tormelodie aufdreht. Das waren ja schon mal zwei Punkte des Programms Max. Und ich hätte noch ein paar weitere gehabt. Wie war das denn bei dir?
Du darfst diese Fragen gerne stellen, aber – und wir kommen jetzt wieder auf diese Wirkmacht – du hast auf das tagesaktuelle Geschehen grundsätzlich erst mal keinen Einfluss.
Auch auf dieses Umfeld der Spiele. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, auf den sportlichen Bereich hat man als Aufsichtsrat…
Ganz grundsätzlich liegt das, was in der Verantwortung des Vorstandes und dann unterrangig in der Verantwortung der Abteilungsleiter etc. pp. liegt, nicht in der Verantwortung des Aufsichtsrates.
Das heißt, du müsstest mit dem Vorstand sprechen, der für den jeweiligen Berat?
Was im Endeffekt auch der richtige Weg ist für einen Aufsichtsrat. Ich kann dann nur für uns sprechen, da sind die Vorstände relativ offen, sich jedem Thema anzu-eigenen, auch wenn es ein bisschen leidenschaftlicher wird, gerade wenn es Fan-Themen sind. Aber das ist dann quasi der richtige Weg. Ein Aufsichtsrat, ein Einzelner, wird nicht verhindern, dass der FC Bayern nach Doha ins Trainingslager fährt, zum Beispiel. Auch wenn man das in irgendeiner Art und Weise fragwürdig, merkwürdig oder zumindest nachfragenswert, warum denn das so ist.
Genau, es geht mir auch gar nicht gleich ums Verhindern, sondern erst mal ums Verstehen und um mal die anderen Argumente hören, die einem selbst ja dann irgendwann gar nicht mehr einfallen. Weil man hat ja so irgendwie seine Perspektive und es ist auch unglaublich schwer, ein Thema ohne eigene Meinung zu betrachten. Es ist eigentlich, wenn man ehrlich zu sich selbst ist, fast unmöglich, dass man das wirklich schafft. Mir ging es also gar nicht gleich um, den kompletten Verein umzukrempeln. Aber es gäbe so viele Fragen, die ich gerne stellen würde. Und so wird es dir dann auch gegangen sein.
Diese Fragen werden grundsätzlich immer alle auch beantwortet. Teilweise halt im nüchthöffentlichen Teil. Und das ist auch etwas, was man sich bewahren sollte. Also diese Fragen zu stellen, weil wenn man nie diesen Fragen schwanger geht, dann kriegt man eben nicht draus, warum wird so gedacht. Warum gibt es da ein tieferes Verständnis? Im Falle von DOH habe ich vielleicht so eine grobe Idee irgendwie, warum. Da könnte er eher im monetären Bereich liegen.
Im positiven Eigenkapital, ehrlich gesagt.
Genau, aber das ist ja gemutmaßend. Jetzt hast du mir sogar noch eine Meinung zu einem Vorfall der Bayern.
Ja, da siehst du mal, wie das geht. So sind sie, die Systemmedien. Die führen einen da aus Glatteis. Aber gab es denn da auch mal so Aha-Momente, wo du dir gedacht hast, ach Wahnsinn, so habe ich da drüber noch nie nachgedacht, ist ja interessant. Also kannst du dich da noch an was erinnern, wo sich deine Perspektive richtig krass erweitert hat und vielleicht sogar deine eigene Position komplett verändert?
Es war eine Situation zweimal, eine vor kurzer Zeit erst, die allerdings in den sportlichen Bereich tatsächlich gefallen sind. Eine ist länger zurück, die hat mit Dieter Hecken zu tun. Da bin ich ihm heute noch sehr dankbar, weil ich mal gesagt habe, ich hatte immer große Hemmungen, obwohl ich mich für Taktik und für das Spiel schon sehr interessiere, mir das irgendwann mal eingeeignet habe. Ich war selber ein miserabler Fußballer, dass irgendwann mal mit der A-Jugend in der zweithöchsten Spielklasse, sogar mit unserer Dorfmannschaft, bis dann irgendeiner Muster gemerkt hat, dass ich da nicht hingehöre. Und dann war es auch schnell vorbei. Aber ich habe mir das zu Herzen genommen, dass – und Slaven Bilic hat das, glaube ich, in irgendeinem Elf-Freunde-Interview gesagt, wenn du in der fünften Klasse Fußball-Taktik unterrichtest, hast du in der zehnten Klasse perfekt ausgebildete Personen, die Fußball-Taktik von vorne bis hinten erklären können. Das hat mich dann fasziniert, das hat mich gereizt, so ein bisschen dieses Rasenschach. Ich habe mich immer gescheut, aber in dem sportlichen Bereich damals eine Frage zu stellen. Ich meinte, oh Gott, wenn ich da jetzt eine Frage stelle, dann denkt er doch, der Ehrenberg hat nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank. Was ist denn das hier? Und ich habe mich dann mal getraut, mit Dieter Hecking eine Frage zu stellen. Das würde jetzt zu weit führen, das war wirklich so ein philosophisches Deckungsverhalten, irgendwas. Und der Dieter Hecking hat sich dann bei uns in der Gaststätte am Pfalz Navaja hingesetzt, so hinsetzen, trinkt jetzt einen Kaffee und der hat mir das eine halbe Stunde erklärt. Und dafür bin ich ihm heute noch sehr dankbar, weil das wirklich so ein Schlüssel-und-Aha-Moment ist. Und ich glaube, im Nachhinein hat er Dieter Hecking damals auch gedacht, so ganz blöd war die Frage ja auch nicht, weil die Antwort dementsprechend freundlich ausgefallen ist. Dieter Hecking war auch jemand, der gesagt hat, wenn irgendwas… Also, glaube ich, habe ich ganz gut abgeschnitten. Und die andere Geschichte, die war erst wirklich vor kurzem, weil ich mich dann halt auch so ein bisschen interessiert habe, wie läuft denn das irgendwie mit Spielbeobachtungen und allem Drum und Dran? Das ist sehr einhergehend mit unserer Idee, digitale Transformation des Vereins, was man alles machen kann, dass ich da wirklich unser Spielanalyster und unser Sportvorstand sehr viel Zeit genommen hat, mir das zu erklären. Und das ist bisher aber auch bei allen anderen Bereichen so gewesen. Und ich glaube auch, so dieses Miteinander, das hat auch nichts von irgendeiner Kumpelai oder Kumpanei zu tun oder so irgendwelche Seilschaften oder Netzwerke zu schmieden, sondern das hat einfach schlicht und ergreifend damit, glaube ich, zu tun, dass man schon merkt, dass ich in vielen Bereichen sehr offener, sehr aufgeschlossener, undogmatischer Mensch bin, undogmatisch im besten Sinne, nicht keine Idealehabe, aber auch keine extremen Dogmenvertrete. Dass es halt einfach auch Sinn macht, sich mit mir über Dinge zu unterhalten.
Jetzt hast du ja auch einiges im sportlichen Bereich erlebt. Also du hast schon angesprochen, die acht Spiele ohne Sieg, da wollen wir jetzt nicht gleich wieder darauf zurückkommen, aber ich sehe einen sechsten Platz in der ersten Liga, das war das erfolgreichste Jahr. Der DFB-Pokalsieg dürfte ja auch in deine Zeit gefallen sein.
Nein, der war vier Jahre vorher, 2007.
Ach stimmt, da war ich ja noch in Freiburg. Ich habe gerade die DFB-Pokalsiege verwechselt. Aber es gab zum Beispiel auch einen recht überraschenden Wechsel von Dieter Hecking zum VfL Wolfsburg. Und jetzt wissen wir ja schon, das ist nicht dein zentraler Bereich und trotzdem ist das ja der Kern dessen, um das sich alles dreht. Ihr könnt das tollste Konzept für den Club haben. Wenn die Mannschaft Viertliga-Fußball spielt, dann wird man in der Vierten Liga landen über kurz oder lang. Da kann er nicht mehr die Relegation allzu häufig retten. Was waren denn da die interessantesten Momente und wie hast du die dann auch anders erlebt in deiner neuen Rolle?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich muss jetzt kurz mal grob sagen, also die ersten Jahre sind ja sportlich durchaus erfolgreich verlaufen. Wie gesagt, es war ein Zehntelplatz, ein Sechsterplatz und nochmal ein Zehntelplatz, glaube ich, wenn ich da wirklich noch drin habe. Das ist auch so ein Phänomen, nur ganz kurz eingestreut. Ich kann meine ersten sechs Spiele und die erste Saison, die ich beim Club dann fix war, 1983, das allererste Mal, kann ich noch 100 beten, aber ich kann dir keine Ergebnisse der Letzten, der Vorletzten oder überhaupt meiner Amtszeit, wirklich keine fünf Ergebnisse. Außer den Derbysieg, den kriege ich noch zusammen. Aber das ist so ein Nebeneffekt.
Das ist aber normal. Ich kann mich auch in den letzten Spieltag nicht mehr erinnern, aber dafür, was ich in den 90ern als 12-Jähriger gesehen habe.
Okay, wenn das normal ist, dann mache ich mir zumindest jetzt schon mal…
Ich glaube, das ist normal für Leute, die sich viel mit Fußball beschäftigen. Ich kenne ganz wenige Leute, die von sich behaupten würden, ich habe ein Fußball-Elefanten-Gedächtnis. Sondern die Leute, die sich viel damit beschäftigen, haben zwar zum Teil eins, aber würden es nie von sich sagen, sondern sagen immer, ne du, wie hat letztes Wochenende Werder gegen Hoffenheim gespielt? Hm, da muss man jetzt mal kurz überlegen. Aber damals, wie wir 94 im DFB-Pokal zweite Runde gespielt haben, das kann ich dir noch sagen. Das ist typisch. So, ich habe dich unterbrochen. Also ein Sechster und zwei Zehnte. Das ist richtig deine sportliche Bilanz, für die du alleine verantwortlich bist.
Jaja, das ist schön. Man muss dazusagen, wenn man heute Sechster Platz hört, muss man nochmal… Sechster Platz, Erste Liga A und B. Leider berechtigte dieser Platz damals nicht zum Europapokal. Sonst wären wir da auch nochmal europäisch gewesen. Ja, das war für den 1. FC Nürnberg eine erfolgreiche Zeit. Auch dahin geht es, dass man sagt, okay, wir sind auf dem Weg der Konsolidierung. Wir hatten damals unheimliche Transferüberschüsse auch geleistet. Wir hatten also wirklich, was man heute den ehemaligen Vorstellenden nicht mehr wirklich so zubilligt. Aber wir hatten damals wirklich Transferüberschüsse, die aber alle wieder in den kompletten Spielbetrieb, in den kompletten Etat reingeflossen sind. Das heißt also dieses Jahr noch ein Jahr und nächstes Jahr und dann wird man nochmal konsolidieren. Das war immer getrieben von der Zeit und getrieben von den Umständen, dass du den Etat in der 1. Liga immer ganz massiv strecken musstest, um auch mitspielen zu können. Und wir trotzdem immer, ich glaube einmal in dieser Amtszeit bis zum Abstieg 13, 14, ich glaube mal den vierten oder fünf niedrigsten Etat nur hatten, ansonsten immer in den letzten zwei oder drei zwei niedrigsten Etats uns da so platziert haben. Und ja, das war wie gesagt eine Zeit, in der man dann auch relativ viel gelernt habe. Ich, wie gesagt, durch meinen Job hat dann auch immer so ein bisschen Netzwerk geschaffen, hatte diesen und jenen kennengelernt bei Auswärtsspielen, weil ich muss sagen, ich bin einer der Kollegen, die relativ häufig dann auch dabei waren. Das heißt also so eine 30er Saison, wie man unter Fans sagt, ist für mich eigentlich normal. Die letzte Saison war sogar eine 34er plus Pokal.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich eher Ausnahme unter Aussichtsräten, oder? Das ist ja auch ein Ehrenamt.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Ehrenamt bei uns und es ist auch nicht notwendig oder zwingend, oder dass man daraus was ableiten könnte im Sinne von, naja, wenn ich jetzt weniger Spiele besuche, habe ich weniger Ahnung von dem Job. Also das ist mitnichten damit gemeint oder gesagt, aber für mich war das immer wichtig, a, weil es mich interessiert hat, b, weil ich halt auch in diese Fußballwelt einfach mal ein bisschen einsteigen wollte und mal Leute kennenlernen wollte und dieses Ganze, da bin ich wieder beim Geschäft, beim geschäftlichen Teil und geschäftlichen Teil, weil ich auch das verstehen und kapieren wollte. Wann, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich bin da reingestellt und gesagt, wie lange dauert es eigentlich, bis man da drin ist in dem Geschäft. Ich habe abseits dieser emotionalen Geschichte mit den acht Spielen relativ schnell gelernt, dass ich noch zu wenig weiß und zu wenig helfen kann, weil ich ja noch gar niemanden kenne in diesem ganzen Netzwerk und weil ich die Hintergründe, warum gewisse Dinge passieren, auch bestenfalls er ahnen kann und nicht weiß. Das hat er dann in einer anderen Sache gemündet, auf die kommen wir dann ja sicherlich noch. Und das war mir immer wichtig und da bin ich auch relativ fleißig auswärts mitgefahren und habe mir da so mein eigenes Netzwerk geschaffen. Für ein kurzes Jahr war auch der Manfred Müller, Manny Müller, der ja auch hier in München noch durchaus ein Begriff sein dürfte. Mein Kollege, mit dem habe ich mich relativ schnell gemerkt, dass ich mit dem absolut auf einer Ebene bin. Der war A, Profifußballer und war B, durch seine Tätigkeit im Film- und Medienbereich für die Bundesliga mit seiner damaligen Firma Übertragungswagen und so, ja auch richtig in diesem Geschäft drin. Und von der Freundschaft, muss ich ehrlich sagen, wir grüßen uns heute auch noch sehr herzlich und halten uns lange, wenn wir uns sehen, habe ich sehr profitiert, weil der gemerkt hat, ah, da ist so ein junger Typ, der ist eigentlich ganz okay. Und dann hat er mir halt mal in Gladbach so die ganze Entourage vorgestellt. Und dann waren wir in Wolfsburg und da hatte ich mir den und den und so, guck mal, der ist interessant, das ist der von der DFL, schau dir das an und komm, da gehen wir mal hin und so. Und davon habe ich unheimlich profitiert und da bin ich, Manni Müller, wenn er es hört, ich schicke ihm auch einen Link, da bin ich ihm unheimlich dankbar, wirklich.
Und Herr Müller, ich suche noch Gäste für den Rasenfunk. Ich habe gehört, Sie haben ein tolles Netzwerk.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das für den Rasenfunk, eigentlich bräuchte das mal jemand. Ich stell dir mal die alle hier vor und sag denen, dass du nicht total ätzend bist und dann fällt was runter. Aber wir wollen ja gar nicht über mich sprechen. Aber wir kamen ja eigentlich vom Sportlichen. Ein Sechster, zwei Zehnte Plätze, das war so in der ersten Phase deines Aussichtsratsdaseins. Unter anderem, du hast angesprochen, dass man da Transferüberschüsse generieren könnte. Philipp Wollschalt ist gewechselt zu Leverkusen, Eker Gündoğan ist gewechselt zu Dortmund. Das sind so zwei der größten Transfers gewesen in dieser Zeit. Wie ist es überhaupt, so einen Spielerwechsel mal so zu verfolgen, dass man nicht lange in der Presse liest, es gibt Gerüchte und dann irgendwann nährt man sich gegenseitig an, sondern über sowas werdet ihr ja frühzeitig informiert?
Ja, das kann man so sagen. Also wir sind tatsächlich sehr nahe dran an dem Geschehen, was sich eventuell so tut und spätestens, wenn es dann, qua Geschäftsordnung auch berichtspflichtig ist. Das heißt also, es gibt zustimmungspflichtige Geschäfte, bei denen der Aufsichtsrat gerade bei Ausgaben zustimmen muss. Und es gibt informationspflichtige Geschäfte, bei denen der Vorstand der Aufsichtsrat darüber informiert, dass eine Geschäftstätigkeit ansteht oder abgeschlossen wurde. Und Transfers, die rausgehen, das heißt Spiele, die uns verlassen sind, Letzteres, weil da geht es ja quasi um die Einnahmen.
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Gibt es da eine Rundmail und da schreibt dann der aktuelle Sportvorstand hey Leute, wollte ich nur sagen, also Philipp, der wechselt jetzt zu Leverkusen. Gibt es da eine WhatsApp-Gruppe? Schreibt ihr euch Briefe?
Jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, ob ich dir das sagen darf. Aber ich glaube, ich sage kein Geheimnis, dass der nächste Weg, der, der gerade am nächsten ist, auch genutzt wird. Das kann auch, wenn man unterwegs ist, wenn es schnell geht, muss kurz mal ein Telefonat sein. Das kann auch die Rundmail sein, absolut anerkanntes Mittel. Das kann aber auch zum Beispiel in der Regelsitzung im Vortrag des Sportvorstands passieren.
Okay, das heißt, ich komme aber ohne ein Fax durch meinen Dasein als Aufsichtsrat, ja?
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar alle noch Faxe, mindestens in der Firma stehen. Aber ja, da kommt man durch. Und das, also man sollte, wenn man sich für so einen Post entscheidet, ich kann jeden nur ermutigen, der sich dafür für Berufen hält, man sollte aber der Kommunikation, der modernen Kommunikation nicht abgeneigt sein.
Ach, das kommt auf den Verein an. Dass wir das von jemandem sagen, der sehr nah an der selben Straße positioniert ist.
Also hier E-Mail ausdrucken lassen und dann…
Genau, also es reicht auch einfach eine digitalaffine Sekretärin oder ein digitalaffiner Sekretär. Gut, aber wie ist das eben, so ein Wechsel schon sehr frühzeitig mitzubekommen, auch ja mit der Verantwortung, dass man einer von neun plus x Personen ist, die darüber auch bitte keinerlei Wort verliert in keiner Runde?
Ja, also das werde ich oft gefragt und ich werde auch bei vielen Fanveranstaltungen, ist auch dieses kritisch, dass ich da früher sehr oft und sehr häufig auf diese Verschwiegenheitspflicht, ja das ist ja, da muss man ja mal was sagen und wie soll man denn als Aufsichtsrat was sagen, wenn einem was nicht passt und dann hat man ja Verschwiegenheit, dann kann man das ja gar nicht sagen irgendwie. Also ja, das ist aber, das weiß jeder spätestens dann, wenn er seine Geschäftsordnung gelesen hat, dann hat er immer noch die Chance, sozusagen, ach, nee, vielleicht doch nicht ganz meins. Und das gehört zum ganz elementaren Teil dieser Tätigkeit. Sie ist aber jetzt auch kein auferliegtes Schweigegelübde in der Form, weil jeder kennt aus seiner beruflichen, aus seiner privaten Tätigkeit Dinge, die er nicht dem allererst besten einfach auf die Nase bindet.
Ja, das stimmt, aber der Unterschied ist, dass man im normalen Privatleben auch nicht so häufig über seine Arbeit gefragt wird. Das spricht, andere verdienen nicht ihr Geld damit, dass sie täglich vor meiner Haustür stehen und sagen, lieber Max, was hast du denn heute in deinem Beruf gemacht? Also wir reden ja hier auch über Medien, die natürlich den Kontakt zu dir suchen. Da muss man sich schon häufig auf die Zunge beißen.
Auf das Tagesgeschäft angesprochen, kann man das sehr einfach, und das wissen leider deine Medienkollegen in Nürnberg auch, sehr schnell dadurch vereinfachen, indem man sagt, wenn Sie sich bitte an die Pressestelle, wenn Sie sich bitte an den Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden, wenden Sie sich bitte an den Vorstand. Das ist der normale Weg, und das kamen gerade in der Anfangszeit ganz viele ganz häufig von mir zu hören.
Was ja auch der richtige Weg ist, dennoch kursieren bei einzelnen Vereinen immer wieder Gerüchte. Es gibt ja unglaublich viele Quellen, also rund im Fußballbusiness. Das ist ja also jetzt inzwischen wurde es vielleicht vom Weißen Haus vom aktuellen übertroffen, aber lange Zeit hätte ich gesagt, der Fußball ist der Bereich, in dem man am häufigsten anonymisierte Zitate zu hören bekommt, die es dann auch tatsächlich so gab, die nicht ausgedacht sind. Und ein mögliches Informationsleck in ganz vielen Vereinen ist immer der Aufsichtsrat oder die entscheidenden Gremien, das wird denjenigen immer unterstellt. Ich will das nicht bewerten, weil ich weiß es nicht. Man hört das immer nur so. Jetzt kannst du sicherlich nicht für den Aussichtsrat des HSV zum Beispiel sprechen, aber ja, für den Club gibt es dieses Klischee in Nürnberg auch?
Das Klischee hält sich, glaube ich, in der Fußballwelt so ganz allgemein. Und es rührt daher vielleicht auch ein bisschen, weil es beim Aufsichtsrat durchaus möglich ist, dass Menschen, die aus der freien Wirtschaft kommen, die auch Fanvertreter sind, die aber in der Regel nicht so geübt darin sind, dass sie, wie gesagt, von Journalisten belagert werden und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit machen müssen, dass daher auch viele dieser Dinge rühren. Pauschal kann man das, glaube ich, so nicht sagen, weil ich glaube, wenn diese einfache Direktive, die vielleicht auch manchmal schwer ist, weil man halt auch sagt, oh Gott, oh Gott, weil in der Zeitung kann ja auch stehen, hat keine eigene Meinung, hat nichts dazu gesagt, wenn du jemanden weiterleitest. Es gibt ja immer so diesen und jenen Kniff. Aber das ist einfach wirklich, und das muss ich sagen, also bei uns in Nürnberg hat jeder die Chance gehabt, nachdem er das weiß und nachdem er das gesehen hat, auch zu sagen, nee, das ist leider nicht meine Welt, das möchte ich leider so nicht. Ja, ich möchte dann immer doch noch eine andere Öffentlichkeitsarbeit wahrnehmen, als ich das als Aufsichtsrat tun müsste, und dann wäre das auch schnell erledigt, wenn das tut natürlich auch keiner.
Und andererseits ist ja vermutlich Aufsichtsrat sein auch ein bisschen Politik. Also auch wenn wir hier von einem Ehrenamt sprechen, man darf weitreichende Entscheidungen treffen und überall, wo weitreichende Entscheidungen getroffen werden, prallen ja verschiedene Typen von Menschen aufeinander. Und da gibt es doch bestimmt auch – wird das thematisiert im Aufsichtsrat, wenn zum Beispiel Informationen dann doch mal irgendwie durchgesickert sind? Redet man über sowas offen? Wird man für sowas vielleicht auch vom sportlichen Vorstand dann – na, zur Rechenschaft kann er nicht ziehen, weil da ist das Beziehungsverhältnis das Falsche. Aber geht man mit sowas offen um? Wie wichtig ist Berichterstattung für ein Aufsichtsrat?
Also ich kann jetzt natürlich nicht für den 1. FC Nürnberg sprechen, weil da immer alles sauber und ordentlich ist. Aber ich würde sagen, dass man sowas tatsächlich offen und ehrlich ansprechen sollte. Weil es ja für solche Dinge grundsätzlich dann immer Gründe geben würde. Und wichtig ist ja nicht, dass irgendwo mal irgendwas rausgeflossen ist. Wie gesagt, es gibt Vereine, die sind damit wirklich… Ja, also ich nenne jetzt wirklich auch keine Namen, weil das nicht dispektierlich ist. Ich kenne dann auch zwei, drei aus den jeweiligen Vereinen, die aber dieser Problematik extrem zu kämpfen hatten. Also auch emotional und mental für sich selbst. Dass man von einem Sitzungstisch aufsteht und es zwei Minuten später online in der Lokalpresse steht. Dinge, die nicht funktionieren. Wenn es dann mal so weit ist, dann gibt es auch keine Reißleine oder sonst irgendwas mehr. Aber wichtig ist ja der Grund, warum so etwas passiert. Das wäre mir wesentlich wichtiger in der Aufarbeitung solcher Dinge, wenn es denn da passieren sollte, als dass dann wirklich Dinge passiert sind, die ohnehin nicht mehr zurückdrehen müssten. Indiskretionen im Fußball. Ich glaube, das ist auch etwas, was jetzt keine Erfindung der Neuzeit ist. Das ist durchaus etwas, mit dem die Branche ja grundsätzlich auch immer ein kleines bisschen leben muss.
Aber wie ist denn das zum Beispiel im Verhältnis zu Journalisten? Haben dich dann auf einmal Leute angerufen, nachdem du Aufsichtsrat war, von denen du vorher vielleicht höchstens mal Texte gelesen hast, aber so noch gar nichts zu tun hattest? Versuchen da auch vielleicht Leute in ein, sagen wir, freundschaftliches Verhältnis zu dir zu kommen, in der Hoffnung, dass du halt mal ein bisschen mehr verrätst?
Nein, das ist tatsächlich nicht passiert, weil ich relativ früh dann halt auch immer darauf verwiesen habe, auf den normalen Weg. Das heißt also, dass es bei uns ganz klare Kommunikationswege nach außen gibt. Und ja, wenn Aufsichtsräte abseits des Tagesgeschäfts, wo dann der Vorsitzende spricht oder einer der Vorsitzenden dann was zu sagen haben, dann wird das ja auch immer klar interdisziplinär im Verein geregelt. Das heißt also, so blöd das klingt, aber dass ich heute hier sitze, das weiß der Verein und das wird ja auch soweit…
Sonst ruft ja jemand bei mir an, das will ja auch.
Ja.
Wobei, andererseits, wenn man Bundesliga-Fallende bei mir anrufen hat. Bist du dann auch innerhalb des Aufsichtsrats derjenige, der dann für sowas stellvertretend Stellung beziehen muss? Denn ein bisschen bist du ja die Brücke von den Fans zum Aufsichtsrat, zumindest am Anfang deiner Tätigkeit war das ja sicher so.
Ja, ist es auch heute noch so. Also das wird vielleicht von Fanseiten jetzt ein bisschen mehr unterschätzt oder sagen wir mal so vielleicht nicht mehr so ganz in den Fokus gerückt. Aber für mich ist das natürlich immer noch ein elementarer Bestandteil. Das hängt aber nicht damit zusammen, dass ich jetzt Fan spreche oder ich weige mich nicht, ich wehre mich nicht gegen das Wort Fanvertreter, aber ich sehe das in einem Gesamtkontext für mich, wie ich den Fußball ganz allgemein sehe und liebe. Und in diesem Fußballkontext hat alles seinen Platz. Da hat der Kommerz seinen Platz, da haben die Medien ihren Platz, da hat der PTV-Anbieter seinen Platz, da hat der digitale Rechteauswärter seinen Platz, da haben aber und nicht zuletzt und vor allem auch die Fans und die Kurve ihren Platz. Und aus diesem gesamtheitlichen Punkt versuche ich dann auch immer Dinge zu vermitteln, zu erklären und ich bin meinen Aufsichtsratskollegen, auch wenn sie nicht immer einer Meinung mit mir sind, sehr dankbar, dass sie das auch anhören und dass sie das auch als nicht Ratschlag annehmen, was ich dazu sagen habe, sondern wirklich als Meinung auch sehen. Und das muss man auch sagen, so weit sind wir immer nicht voneinander entfernt.
Es gibt auch einige Dinge, die keinen Platz im Fußball haben, Rassismus, Homophobie und so weiter. Vielleicht stelle ich diese Frage unter dem Eindruck, dass ich heute ein Aussteiger-Special auf elfreunde.de gelesen habe über drei Ultras, die in rechtsextreme Kreise gezogen wurden, über ihr Ultra-Dasein und davon den Absprung geschafft haben. Dieser Text ist für mich ein einziges Schreien nach Fußball und Politik. Dieses Argument, man darf das nicht voneinander trennen, das ist einfach schon allein deshalb falsch, weil es nicht voneinander zu trennen ist. Wie positioniert sich denn da der 1.
Du darfst jetzt auch gerne ein bisschen spoilern. Tatsächlich habe ich genau das jetzt für mich schon mal auf meine Leseliste für morgen gelegt. Ich glaube, gestern kam da der Lied raus, auch mit O-Tönen. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, weil es auch eins meiner maßgeblichen, markantesten Themen ist. Der 1. FC Nürnberg engagiert sich in dieser Sache vor allem auch mit einer großen Rückdängung, gerade der aktivsten Fans und der Ultras, in dieser Sache ganz extrem. Und extrem ist jetzt das falsche Wort. Aber wir veranstalten da auch im Rahmen des Vereins sehr viele Dinge, die für mich manchmal auch ein bisschen schockierend groß in Wiederhall oder Widerworte finden, so in der Allgemeinheit zum Beispiel den Flüchtlings Cup. Zum Beispiel, dass eine Faninitiative die Idee hatte damals, das war 2015 oder 2014, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, ein guter Freund von mir auch sagt, ja, wir haben jetzt hier Flüchtlinge mal eingeladen, dass die mal so rauskommen aus ihrem Alltag irgendwie, der FC N sofort parat war und neben viel Zuspruch und auch Engagement und Elan, gerade eben auch von der aktiven Fanszene, braucht ihr noch Helfer, können wir da noch irgendwie denen irgendwie, dass man die hinleitet oder sonst irgendwas, kam halt auch sehr viel Unverständnis im Sinne von, ja, warum kriegen die alles umsonst? Das macht mich immer extrem betroffen, weil ich das schon als einen elementaren Teil eines Fußballvereins sehe, unabhängig von der Rechtsform, Unabhängig von irgendwelchen Dingen, dass der 1. FC Nürnberg in Nürnberg und das der FC Schalke in Gelsenkirchen und das von mir aus auch der FC Bayern München in München, aber mit seiner Strahlkraft über die ganze Welt, was man immer davon halten muss, auch Statements gesellschaftlicher Art setzt. Und das ist bei uns ganz, ganz eng auch in den, nicht nur so verankert im Sinne von, ja da müssen wir was machen, da müssen wir was tun, sondern ganz eng auch in den Menschen und in den Leuten, die im Verein und um den Verein herum arbeiten. Und dazu muss ich auch sagen, dieser Kampf gegen Rassismus, in der DFB ja auch schon lange Plakatier, zeigt Rassismus die rote Karte, der wurde im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes als Kampf geführt in den Kurven. Ich war damals Mitte, Ende der 90er auch live dabei, als das in Nürnberg angefangen hat, dass man angefangen hat, oder dass das mal dieses, das alleine schon mal dieser Fußball-Schick, ich weiß nicht, ob du den auch noch kennst, grüne Bomberjagge, ich bin stolz ein Deutscher zu sein auf näher, ja, das war gang und gäbe in den deutschen Fan-Kurven. Dass es das heute nicht mehr gibt, ist nicht irgendwelchen Plakaten oder irgendwelchen Aktionen von DFB oder DFL zu verdanken. Deren Engagement natürlich auch sehr, sehr löblich ist. Das haben die Fan-Kurven und die Fan-Gruppierungen ganz alleine wirklich geschafft. Und das ist etwas, was mir in dieser ganzen Betrachtung zu diesem Themenkomplex immer extrem zu kurz kommt.
Vielleicht aber auch deshalb, weil es sich gerade anfühlt, als würde sich die Zeit da wieder ein bisschen zurückentwickeln. Und das Einzige, was sich geändert hat, ist, dass entsprechende Fans mit Hang zu rechtsextremen Gedankengut eben nicht mehr mit der Bomberjacke kommen, sondern zum Teil auch gar nicht mehr einheitlich gekleidet. Also es ist schwieriger zu entdecken, aber es gibt sie noch. Und welche Chance hat denn da ein Verein überhaupt, gegen vorzugehen? Ich habe eine ähnliche Diskussion. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es damals gehört hast, im Tribünengespräch mit Sebastian Schuppern. Genau, Cottbus und der bei Dynamo Dresden gespielt hat. Und Dynamo Dresden ist ja auch so einer der Vereine, dem das immer vorgeworfen wird, wo ich auch in diesem Tribünengespräch sehr kritisch war. Damals wusste ich einige Dinge noch nicht, die ich inzwischen weiß, wo ich inzwischen sehe, Dynamo Dresden tut sehr viel. Das war auch ein klarer Fehler von mir. Ich hatte da eine Informationslücke. Und trotzdem gibt es diese Probleme und sie sind auch nicht wegzureden. Hat man als Verein überhaupt die Chance, da was zu machen? Jenseits von, wir positionieren uns als Verein dagegen, aber da ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht so schwierig, mal wegzuhören für diejenigen Fans, die da nicht mit übereinstimmen.
Ja, also in diesem großen, übergeordneten Rahmen wäre es sicherlich eine Herkules-Aufgabe und es wäre auch, sagen wir mal so, nicht gerecht, den Vereinen das wirklich komplett aufzubürden, so haltet bitte eure Stadien sauber, dass in eurem Umfeld keine dieser Dinge passieren. Dass man das nicht wünscht und dass man das auch total ablehnt seitens der Vereine, das ist relativ klar. In Nürnberg ist das auch so, dass die Fanszene sehr, sehr klar und sehr deutlich auch antirassistisch gezeichnet ist. Aber man muss auch sagen, wann und wo immer, und das ist ja jetzt auch in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren immer öfters mal passiert, wann und wo immer mal man die aktive Fanszene aufgrund von Verfehlungen, die nicht tolerierbar sind, aber auchgrund von Dingen, wo man sagt, oh, mit Kanonen auf Spatzen geschossen, schwächt, wo man die Meinung und das Standing der Kurve schwächt, tauchen natürlich diese Elemente, die du gerade beschrieben hast, die nie weg waren. Die sind immer noch da, natürlich. Der Fußball ist ein Querschnitt der Gesellschaft. Er ist übrigens einer der letzten Sammelpunkte, wo sich alle treffen. Genau. So viel zum sozio-kulturellen Charakter des Fußballs. Aber bezogen auf dieses Thema, dass solche Kräfte sich immer besser organisieren. Das sieht man abseits des Fußballs. Wie du schon sagst, die Bomberjacken und die Aufnäher sind quasi weg. Autonome Nationalisten sehen völlig anders aus als früher. Sie haben auch einen viel größeren Drang, sich zu organisieren. Sie haben auch einen viel größeren Drang, ihre wirklichen Aktionen in der Form zu fahren. Und sie haben einen ganz anderen Vernetzungsgedanken. Und natürlich sind solche Netzwerke, die in Vernetzung, die in diesen Dingen geübt sind, viel leichter in der Lage, wieder Fuß zu fassen. Und sehr viel schneller in der Lage, auch Raum zu greifen. Und das ist eigentlich auch ein Teil, der immer dann und dort auftritt, wo die aktive Fanszene aus vielerlei Gründen gerade geschwächt wird. Das ist zu beobachten an zwei, drei Stellen, ohne jetzt einen Namen zu nennen. Aber das ist schon auch ein Hinweis darauf, dass dieses Problem nicht weg ist. Dass man es tunlichst nicht unterschätzen sollte, meiner Meinung nach. Aber dass man als Verein immer auch ein Stück hilflos ist. Hilflos im Sinne von, dass man dieses Problem nicht alleine in den Griff bekommt.
Ja, das stimmt. Es ist ja auch ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem. Und dafür können ja die Bundesliga-Vereine nicht. Auf der anderen Seite sind sie vielleicht eine der letzten Institutionen, die auf die Jugend zugreifen kann, neben Schulen. Und Fußball, vor allem die Ultrakultur, ist eine Jugendbewegung. Und Jugendliche sind besonders empfänglich dafür. Die sind, vereinfacht gesprochen, noch formbar, sind sich noch nicht sicher in den Weltpositionen, suchen Anerkennung, suchen Halt, gerade männliche Jugendliche. Da gibt es genügend Studien zu. Das heißt, der Fußball hat auch eigentlich den perfekten Ansatzpunkt, um da auch Präventionsarbeit zu leisten. Fanprojekte etc. Würdest du dir da manchmal noch mehr Unterstützung wünschen? Denn das ist ja auch eine finanzielle Frage. Ihr könnt jetzt auch nicht sagen, wir stellen 30 Leute nur für Fanprojekte ein. Das ginge ja nur in einer konzertierten Aktion. Wenn ich mich aber umgucke im Fußball, dann sehe ich da schon in den, nicht nur bei den Vereinen, sondern auch bei den Verbänden und bei der Liga, da sehe ich Millionenbeträge rumliegen, wo ich sagen würde, davon jetzt einfach mal zehn abzuzwacken. Das wäre eigentlich schon drin, um dafür bei den, meinetwegen 36 Erst- und Zweitligisten zu helfen, Fanprojekte aufzubauen.
Ja, also die Fanprojekte, das muss man dazu sagen, der Vollständigkeithaber, werden ja finanziert von Regionen, von Land und dann vom Verein. Das heißt also, es soll sehr unabhängig sein. Und dann gibt es so einen Föderalismus, der sagt, wenn die Stadt so und so viel oder das Land so und so viel zahlt, dann zahlt auch der Verein so und so viel. Das heißt also, wie das Fanprojekt begünstigt wird, das hat man auch so ein bisschen selber in der Hand. Aber Fanprojekte, das muss man der Vollständigkeithaber, nicht, dass die Leute denken, Fanprojekte sind dann bezahlt vom Verein, sind völlig autark handelnde Dinge, weil man ja durchaus auch mal Klientel hat, die vielleicht mal mit dem Verein in Konflikt gerät. Das ist ganz wichtig. Was Unterhalt des Vereins aufgebaut ist, ist die Fanbetreuung. Das heißt also die Fanclubbetreuung, die klassische, nur um das sauber zu trennen. Am Ende des Tages ist es, glaube ich, sehr viel wichtiger, dass das Engagement gegen diese Problematik und unabhängig von der Finanzierung, von den Leuten, die es betreiben, die es auf dem Schreibtisch haben, auch wirklich ernst gemeint und nachhaltig und nachvollziehbar betrieben wird. Wenn das quasi, ohne dass sie jemanden so unterstellen, wenn das pauschal immer so eine Werbeaktion ist, weil man sagt, na ja, man muss halt das Plakat hochhalten gegen Rassismus und dann ist das Thema wieder, und dann so wie es eigentlich ist, das Plakat gegen Rassismus, das muss man doch hochhalten bei jedem zweiten Heimspiel. Ah ja, das liegt irgendwo da, schau halt mal so. Wenn es diesen Charakter hat, dann lasst es bleiben. Es muss wirklich gelebt werden und es muss wirklich auch mit Überzeugung gearbeitet werden. Ich kann das von unseren lieben Kollegen oder von den Leuten im Fanprojekt auch wirklich sagen, dass die das wirklich sehr engagiert angehen und sehr engagiert leben, auch mit vielen anderen Projekten, die halt auch mit Jugend, Jugendbildung zu tun haben und nicht zuletzt halt auch, dass du hast die Ultras angesprochen, die nach Schätzungen – es ist ja immer sehr schwierig, dort Erhebungen zu finden – tatsächlich sogar momentan als die größte Jugendsubkultur in Deutschland gelten, dass die auch hier ihre Wirkmacht dahingehend entfalten. Und ich glaube, da ist man grundsätzlich auf einem guten Weg, aber es ist meiner Meinung nach eine Frage der Überzeugung. Und manchmal wirkt es halt so, als wären das dann so Image-Projekte. Das muss man halt machen. Und ich glaube, dazu sollte es nicht verkommen. Und das ist sehr viel wichtiger, als dass man sich irgendwie so über – ja gut, die Finanzierung muss natürlich auch gewährleistet werden von solchen Sachen, aber das ist, glaube ich, wichtig. Überzeugungstäter sind immer mehr wert, als irgendwie das teure bezahlte Plakat, das dann irgendwie von der Hauptribüne hängt.
Genau, das ist dann nur plakativ im Wortsinn. Aber das ist das, was mir manchmal auch fehlt, wenn man – es wird häufig genug über die Bedeutung für die Region – da kann man fast schon einen Trademark dran machen – die Region von Bundesliga-Vereinen gesprochen. Und das hat ja auch eine Bedeutung. Und genau an diesem Punkt, finde ich, kommt mir das aber häufig zu kurz. Denn dass es viele Menschen gibt, die sehr, sehr große Angst haben – also meiner Meinung nach kommt Fremden-Hass oft aus einem Gefühl der Unsicherheit. Sonst, wenn es dir gut geht und du dich gut fühlst, dann gibt es eigentlich keinen Grund, warum du vor dem Fremden erstmal Angst haben musst. Das kommt ja aus Missständen. Und die sind vor allem regional leichter zu beheben als auf einer nationalen Ebene. Es würde jetzt nicht helfen, wenn wir einfach die Geldkieskanne aufmachen und sagen, hier sind 1 Milliarde Euro, jeder Bundesbürger bekommt dafür 20 Euro. Das wird nichts helfen. Aber mit regionalen Projekten kann man unglaublich viel tun in Strukturen. Vielleicht bin ich da auch sehr durch meine dörfliche Herkunft geprägt. Und ich habe sowohl tief, tief braune Dörfer erlebt in Mittelfranken, auch in Unterfranken zum Teil, als auch Dörfer, die es geschafft haben, da eine Trendumkehr herzustellen. Und es ging immer über Projekte, die irgendein Träger gemacht hat, dessen primäre Aufgabe das eigentlich gar nicht war. Oft Kirchen, manchmal auch Zusammenschlüsse von Eltern. Und was aber immer gefehlt hat, zumindest in der Zeit, in der ich noch Kind war, waren Fußballvereine. Die haben da nie was gemacht. Von denen kriegt man vielleicht mal einen Strampel, wenn man im entsprechenden Stadtkrankenhaus geboren wird. Aber danach nichts mehr. Ist doch eigentlich komisch.
Also für alle Interessierten muss ich jetzt natürlich noch kurz Werbung machen. In Nürnberg gibt es sogar einen den 1. FC Nürnberg Kreißsaal. Ja, so viel Werbung sei mir dann erlaubt.
Kommentiert da dann dein Kollege Günther Koch die Wehen? Oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Die Idee nehme ich mal mit nach Hause. Danke schön.
Ich halte das nicht mehr aus. Aber das Nürnberg am Abgrund, das sollte man rausnehmen.
Sie haben ein Kind gemacht. Sehr gut.
Da muss er mit Druck über die Mitte kommen. Pressing ist da besonders wichtig im FCN-Kreis, vielleicht sogar wichtiger als manchmal auf dem Platz bei euch. Aber wir waren ja bei lokalen Projekten von Fußballvereinen.
Ja, ich kann hier nur aus eigener Erfahrung eine Sache erzählen. Das heißt also, das Thema liegt mir aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr im Herzen, unter anderem auch, weil ich auch aus einem Ort stamme, der als ich sehr jung war, als ich meine sozio-kulturelle, über die Punk- und Hardcore-Punkmusik sozio-kulturelle Prägung erfahren habe, sehr viele Probleme mit diesem Thema hatte. Und ich da auch durchaus handfest Erfahrungen gemacht habe mit neonazistischen und rassistischen Umtrieben Anfang, Mitte der 90er Jahre. In der Nähe von Kulmach gibt es einen kleinen Ort, der heißt Schwarzach. Und dieser Ort wurde, man kann fast schon sagen, transalliert und maltratiert von einer immer stärkeren werdenden Organisation von Neonazis, was darin mündete, dass dann immer recht regelmäßig ein – ich weiß gar nicht, was das für eine Feier war, aber es war immer recht regelmäßig ein ganz großes Treffen der NBT auch. Und irgendwann sind diese Bürger der Stadt aber, also wirklich aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft, wenn man so will, aufgestanden und haben gesagt, so jetzt reicht's. Und haben sich einfach mal angefangen dagegenzustellen, erst in kleiner Zahl, dann immer größer und größer, dann wurde das auch wirklich zu einem lokalen Phänomen, bis hin zu der Tatsache, dass sie es dann irgendwann vor – jetzt mag ich nichts Falsches sagen – vor drei Jahren ungefähr dann wirklich geschafft haben, dass die NBT-Feiern dort nicht mehr stattfinden, dass das Bündnis Schwarzach ist bunt, auch überregional Anerkennung erfahren hat. Und dass das für mich wirklich – ich bin darauf aufmerksam geworden natürlich, weil, wie gesagt, das ist sechs Kilometer weg von mir – dass das einfach wirklich absolutes gelebtes Bürgerengagement war. Und man muss auch sagen, dass diese Menschen, die das damals aus der Taufe gehoben haben, auch wirklich zunächst nicht wussten, was erwartet uns da, die auch Angst hatten, aber die Mut gefasst haben als das ganze Dorf und immer mehr und immer mehr und plötzlich auch überregionaler Zuspruch war und irgendwann aber wirklich so stark war, dass man gesagt hat, okay, dieses Fest wird hier nicht mehr stattfinden, Punkt. Und bei den Leuten, muss ich mir sagen, habe ich mir für mich ganz selber sehr viel von diesem Engagement und von dieser, wie sagt man es, von dieser, diese Initiative und die ist ja genau abgeguckt. Mich freut es auch, dass die treffen sich glaube ich immer noch im Nebenraum einer Metzgerei, einer Gaststätte und dort hängt auch ein Club-Trikot Match-Worn, damals von Timo Gepard, ein Match-Worn-Trikot an der Wand und zwar als diese, ich kriege den Text jetzt nicht mehr zusammen, genau als diese Aktionswoche vor zig Jahren, als wir noch Bundesliga gespielt haben, gegen Rassismus. Also auch wieder so ein, wo das auf dem Stand, auf dem Trikot stand, irgendwie eine Aktion. Und Timo hat dann quasi erfahren von dieser Aktion und hat gemeint, also gebe ich sofort mein T-Shirt ab und das haben wir dann in der Glas gegossen und dann bin ich da mal vorbeigefahren. Und das war schon etwas, wo ich sage, diese Zivilcourage – das Wort jetzt habe ich es endlich – diese Zivilcourage hat auch Erfolg, wenn man wirklich so engagiert und sich gegen diese Sache auflehnt.
Und sowas könnte man doch öfter machen. Man könnte doch zum Beispiel sagen, es gibt jetzt, bewirb dich mit dem, was du tust, gegen, muss ja auch jetzt gar nicht immer gegen etwas sein, sondern so auch einfach, wo du dich engagierst und jeden Spieltag werden 10 oder 100 Leute von Organisationen ins Stadion eingeladen, die sich für eine bessere Gesellschaft einsetzen. Sowas könnte man doch regelmäßig machen.
Das könnte man grundsätzlich regelmäßig machen, ja. Ich glaube, aber was heißt ich glaube? Ich finde diese Idee sehr charmant. Ich muss aber immer auch dazu sagen, dass ich genauso diesen punktuellen, die Geschichte, die dann dazu passt, weil die dann wesentlich wirkmächtiger ist. Dieses Schwarzach-Thema, das kennst jetzt du, das kennen jetzt vielleicht noch mehr. Vielleicht schauen ein paar im Internet und finden da ein bisschen was. Aber das war damals so wirkmächtig für mich ganz persönlich und auch, dass der Verein das damals so mitbekommen hat, dass da heute sich noch Leute daran erinnern und dass sie sagen, ja, damals hier. Und wenn dann jemand da in der Gaststätte vorbei kommt und sagt, ja, guck mal, warum es hängen da ein Clubtrikot, dass da auch die Geschichte dazu passt, das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was die Sache dann weiterträgt.
Genau, das würdet ihr dann über was anderes auch machen. Also es muss jetzt auch nicht sein, mit jedem Spieltag oder sonst wie. Aber als Verein hat man ja die Möglichkeit, entweder direkt eigene Projekte zu starten. Dann ist man logischerweise immer im Fußballumfeld und immer auch – du hast ja die Trennung von Verein und Fanprojekten auch völlig richtig ja vorhin schon beschrieben – aber man kann ja auch Bürgerinitiative fördern, ins Rampenlicht stellen. Meinetwegen in jedem Stadionzeitschrift eine Seite freiräumen für das Projekt des Spieltags und vielleicht mal auf einen Song aus den 80er- 90er- und den besten von heute im Stadionprogramm verzichten und dafür noch kurz irgendwie zwei Leute der Aktion vorstellen. So hätte man ja zum Beispiel auch Schwarzach – du hast das jetzt hier präsentiert – so hätte man es dann gleich vor zigtausenden im Stadion präsentiert und so weiter. Also ihr habt ja eine große Öffentlichkeit und deswegen habt ihr die Möglichkeit, Dinge in die Öffentlichkeit zu ziehen und damit ja auch einen…
Was wir ja auch tun tatsächlich, wenn du bei uns auf die Homepage schaust, mit dem Projekt Nürnberg gewinnt, wo wir auch ganz viele Kuratoren haben aus dem öffentlichen Leben. Zum Beispiel Hans Meyer ist da ein Kurator, was mich ganz persönlich sehr freut, wo es wirklich auch um diese soziokulturellen und gesellschaftlichen Themen und das Engagement geht. Und unter diesem Label Nürnberg gewinnt, wird das alles gesammelt. Und da sind vielfältige Projekte aufgehangen, da können auch neue dazukommen. Und das ist auch entstanden, das macht die Kollegin, die Frau Fritsch, die leitet diese Abteilung. Es ist wirklich eine Abteilung, die sich um die Verankerung des Vereins innerhalb der Gesellschaft kümmert. Ich verwende da immer gerne den Begriff soziokulturell, das spricht immer am besten an, auch wenn das so ein Kunstwort ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was man jetzt neudeutsch als CSR, also Corporate Social Responsibility – Das ist unsere CSR-Abteilung, ganz genau. Darunter ist es aufgehangen, den Begriff – Wie groß ist das?
Ist das nur die Frau Fritsch?
Das wird immer relativ projektbezogen, dann so bearbeitet, dass dann auch Leute aus anderen Abteilungen dazukommen und das auch wirklich sehr tragen. Und was ganz wichtig ist, weshalb ich auch vorhin gesagt habe, so ein Plakat aufhängen und irgendwie, das ist schön, das ist plakativ, wie du schon gesagt hast, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Aber wenn du so etwas tust, dann brauchst du die Menschen und dann brauchst du die Überzeugung der Leute und auch den Menschen im Verein, dass das gelebt werden muss, dass das auch Sinn macht. Und dass das Sinn macht, dass das auch auf den Verein zurückkommt, mit positivem Engagement, das merken wir an jeder Stelle. Und dieses Projekt läuft jetzt – jetzt darf ich auch nichts Falsches sagen – seit zwei oder drei Jahren. Und wir merken einfach, dass das wirklich so fast schon ein Eigenleben entwickelt. Und dass das einfach wirklich auch eine gute Sache ist. Und ich da auch nur die Kollegen anderer Vereine extrem dazu ermutigen kann, diese kulturelle, diese gesellschaftliche, lokale Verantwortung auch zu übernehmen, was sich das unbedingt auszahlt auch.
Ja, man kommt nicht raus aus dem Kontext, in dem man auch als Bundesligaverein hängt. Auch wenn man so ein bisschen im Fußballbusiness ja immer über der Welt schwebt, aber die Welt holt den Fußball immer wieder ein an verschiedenen Stellen. Nicht zuletzt, wenn die Welt zu Gast im Stadion ist. Ja. Etwas groß formuliert. Wir haben vorhin immer mal wieder schon das Thema gestreift, dass du gemerkt hast, 2011, du bist in den Aufsichtsrat gekommen, mir fehlen da noch einige Puzzlestücke an Wissen. Ich kann zwar Bilanzen lesen wie Spielberichte, aber ein paar andere Dinge kenne ich noch nicht so gut. Und dann hast du dich dazu entschieden, eine Fortbildung zu machen. Es gibt also eine Fortbildung, die einen D-Bereich schlauer macht. Das musst du uns jetzt erklären. Was war das für eine Fortbildung?
Ja, also um es chronologisch zu bleiben, ist diese Fortbildung tatsächlich in eine Zeit gefallen, in der ich ein Jahr lang kein Aufsichtsrat war. Man muss das vielleicht so erklären. 2014 für alle Clubfans, die wissen das noch, ein sehr schmerzlicher Abstieg mit einem, auch drei Jahre später oder vier Jahre später, nicht mehr zu fassenden Schneckenrennen am Tabellenende, das so unglaublich war, indem so unglaubliche Schlaglichter mit acht Verletzten teilweise passiert sind. Das war eine ganz komische Zeit. Ich komme dann gleich auf die Weiterbildung. Und danach war dann der Abstieg und dann das Thema zweite Liga.
Da hast du gesagt, die zweite Liga gehe ich nicht mit.
Ja, das war, sagen wir mal so. Also ich muss da jetzt ein bisschen persönlich werden. Es ist schlicht und ergreifend so gewesen, dass es bei mir gesundheitlich schon immer so ein bisschen so eine Gradwanderung war. Was traue ich meinem Körper zu? Was traue ich mir zu? Du siehst mich jetzt hier, die Höhere nicht. Das heißt also, ich wachse seit ein paar Jahren nur noch nach vorne. Und das ist jetzt aber auch schon wieder besser geworden. Es war einfach eine Zeit, in der ich mir beruflich und auch durch diesen Stress im Fußball, das kann ich nicht anders sagen, einfach viel zu viel zugemutet habe. Und es gab dann so ein Schlaglicht für mich. Nicht lustigerweise, sondern es war kurz bevor man sich meldet, ob man wieder zum Aufsichtsrat kandidiert. Und ich habe meine Bewerbung und alles schon abgegeben. Und es war ein Sonntagsspiel in Karlsruhe, das nationale Bekanntheit durch einen anderen Aspekt erlangt hat, nämlich, dass vermeintlich die Spieler nach dem Spiel die Trikots abgeben mussten. Das war so ein Fall, der ein bisschen durch die Medien ging. Das soll aber nicht das Thema sein. Und ich habe an diesem Spiel, das wir dann auch folgerichtig aufgrund desolater Leistungen verloren haben, ich habe dann schon gemerkt, irgendwas stimmt nicht mehr. Dann habe ich so quasi meine Medikamente noch vergessen. Und was macht man dann, wenn man Medikamente für den Blutdruck vergisst? Man trinkt natürlich noch zwei Kaffee zur Halbzeit. Das sich die Wirkung umkehrt. Und dann bin ich nach Hause gefahren, habe gegrübelt und gedacht, weil natürlich nehme ich so eine Situation mit. Und am nächsten Tag bin ich dann quasi auf die Arbeit gegangen. Ich muss dazu sagen, unser Hausarzt, der hat die Praxis direkt in unserem Haus. Der hat gemeint, du siehst nicht gut aus, kommst mal vorbei. Und die Kurzfassung ist dann, ich habe diesen Nachmittag dann halt auch im Krankenhaus verbracht, wie auch die nächsten eineinhalb Wochen. Das war, sagen wir mal so, die Geschichte geht so weit, dass ich ja schon zwei- dreimal vorher Bekanntenschaften mit dem Krankenhaus gemacht habe. Und ein Arzt, der mich dann schon kannte, der Arztin hat gemeint, wir können ihm nicht mehr helfen. Wir sind fürs Herz zuständig, nicht für den Kopf. Und das war so der Initialschuss, wo ich gesagt habe, so, jetzt wird erstmal alles abgesagt, jetzt wird erstmal radikal runtergefahren, jetzt wird erstmal gesundet. Das ist jetzt auch alles passiert, also das ist auch alles kein Problem gewesen. Aber darin mündete eben auch meine Absage, erneut zu kandidieren. Das heißt also, ich habe eine Jahreshauptversammlung verpasst, die wohl auch sehr kurios gewesen sein muss, mit irgendwelchen Videoeinblendungen und sonst irgendwas. Wie gesagt, ich kenne sie nur aus der Ferne, sie muss aber eine der wirkmächtigsten Jahreshauptversammlungen des Clubs ever gewesen sein. Aber in diese Zeit fiel eben auch rein, dass der FC Schalke 04 in Verbindung mit der Universität St. Gallen ein Konzept aufgesetzt hat, das ursprünglich gedacht war für ehemalige Spieler. Quasi Fuß zu fassen in diesem Fußball-Business. Ich habe mir dann das Projekt angeguckt, habe dann auch mal jemand bei Schalke angerufen und habe gefragt, was ist denn das? So ein halbjährliches Projekt, quasi wirklich ein Studio mit Abschluss, das man immer drunter versteht. Und es soll halt auch sehr praxisnahe sein, der Teil bei uns auf Schalke mit Event- Arena-Management, mit ganz klassischen – damals noch Horst Held – mit Gesprächen, mit den Managern. Also ganz klassisch, so wie Alexander Joos eine Vortrag über Management gehalten hat. Das war alles wirklich großartig und auf der anderen Seite wirklich diesen fachlichen Aspekt untermauert von der Uni St. Gallen. Das heißt also mit den Regelwochen unten in St. Gallen. Und das hat mich von Anfang an fasziniert. Und dann habe ich aber gesagt, ey Leute, schwierig, für mich macht es ja keinen Sinn mehr. Und dann habe ich gesagt, nee, das gehört jetzt zum Teil meines persönlichen Restrukturierungsprogramms, also auch gesundheitlich und inhaltlich. Ich hatte da immer wahnsinnig Lust drauf und ich wollte das machen. Und es ist ja auch aus der Prämisse entschanden, dass ich längst noch nicht alles weiß, was ich glaube, wissen zu müssen über dieses Geschäft. Und dann habe ich das 2015, habe ich das dann quasi abgeschlossen im Juli. Mit mir zum Beispiel in diesem Kurs war Jens Keller, Malik Fatih zum Beispiel, aus der Schweiz David Degen, den man zum Beispiel auch noch aus seiner Zeit aus Gladbach kennt. Aber auch ganz viele Leute aus der Wirtschaft, die aus anderer Sicht mit dem Fußball zu tun haben oder mit Sport ganz allgemein. Nämlich, dass sie Sponsoren waren oder quasi in dieser anderen Bereich aktiv waren. Das war eine so unglaublich befruchtende Gruppe. Und wirklich, sagen wir mal so, die Lehrinhalte von Schalke, die Lehrinhalte vor allem von der Uni St. Gallen, die waren so unheimlich wichtig, weil ich endlich mal dieses Learning by Doing mit einer Grafik unterfüttern konnte. Weil ich dieses A in Schema pressen konnte. Was mir heute in meiner zweiten Anstalt auf sich trat, unheimlich viel hilft, Dinge sachlicher zu bewerten. Aber sehr, sehr befruchtend waren zum Beispiel, sich einfach mal einen Tisch zu setzen, wenn sich Leute, die aus diesem Geschäft und schon langjährig in diesem Geschäft waren, einfach mal so über die Kaderplanung von X unterhalten. Da mal zuzuhören und einfach mal zu sagen, ah ja, da nehme ich mir ganz viel mit. Und aus dieser Idee Kader Mathematik zum Beispiel oder Gremienethik, wie sowas angelegt wird, das war für mich ganz wichtig.
Was ist Kader Mathematik?
Kader Mathematik ist im Endeffekt, okay, zwei rechts, zwei links, vier Innenverteidiger, defensive Sechser, nie sparen, immer lieber einen mehr als einen zu wenig.
Also man ist der HSV?
Dieser Klassiker, ja. Und das ist das Wort HSV wirklich gefallen. Ja, du hast es gesagt.
Ja, es tut mir auch leid, es wird mir ja auch immer unterstellt, dass ich auf den rumhacken würde, aber gut, die haben sich ja jetzt Dominik Kaiser geholt, das heißt, man hat auf der Position nachgebessert. Also nehme ich den HSV aus der Kette raus.
Richtig, und das ist also etwas, was da quasi so auch vermittelt wurde und da bin ich sehr dankbar, weil das war ein Kurs, der war damals neu, inzwischen haben auch ganz viele nachgezogen, es gibt ihn auch vom DFB, ich glaube, es gibt ihn auch vom Wolfsburg, es gibt ihn von vielen anderen Vereinen, genau immer in Verbindung mit einem Leerstuhl oder zumindest mit einem Bildungsträger zusammen. Und das war für mich ganz eminent wichtig und der geht jetzt in die vierte Runde, Gerald Asamoah hat zum Beispiel vor zwei Jahren noch abgeschlossen und die ganzen Kollegen treffe ich auch am letzten Samstag im Januar wieder, da haben wir Alumni-Treffen bei VfB gegen Schalke und da bin ich mal gespannt. Und das war für mich unheimlich wichtig und wie gesagt, ich hatte damals ebenso ein Jahr, wo ich kein Aufsichtsrat war und wo ich eigentlich auch keiner mehr werden wollte. Habe mir aber dann gesagt, naja, dann ist ja dieses ganze Studium eigentlich hinfällig. Und dann wurde ich aber auch so gefragt, sag mal, hast du nicht wieder Lust? Und es war damals inzwischen, muss man sagen, auch ein neuer Aufsichtsrat. Es war ein neuer Vorstand da, es gab also ganz viel Aufbruchsstimmung. Und man hat mir da bedeutet, dass es vielleicht interessant wäre, wenn ich da mithelfen könnte und würde und das bin ich dann auch glücklicherweise wieder gewählt worden. Und dann ging es da weiter. Aber wie gesagt, diese Zeit, man nennt das umgangssprachlich die Schalker-Akademie. Das finde ich sehr witzig. Die war für mich wirklich auch nochmal so ein Fingerzeichen im Sinne von, ja. Und meine Abschlussarbeit, und da war ich wirklich der Exot in dieser Klasse. Aber ich muss auch sagen, sehr aufgeschlossen, vor allem auch von den Unis an Gallen, die Abschlussarbeit war der Fußball zwischen Volkssport und Kommerzialisierung. Ein Thema, das sich für mich extrem durchträgt. Und das mich auch in diesem Studium sehr geprägt hat. Weil du hattest dann auch verschiedene Meinungen von 50 plus 1 muss komplett wegfallen, die Investoren und hier und da. Und auf der anderen Seite halt auch so eine Position, eine sehr archaische Position, wie ich heute finde. So nein, Fußball, Volkssport und so. Und anfänglich haben sich diese beiden Meinungen gar nicht so vertragen. Und irgendwann hast du gemerkt, Moment mal, wir kommen ja eigentlich nur weiter, wenn man das als großes Gesamtes sieht. Wenn du wirklich sagst, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube zum Beispiel nicht, wenn sich Verbände und aktive Fans oder überhaupt irgendwelche Fan-Gruppierungen treffen und anhand Demarkationslinien jetzt definieren, wer denn jetzt was kriegt. Zum Beispiel Stehplätze müssen auf jeden Fall erhalten bleiben, dann sagt der Verband, ja, aber dafür brauchen wir dann ein Montagsspiel mehr. Ich glaube nicht an diese Demarkationslinie.
Aber wie kann man sich dann einigen?
Wenn ich das wüsste, wäre ich höchstwahrscheinlich ein sehr reicher Mensch.
Das ist nicht das Problem, wenn wir über solche Themen sprechen und wir jetzt in dem Fall sind ja die Antagonisten zueinander der DFB und die Ultras. Sagen wir jetzt einfach mal, dass Sprachworte jeweils andere Positionen sind. Und es ist nicht davon auszugehen, dass in einer Diskussion, egal wie lange sie dauern mag, die eine Seite der anderen Seite so viele Argumente zeigt, die die noch nie gehört hat, dass die andere Seite sagt, Mensch, ihr habt ja Recht. 50 plus 1 muss ja wirklich bleiben. Das wird ja nicht passieren.
Für 50 plus 1 sind wahrscheinlich beide Parteien.
Stimmt, das wäre jetzt da mit der DFL genau. Da habe ich jetzt zwei Themen miteinander vermischt. Aber dann kann man sich ja nur noch irgendwie so einigen, dass man Positionen klarmacht, dass man auch sagt, wo sind rote Linien. Gutes Beispiel aktuell, der angekündigte Boykott der Dortmund-Fans beim Montagsabendspiel gegen den FC Augsburg. Ich denke, da werden sowohl die Liga als auch der Verband nicht unbedingt mit gerechnet haben, dass in einem solchen Stadion wie Borussia Dortmund da große Teile der Südribüne eventuell leer bleiben werden. Man kommt ja dann nur noch so voran, dass man sagt, ok, das sind rote Linien. Wenn ihr die überschreitet, dann wird es Konsequenzen haben in dieser Richtung. Ich habe den Eindruck, anders funktionieren leider heutzutage Debatten gar nicht mehr.
Ja, das macht den Eindruck auch aus, dadurch, dass wir jetzt auch unter dem Eindruck einer politischen Diskussion um die nächste Regierung stehen, wo halt auch um jeden Zentimeter gefochten wird. Tatsächlich muss ich sagen, ich bin ein bisschen abstrakt und ich habe auch noch keine unbedingende Lösung. Aber ich glaube, wenn alle Bedarfsgruppen, wie man so schön sagt, wenn alle Bedarfsgruppen sich auf ein Modell Fußball Zukunft einigen, das zu 80 bis 90 Prozent alle relevanten Teile abdeckt. Denn der Kernpunkt ist auch für mich immer, diese beiden in Anführungsstrichen völlig konträr zueinander stehenden Parteien haben, je länger sie miteinander reden, immer mehr das Gefühl, Moment mal, uns trennen nicht 90 Prozent, sondern uns trennen nur noch 10 Prozent. Das glaube ich, da bin ich mir sehr sicher. Und deshalb glaube ich auch an diesen gesamtheitlichen Ansatz, Fußball Zukunft, wie der ausschauen kann, wie man sowas initiieren kann, das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich glaube nicht an einen Fußball, der an Demarkationslinien entlang gehandhabt wird, weil sonst irgendwann halt mal zwei Dinge passieren. Die Initiative PlayFair zum Beispiel, die hat ja auch diese Umfrage unter, glaube ich, 17.000 Fußballfans gemacht. Und die Themen, die von einer vermeintlich kleinen Gruppe der aktiven Fans immer jetzt im Zuge dieser Proteste auf die Transparente und die Plakate gemalt wurden, die sind ja jetzt keine Einzelmeinungen von einem kleinen Teil, sondern die sind ja auch wirklich Teile der – das sind ja wirklich große Teile der Fans, vornehmlich wahrscheinlich Stadiongänger oder übermäßig am Fußball interessierter Menschen, die sagen, naja, irgendwann mal ist halt der Punkt erreicht. Und da müssen wir gar nicht bis zu einer Imagin, was ja inzwischen eigentlich absurde Dinge angenommen haben, sondern dass diese Naimartransfers halt nach unten auch abstrahlen. Ja, dass ja quasi so, dass immer, oder sagen wir mal so, eine Verrücktheit mehr im Fußball führt zu anderen und führt immer zu einem Effekt nach unten.
Trick it down, Madness. Klar, dann kostet einen.
Und das ist ja jetzt keine exklusive Meinung, nur von einem kleinen Teil der Fans und das ist halt auch das. Und ich habe halt Angst davor, dass der Fußball, so wie ich ihn liebe, ich könnte mit dem Status Quo heute gar nicht mal so schlecht leben, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich verweige mich auch aus vielerlei Gründen auch nicht dem Kommerz. Ich glaube auch, dass wir noch ein bisschen in der Auslandsvermarktung Möglichkeiten haben. Ich glaube aber nicht mehr dran. Oder ich glaube nicht daran, dass, wenn wir eine der Bedarfsgruppen vergessen, dass es ein tragfähiges Modell ist, das in 10, 12, 15 Jahren auch immer noch so funktionieren kann.
Genau, dann sind halt die Faninteressen eine dieser Bedarfsgruppen. Das wird vermutlich jetzt so ein bisschen das Schlusskapitel deiner Abschlussarbeit gewesen sein.
Ja, tatsächlich. Ich habe das wieder aufgenommen, weil es mich lange, lange – ich habe gedacht, das kann man doch – irgendwie kann man das doch zu irgendeinem Thema machen. Und dann bin ich draufgekommen, dass man das grafisch darstellen kann. Und ich kann es leider schlecht erklären. Ich musste ja auch in meiner Abschlussarbeit dem Professor Jennewein erklären, dass die Kreise, diese unförmigen, eigentlich Zahnrädchen sein sollen. Ich habe so eine Zahnrädchen-Idee entwickelt im Sinne von, wie du eine Vereinsarbeit darstellen kannst und wie du dieses ganze große Gesamte. Und dann gab es halt die sportlichen, die wirtschaftlichen. Aber es gab ganz wichtig – und das hat mich immer beschäftigt – diese emotionalen Zahnrädchen, wo immer irgendwas nicht stimmt. Und ich habe das – ich sage das auch wieder – am Beispiel vom HSV durchdekliniert, dass dieses Ding funktioniert. Das war in einem Verein, in dem gerade alles irgendwie gegeneinanderarbeitet. Das war kurz vor der Ausgliederung. Das war also wirklich ein Wirrwarr. Hat es damals Bruno Labbadia geschafft, über einen ganz kurzen Zeitraum den Bereich sportlich, Mannschaft, von diesem ganzen Restkomplex zu trennen und dann unabhängig davon von der ein oder anderen Schiedsrichterleistung vielleicht, auch wirklich geschafft, das zu schaffen, dass dann quasi die sportlichen Ziele kurzfristig erreicht werden? Und der zweite Punkt, der Abschlussarbeit, der Arbeit, wenn es jetzt nicht zu einem großen Zusammenfügen kommt, wenn man das jetzt nicht mehr so darstellen kann, dann wird es auch über kurz oder lang ein kurzer Spaß werden, dann werden sich diese Prozesse wieder auflösen. Und an der Sache, dieses grafisch darzustellen und vielleicht auch verfügbar zu machen, da arbeite ich gerade mit so jemandem, so einem Wirtschaftsgrafiker, der das schon mal gemacht hat und der das super interessant findet. Und es gab immer, wenn man es auf den Verein bezieht, ein ganz großes Zahnrad. Das ganz große Zahnrad, das heißt, was treibt euch an? Was ist der elementare Punkt eures Vereins? Was treibt euch früh in die Büros? Was treibt euch früh rauf auf den Trainingsplatz? Und man mag es kaum glauben, wie wenig Vereine auf diesen mittelpunkt, auf diesen elementarsten Punkt wirklich eine passende Antwort haben, abseits von irgendwelchen Marken oder Sätzen.
Und was ist dann der Mittelpunkt des 1. FC Nürnberg?
Den definieren wir gerade, den finden wir gerade tatsächlich.
Das finde ich alles sehr spannend, weil das auch, glaube ich, sich mit vielen Gedankengängen deckt, die ich hier schon hatte im Rasenfunk, ausgesprochen und unausgesprochen und sicherlich auch viele meiner Gäste. Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, man redet da viel über Utopien und Dystopien, man macht jeweils der Gegenseite Angst. Wenn du jetzt sagst, bestimmte Bedarfsgruppen dürfen nicht weggelassen werden, dann könnte ich dir jetzt auch Angst machen, indem ich sage, naja, vielleicht wird Fußball in 15 Jahren so sein wie E-Sport, dass es gar nicht mehr so sehr auf die Stadionzuschauer ankommt, sondern an die 60 Millionen im Livestream. Ich wünsche mir nicht, dass es dahin kommt. Es ist aber ein mögliches Szenario. Was ich…
Wir haben auch eine E-Sport-Abteilung, oder? Ich hatte ja ein hochinteressantes Gespräch mit einem der Leiter eines der größten E-Sports-Teams in Deutschland, ich glaube auch weltweit. Das war hochinteressant.
E-Sport müssen wir gleich darüber sprechen. Erst will ich noch den einen Gedanken fertig bringen.
Entschuldigung.
Nein, nein, alles gut. Denn wenn wir über Commerz im Fußball sprechen, dann ist die grundsätzliche Frage doch eigentlich die, ob es dieses höher, weiter, schneller, ob es das wirklich braucht, ob das die Antwort ist. Denn das ist ja die Triebfeder des ganzen Kommerzialisierungsansatzes, der aber weder einen Anfang kannte – es ging schon ganz früh los, im ganz Kleinen – der aber auch meines Erachtens nach kein Ende kennt. Und das ist das, was zunehmend problematisch wird, weil man immer mehr sich in Sphären weiterentwickelt, die mit der Lebensrealität der Menschen so wenig zu tun haben, dass da offene Brüche entstehen. Also der Fußball war schon immer kommerziell, aber es war immer noch näher am Menschen. Und diese plakativen Beispiele von Neymar oder jetzt Coutinho, Obermeir Jung streikt sich jetzt gerade weg, wenn das hier erschienen ist. Wissen wir wahrscheinlich auch schon, ob er jetzt bei Arsenal gelandet ist. Wir zwei wissen es gerade noch nicht. Und dass die ein unglaubliches Gehalt bekommen und dass, selbst wenn es dann positive Bewegungen gibt, wie eben zum Beispiel, dass die Spieler Teile ihres Gehalts spenden, dann sind das immer noch so absurde Summen, dass ich mir denke, Wahnsinn, wie groß muss eigentlich dein Gehalt sein? Das gibt es doch alles gar nicht. Also sprich, wir erleben doch eigentlich gerade, dass es den Bruch, den man auch in ganz vielen anderen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen sieht, nämlich, dass einige wenige sehr, sehr viel Geld haben und viele andere immer weniger Geld haben, zumindest der Wert des Geldes wird immer weniger, den erleben wir doch auch im Fußball. Und da kann doch, also da kann ein höher, schneller, weiter, das kann doch gar nicht mehr funktionieren, jetzt auf eine Sicht von zehn Jahren bezogen. Und da finde ich es richtig, auch mit einem Aufsichtsrat drüber zu sprechen, denn der Sportvorstand, der muss immer wirtschaftlichen und sportlichen Erfolg in Einklang bringen, denn das eine funktioniert nicht lange ohne das andere, außer man ist losgelöst vom Geldkreislauf durch einen Investor. Aber du als Aufsichtsrat, du hast ja diese längeren Zeiträume. Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum man dann überhaupt nur so argumentiert, wir müssen jetzt die Lücke zur Premier League schließen. A, frage ich mich, wie? Und B, was soll denn dann bitte passieren? Dann sind die doch wieder davon gelaufen und dann müssen wir, wir werden doch diese Lücke, wo wollen wir denn hin? Und macht das denn dann wirklich einen Unterschied, ob es jetzt fünf Milliarden für die Bundesliga sind oder zehn Milliarden, vor allem, wenn im Amateursport auch nichts ankommt? Na gut, ich könnte da sehr lange drüber diskutieren, aber ich frage mich, wo will man denn da eigentlich hin, langfristig gesehen? Es geht doch eigentlich immer nur darum, da geht es meiner Meinung nach immer eher um kurzfristig höhere Gewinne. Und wenn es der DFL-Chef Seifert nicht schafft, über eine Milliarde zu erlösen mit dem nächsten TV-Deal, dann hat er versagt. Und jetzt mit dem nächsten Deal wird er jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen mehr erreichen müssen. Ansonsten hat er in Anführungszeichen versagt. Das ist doch eine Spirale, die auch gar nicht mehr an Logik gebunden ist. Oder kannst du mir das erklären?
Nein, ich kann es dir tatsächlich nicht erklären, weil meine Gedankengänge grundsätzlich dieselben sind. Meine Problematik ist aber, ich sitze jetzt hier auf der Seite des Aufsichtsrats eines Bundesliga-Zweitligisten, der sich vielleicht anschickt über kurz oder lang. Mir wäre es lieber über kurz, sich zu einem der Vereine zu entwickeln, die sich auch in der ersten Liga etablieren können. Diese Lösung, diese Möglichkeit. Um das mal ganz kurz zu denken, das ist so der Anspruch. Sobald ich in dieser Verantwortung stecke, muss ich das Spiel, das du jetzt meiner Meinung nach sehr treffend beschrieben hast, auch ein bisschen mitgehen. Es wäre ja auch verlogen, wenn ich das nicht machen würde, weil ich ja auch durch mein Amt und auch wenn wir sehr, sehr, sehr viele Punkte jetzt gemeinsam, wo wir jetzt einer Meinung sind, es wäre ja auch verlogen, weil ich ja dieses Spiel auf eine gewisse Art und Weise ja jetzt schon mitspiele. Ich bin ja – und als Zweitlich ist das mal vielleicht immer ein bisschen getriebener – in diesem Spiel, weil man anderen wiederum hinterherhechelt. Für uns, du sagst, aus Sicht eines Bayern-Fans ist natürlich diese Diskussion, Premier League Bayern und so, die ist natürlich omnipräsent. Für uns geht es aber darum, Bayern, Rabaa, Leipzig. Danke übrigens für diese – Sehr gerne.
Ich hoffe, du sprichst doch in Aufsichtsrat. Steht das in Aufsichtsratsprotokollen, dass du Rabaa, Leipzig sagst? Da wäre ich jetzt sehr stolz.
Nein, ich weiß aber von wem ich am Montag – egal wann das gesendet wird – einen Anruf kriege.
Derjenige, der gerne noch mal die fünfeinhalb Stunden Tribünengespräch dazu hören will, wo es zur Herleitung kommt, warum ich diese Wortmeldung gemacht habe.
Ja, deshalb habe ich die auch. So bin ich konditioniert, siehst du mal. Und dann Borussia Dortmund, und dann geht quasi so ein sehr breites Mittelfeld an von Vereinen, von denen du quasi wirklich nicht sagen kannst, dass sie nicht irgendwann mal in Abstiegsgefahr geraten können. Selbst Dortmund ist das vor drei, vier Jahren passiert. Und da ranzukommen, ist im Endeffekt unsere Premier League, wenn man so will. Diese Schere zwischen erster und zweiter Liga geht ja auch immer weiter auf. Wenn du sagst, Ich sag mal so Pi mal Daumen. Ein Abstieg aus der ersten Liga kostet dich automatisch 20 Millionen. An Erlösen, die du über TV, über Vermarktung und so nicht mehr hast. Dann kannst du dir in etwa ausmalen, was mit deinem Verein passiert, wenn du nicht sofort wieder aufsteigst. Zeitgleich hast du aber in der zweiten Liga so diesen Gap zwischen der ersten und zweiten Liga, dass es unheimlich schwierig wird für dich, als etablierter, in Anführungsstrichen, Zweitligist, da noch mal oben ranzuschmecken und quasi diese Chance zu ergreifen. Und das ist im Endeffekt der Punkt, der für uns so ein bisschen dieses Premier League Dilemma eine Etage tiefer darstellt. Und jetzt geht es auch darum…
wird es durch Geld lösend zu sein? Also auf kurz gedacht ja, klar, mehr Geld hilft immer. Da kann man sowohl kurzfristig in Transfer stecken, als auch langfristig in Steine, also nicht nur in Beine, sondern auch in Steine. Aber gleichzeitig machen ja alle anderen genau das Gleiche. Also alle versuchen ja gerade durch die unterschiedlichsten Konzepte, Ausgliederungen, Öffnen für Investoren und so weiter, sich ein höheres Kapital zu erarbeiten. Und man hat natürlich Angst da, man möchte nicht Waldhof Mannheim sein, von dem man jetzt nichts mehr hört im Profi-Fußball. Und da gibt es noch genügend andere Beispiele. Oder man möchte auch nicht wie Aachen in die zweite Insolvenz gehen. Also ich verstehe das auch, ich finde das alles rational. Aber gleichzeitig frage ich mich, wo sind denn für einen Verein wie den 1. FC Nürnberg jetzt zum Beispiel die großen Hebel? Wo wirklich auch ein nennenswertes Kapital bei rumkäme? Und ich habe den Eindruck, das ist das dahinterliegende große Problem, dass die Internationalisierung des Fußballs, dass eben heutzutage auch in Nürnberg wahrscheinlich viele Kinder mit einem Messi-Trikot herumlaufen und den Club eher langweilig finden, selbst wenn er 1. Liga spielen würde, weil er nur 13. oder 14. Liga spielt. Also wo könnt ihr denn überhaupt noch euch nennenswert Kapital holen?
Also das mit den Jugendlichen, dass sie den langweilen, da muss ich jetzt nicht qua Amt natürlich völlig widersprechen. Natürlich ist er erst zu Nürnberg das Spannendste, was es gibt in der Region.
Da muss man nicht weit über die Stadtgrenzen gehen, um schon ein paar Leute zu finden, die exakt das Regen versagen.
Das wird gekonnt ignoriert. Spätestens seit dem letzten Ergebnis wird das gekonnt ignoriert. Und ja, du hast faktisch recht. Ein Hebel, ein kleiner Hebel, aber so etwas, wo man sagt, man muss in diese ganze Verteilung auch noch mal Werte mit einbringen oder honorieren, wenn Vereine wirklich nachhaltig arbeiten. Das ist zum Beispiel die neue Verteilung nach den local, nach eingesetzten Jugendspielern, ausgebildeten Spielern. Das sind wir – jetzt lass mich nicht lügen – an Platz zwei oder drei sogar in Deutschland von den Profitabellen. Das wird dann auch inzwischen bei der Ausschüttung der Gelder honoriert. Das sind, glaube ich, solche Schlüssel, wo man dann auch versucht, diese Sache ein bisschen gerechter zu machen. Es gab ja lange – und das ist ja auch in Europa keine Seltenheit – Italien macht das zum Beispiel, die dann nach Mitgliedern oder nach Zuschauerzahlen zum Beispiel auch im Stadion das verteilen, was ich eine sehr charmante Idee auch finde. Aber grundsätzlich hast du natürlich auf diesem Wege recht, die Hebe und die Mittel sind begrenzt. Und jetzt reden wir nicht nur beim 1. FC Nürnberg, sondern bei vielen anderen Vereinen. Du hast gerade Vereine genannt, die in einer extrem präkrieren Situation sind. Es reicht übrigens in Anführungsstrichen auch schon ein Abstieg in die dritte Liga, um da ein Gap von, sagen wir mal, 7-8 Millionen rund auf 800.000 Zentralvermarktung zu haben. Das heißt, Summen, die in einem Etat, in den drittligesten, so absurd sind, dass ich mich… Also, das…
Da kriegst du wahrscheinlich Gänsehaut der Angst, wenn du da als einen Bilanzmännchen denkst. Das kann ich auch verstehen. Und es hängen ja auch Arbeitsplätze dran. Also, das darf man ja nicht vergessen. Wir reden hier darüber, dass vergessen wir manche Leute zum Beispiel… Es tut mir leid, wenn wir wieder auf den HSV kommen, aber da gibt es ja genügend Fußballfans da draußen, die jetzt sagen, denen wünsche ich jetzt mal einen Abstieg. Und so sehr ich das irgendwie nachvollziehen kann, so schwierig finde ich es, so etwas zu sagen, weil damit wünscht man de facto auch Geschäftsstellenmitarbeitern die Entlassung.
Und das würde ich niemandem wünschen. Wenn da jetzt ein kleiner Seitenblick mal gestattet sein darf, das vergisst man im Fußball, außer wenn mal wieder ein Schlaglicht passiert, ein tragisches und trauriges Schlaglicht, vergisst man im Fußball Geschäft, jetzt Geschäft im negativen Sinne, sehr oft, dass es um Menschen geht. Man vergisst auch, dass es bei Spielern um Menschen geht.
Ja, man selber vergisst es ja auch, obwohl man sich es vornimmt.
Ja, und die andere Sache, wir haben natürlich auch so diese Problematik, dass in Nürnberg ist es ja gerade ein großes Thema, diese Ausliederungsdebatte mit vielerlei Begleiterscheinungen, den Kritikern, der Fan-Initiative, aber auch der Arbeitsgruppe innerhalb eines Vereins. Wir stellen uns den Verein vor. Ich muss auch sagen, ich bin in vielen Bereichen Traditionalist, aber in der Sache muss ich auch sagen, dass mein Herz nicht an einer Rechtsform hängt, dass ich nicht glaube, dass ich daran jetzt irgendwie das messen würde. Und das wäre natürlich ein Hebel. Aber – und das ist ja auch der Punkt – das ist ein einmaliges Hebel, der sitzen muss, der wirklich mit Partnern sitzen muss, die diesen Weg mitgehen. Und immer mit der latenten Unsicherheit, in der wir uns bewegen, dass wir 50 plus 1 strukturell auch durch den Verband, durch Argumentationen und allerlei andere Aktivitäten gestützt ziehen wollen. Auf der anderen Seite, aber jetzt zum Beispiel auf dem aktuellen Sporbiss, quasi zum Beispiel, ja, 50 plus 1 fällt, die Investoren stehen Schlange. Was ein bisschen sehr im – wo mir irgendwie total der Konjunktiv fehlt, wo ich dachte, habe ich jetzt irgendwas verpasst in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Also das ist ein Sport-Business-Kongress, nur für alle, die es nicht wissen. Ein Festival lese ich gerade so, was? Das wird als Festival verkauft.
Und da geht es um Gürtel. Da redet, glaube ich, unser Vorstand, der Herr Mieske, auch zu so einem Panel eingeladen. Und in dieser Gemengelage bewegt er dich. Das heißt also, du weißt nicht, was passiert in den nächsten zwei, drei, fünf Jahren. Du musst ja in deinem Sinne und qua Auftrag das Allerbeste für den Verein rausholen. Aber du weißt nicht, ob ein Schritt, den du heute vielleicht gehst, ob der in drei oder fünf Jahren schon wieder überholt oder obsolet ist. Und das ist jetzt eine ganz spannende und interessante Zeit, aber auch eine ganz schwierige, in der sich die Vereine einfach auch definieren. Und um in diesem Kontext auch mal zu sagen, so Boombranche. Ich habe von unserem Vorstand, von Herrn Mieske, der war auf dieser DFL-Tagung, wo der Herr Seifert wohl auch gesagt hat, man braucht jetzt mal ein Verständnis oder wirklich eine Initiative, dass man sich zum Kommerz auch ein bisschen bekennt. Und dass man auch ehrlich gesagt, das habe ich heute in einem Podcast gehört, ich mag es ihm nicht in den Mund legen, aber dort wurde quasi sinngemäß darüber diskutiert, dass die Trennung zwischen Profi und Amateure noch größer wird wahrscheinlich in diesem Fall, wenn man sich noch kommerzieller aufstellt und positioniert. Der Fakt ist ja auch, die Fanproteste, die Öffentlichkeit, immer mehr Leute, die sagen, naja, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Auf der anderen Seite aber Steigerungsraten und Wachstumsraten, die wirklich passieren, obwohl so viel Gegenmeinung da ist. Man könnte jetzt vielleicht auch auf die Idee kommen, dass man diese Gegenmeinungen vielleicht gar nicht mehr braucht für das Wachstum. Das ist auch so ein Gedankengang, der gar nicht so weit weg ist aus vermarkter Sicht. Und das ist ja auch diese Krux. Und deshalb ist es auch so furchtbar, also es ist eine furchtbar spannende Zeit. Es ist sehr viel Philosophie, was jetzt gerade so in der Branche geredet wird. Und gerade das Thema 50 plus 1 ja oder nein, Ausgliederungen ja oder nein, das sind auch hochspannende Themen, was sich da auch ein bisschen so definiert, wie sieht denn irgendwie der Fußball bei uns in der Zukunft aus. Aber gleichzeitig ist es halt sehr schwierig, also für mich ganz persönlich schwierig, jetzt die adäquat richtige Lösung zu finden. Das wird wirklich eine sehr, das erfordert eine sehr engagierte Leistung und das erfordert eine sehr, ja, das ist maßgeblicher bei den Vorständen noch aufgehängt, aber als Aufsichtsrat musst du das dann ja auch mittragen. Das ist einfach jetzt wirklich eine spannende Zeit, wo sich wirklich definiert, wie das weitergeht und welcher Verein sich welchen Weg für sich findet.
Geht es da nicht nachgelagert, aber eigentlich hauptsächlich um die Frage, man möchte mehr Geld bekommen und gleichzeitig sind Unternehmen oder Einzelpersonen, die viel Geld bereit sind zu zahlen, heutzutage nicht so erpicht, wenn sie dann nicht Bestimmungsbefugnisse haben. Darum geht es doch eigentlich im Kern der Frage. Und genau das hat man ja im Rahmen der Aufsichtsräte schon so geklärt, dass man sagt, sportlicher Bereich, ihr dürft die entscheidende Person einsetzen, aber ansonsten seid ihr bitte, haltet ihr euch bitte zurück. Wenn jetzt natürlich der etwas komplett anderes macht, als ihr es macht, dann habt ihr die Möglichkeit, den Vorstand zu entlassen und einen neuen zu besetzen, aber ihr haltet euch eigentlich aus diesem sportlichen Bereich raus. Und das ist das Damoclash-Wert, auch hier repräsentiert durch den TSV 1860 München. Jeder Gegner von Ausgliederungen muss dem TSV dankbar sein, dass der Worst-Case hier in Deutschland gerade zu beobachten ist. Du hast einen Investor, der aus seiner Sicht auch vollkommen verständlich sagt, ey, Moment mal, ich gebe die ganze Zeit hier die Kohle, da möchte ich bitte auch mitsprechen und ich weiß so viel von Fußball. Ich spreche jetzt mit seinem Mund und deswegen glaube ich, die und die Leute müssen es jetzt richten. Und wenn ihr das nicht macht, dann gehe ich dagegen mit allem vor, was ich zur Verfügung habe und der Verein ist in einer kompletten Abhängigkeit von ihm. Und das ist ja doch im Grunde das Worst-Case-Szenario, was man sich vorstellen könnte im Rahmen jeder 50 plus 1 oder Ausgliederungsdebatte. Aber ist denn das – aber auf der anderen Seite ist es ja auch völlig unrealistisch zu glauben, dass jemand viel Geld gibt, ohne dass er dann dafür irgendwie mitreden kann. Lässt sich das denn überhaupt auflösen? Ich sehe da so grundsätzlich einfach zwei verschiedene Vorstellungen und ich sehe da keinerlei Vereinbarkeit außerhalb eines Modells, wie man es jetzt mit Aufsichtsräten eigentlich schon hat.
Also es ist – es hängt auch sehr viel mit der 50 plus 1 Regel zusammen. Die 50 plus 1 Regel ja nichts anderes bedeutet, als dass der Verein das Hoheitsrecht und das Bestimmungsrecht hat, über das wie der Verein zu führen ist und welche – ja wie der Verein zu führen ist und dass der Verein auch durch den – durch vom Verein bestätigte Personen geführt werden kann. Du hast in allen Punkten recht. Ich glaube aber einhergehend mit dem, was ich über mich mal gesagt habe, in einen Verein reinzukommen und nicht zu glauben, alles zu wissen, alles zu kennen. Und vor allem eine ganz wichtige Erkenntnis. Und ich habe Leute kennengelernt aus dem klassischen Investmentgeschäft, die an anderer Stelle gesagt haben, das interessiert mich, das finde ich toll, aber ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung. Nur ich erkenne da einen gewissen Wert oder auch nur eine ideelle Liebe, was im Film- und Musikbereich relativ häufig der Fall ist. Und ich investiere da. Aber frag mich bitte nichts, weil ich habe keine Ahnung davon. Das wäre der Idealfall. Das ist aber beim Fußball auch manchmal sehr schwierig, solche Leute zu finden, weil da halt jeder auch mitreden kann. Jeder einen Lieblingsverein hat und jeder im Endeffekt nach drei Spielen sagt, ja das kann ja nicht funktionieren. Also diese Funktionärsruhe, die sollte man unbedingt mitbringen. Das ist wirklich, glaube ich, auch so dieser Weg, den du nur durch Beständigkeit, nur durch Verlässlichkeit und nur durch Vertrauensaufbau schon im Vorfeld als Verein geben kannst, im Sinne von guck mal, wie das bei uns inzwischen seit drei Jahren läuft. Es gibt keine Wasserstandsmeldung jede Woche von irgendwem, irgendwie in irgendeiner Presse. Es gibt keine Skandale, es gibt keine Skandälchen. Es gibt Transfers, die am Tag der Abwicklung bekannt gemacht werden durch die Presseabteilung des Vereins, was Novum ist. Das muss man wirklich so sagen. Das ist aber so, sagen wir bei uns. Und darüber schaffst du das Vertrauen, dass du als Verein im Stande bist, ein Setup hinzustellen, das auch einem potentiellen Investor dieses Vertrauen gibt, im Sinne zu sagen, jawohl, die wissen, was sie tun. Eine andere Chance hast du als Verein, glaube ich, nicht. Aber das ist das Mindeste, was du als Verein auch wirklich tun solltest.
Und muss man dann auch Investoren finden, die aus ideellen Gründen und nicht aus Renditegründen in den Vereinen investieren?
Also einem Investor ist es immanent, dass er investiert, um irgendwann mal Rendite rauszuholen. Aber – jetzt muss ich Utz Klaßen zitieren, was mir extrem schwerfällt – aber es gibt auch eine emotionale Rendite, die durchaus auch etwas wert sein kann. Und wenn du ein Verein bist, bei dem es für die investierenden Unternehmen gut ist, sich dort in dem Schein auch ein bisschen zu sonnen zu sein, wir haben hier ein Setup, wir haben hier eine Idee, wir verfolgen hier gemeinsame Ziele, was wir zum Beispiel in extrem hohem Maße mit unserem aktuellen Hauptsponsor der Nürnberger Versicherung haben, also quasi im klassischen Sponsoring, aber wo du auch merkst, das sind ganz andere Verbindungsstränge und ganz andere Dinge, die gemeinsam auch betrieben werden, weil beide Seiten auch wirklich Spaß und Lust auf diese Partnerschaft haben, dann glaube ich, ist das im Endeffekt auch möglich, dass sich jemand da auch anderweitig aussieht. Und auf der anderen Seite, alle Prognosen oder die meisten Prognosen sprechen schlicht und ergreifend trotzdem dafür, dass es sich beim Fußball – Geschäft, in Anführungsstrichen – um eine Wachstumsbranche handelt, die durchaus auch mittelfristig diese Anteile quasi mit Gewinnen verzinsen kann. Darauf bauen natürlich auch viele, das ist richtig.
Ach, ich könnte ja noch so lange mit dir drüber diskutieren, aber ich will dich auch nicht ständig über andere Vereine urteilen lassen. Aber du hast vorhin gesprochen, dass man ja auch so ein bisschen – es ist eine sehr spannende Zeit und man orientiert sich so ein bisschen an anderen. An welchen anderen Vereinen würdest du denn jetzt sagen, du sprichst nicht für den kompletten Aufsichtsrat, aber nur für dich sollte sich der 1. FC Nürnberg orientieren?
Ich beobachte Vereine. Orientierung ist jetzt zu viel gesagt, aber ich beobachte Vereine. Durch einen familiären Kontakt habe ich zum SC Freiburg, mein Cousin arbeitet da. Da habe ich auch durchaus mal das ein oder andere Gespräch geführt mit so einer Teilungsleiterin. Übrigens, das muss man auch sagen, wer sich für irgendetwas in dieser Fußballbranche interessiert. Das ist eine extrem offene Branche. Es wird also keinem die Tür vor der Nase zugeschlagen, gerade nicht, wenn er eine gute Idee hat. Stichwort digitale Transformation gerade. Gerne einfach mal hingehen und einfach mal fragen. Das ist aber so ein Nebenbei. Das machen, glaube ich, die ganzen digitale Sportmanager-Podcasts.
Ja, da gibt es auch einige. Und wir unterhalten uns, erwähnt hier gerade ein paar Kilometer weiter nördlich bei den FC Bayern Hack Days. Da werden neue digitale Projekte entwickelt werden.
Und da beobachte ich den SC Freiburg, weil er für sich für mich auf eine ganz faszinierende Art und Weise, unabhängig von der Rechtsform, EV, sich ganz klar auch dazu bekannt, sich eine modernere Struktur gegeben hat mit einem Aufsichtsrat, vorher hatte der keinen Aufsichtsrat. Das muss man vielleicht dazu sagen. Es ist nicht zwingend notwendig, dass ein Verein einen Aufsichtsrat hat. Das ist mir so eher eine Freiwillige Leistung. Manche Vereine wünschen sich dann vielleicht auch, dass sie diese Entscheidung nicht getroffen haben.
Das ist wie 50 plus 1. Du kannst den Hebel nicht mehr in die andere Richtung legen.
Das fasziniert mich halt, wie die sich ein Selbstverständnis gegeben haben, das ganz klar positioniert ist. Dieses, was treibt euch an, was ich vorhin in meiner Abschlussarbeit zeigte, dort steht beim SC Freiburg aus diesem riesengroßen Rat, wir wollen immer einer der Top-20-Vereine in Deutschland sein. Und Top-20, dann ist es jetzt eine mathematische Aufgabe, es sind im Moment 18 Erstligavereine. Ah, okay. Die rechnen also quasi in ihre Philosophie, immer damit, dass es auch durchaus mal in die zweite Liga gehen kann. Und dadurch, dass sie das so offensiv und so gut vertreten, nimmt man es denen ab. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was ganz eminent wichtig ist, dass du einen Verein so kleiner auch sein mag und so international auch vielleicht unbedeutend für die Vermarktung sein mag, aber dass du ihm dieses Image abnimmst und darauf etwas aufbaust. Und andere Vereine, die ich dann beobachte, die mag ich jetzt nicht nennen, weil sie sehr viel mit den negativen Dingen – häufiger Gremienwechsel, hier und da, Sportvorstand entlassen, Sportvorstand eingestellt, Sportvorstand wieder entlassen – tatsächlich als malende Beispiele, wie man es besser nicht macht, auch wenn es mal richtig kracht im Gebälde.
Okay, ich glaube, da hat jede Hörerin und jeder Hörer schon ein paar Ideen im Kopf. Wer das so sein könnte, da will ich auch nichts aus dir rauslocken. Jetzt sag mir mal, warum braucht ein Bundesliga-Verein eine E-Sports-Abteilung und was wird in eurer E-Sports-Abteilung gemacht?
Also, die E-Sports-Abteilung ist bei uns erstmal beschränkt auf das fußballaffine Thema FIFA. Das heißt also, anders als zum Beispiel der FC Schalke, die auch eine League of Legends-Mannschaft haben, weil wir uns gesagt haben – oder andersrum gesagt, es ist so eine Sache, wo du quasi relativ leicht Fuß fasst und wie wir gemerkt haben, wo du auch eine Zielgruppe näher an den Verein holen kannst – man mag es wirklich kaum glauben – die schon fußballaffin ist, die aber völlig andere Siehgewohnheit hat. Und das ist für uns eigentlich so ein weiterer Punkt.
Und ist das noch eine Arbeitsthese? Da hat sich das auch schon bewiesen. Wie lange gibt es dies?
Die hat sich jetzt in dieser Saison erst gebildet. Das wurde jetzt im Sommer aufgesetzt. Wir haben zwei Spiele. Arne, den Buhu, der auch schon deutscher Meister war. Und die eigentlich so in diesen – die liegen, soweit ich das überblicken kann – ganz gut vorne liegen. Und Hens Soh, auch als junger Spieler. Ganz interessanter Mensch, der selber zum Beispiel noch Landesliga-Fußball spielt. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, deren Taktikverständnis ist schon sehr interessant, weil das, was bei FIFA offensichtlich passiert, sehr, sehr nahe an der klassischen Fußballtaktik dran ist. Und das finde ich hoch spannend und interessant. Und es hat sich auf vielen Bereichen schon bewährt. Und es ist auch die Erfahrung, die andere Vereine schon mit ihren E-Sports-Abteilungen gemacht haben. Jetzt mal ganz salopp gesagt, wenn du zwei Jungs im Trikot eines Vereins quer durch die Welt schicken kannst und erreichst an gewissen Stellen dieser Welt nahezu denselben Effekt, als würde deine erste Mannschaft ein Freundschaftsspiel gegen den lokalen Erstligisten spielen, dann ist das schon sehr außergewöhnlich. Und das ist bei anderen schon ein bisschen weiter fortgeschritten, auch ein bisschen messbarer. Und bei uns geht es auch in diese Tendenz, dass das wirklich auch so ein Ding ist, dass man wirklich dem Fußballsport, auch dem klassischen Fußball, auch beifüttern kann, um dieses Thema 1. FC Nürnberg weiter zu transportieren und zu verstärken. Nicht abzulenken in eine völlig andere Ecke, weil das würde bedeuten, dass du sagst, irgendwann wird eSports eh den Fußball ablösen. Aber du hast es vorhin gesagt, vielleicht wird unsere Zukunft mal sein, dass die Leute nur noch zu Hause zugucken. Im Fußball wäre das fatal, fatal beim E-Sports ist es so, dass die Events vor Ort jetzt immer größer werden. Also eine umgekehrte Entwicklung, das ist auch ganz spannend. Und ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich habe mich schon mal mit einem, kurz bei einem Auswärtsspiel von uns in Düsseldorf, mit jemandem unterhalten können, der einer solchen kompletten Mannschaft vorsteht. Und das war wirklich hochinteressant. Und für mich war, was ich aus diesem Gespräch mitgenommen habe, ist die Begeisterung. Wenn die Begeisterung für dieses Ding echt ist, also der Elan und wie die Zuschauer dabei sind und so, dann ist es für dich auch als Verein grundsätzlich immer spannend.
Aber im Grunde seid ihr ja so eine Art Sponsor, oder ist es geplant, dass die E-Sports-Abteilung auch mal eigene Gewinne abwirft?
Die E-Sports-Abteilung hat schon ihren ersten eigenen Sponsor. Die E-Sports-Abteilung ist durchaus etwas, was sich trägt, tragen soll. Die E-Sports-Abteilung ist jetzt meines Wissens nach – da müssten wir jetzt mal den Kollegen, der die verantwortet, den Herrn Seiwart, fragen – wie die als Profit-Center oder irgendwas angelegt ist. Aber wovor wir uns nicht verschließen können, das ist, wenn E-Sport in ähnlicher Art und Weise interessant wird. Wenn dann zum Beispiel diese E-Sport-Bundesliga analog zu Österreich gegründet wird, wo man schon mal über den Tellerrand geguckt hat, wie ist das da? Es ist schon irgendwie interessant, wenn Rapid gegen den Lask spielt oder so auf der Konsole. Weil da ist schon die emotionale Verbundenheit zum Hauptverein oder so. Das ist schon da und das könnte auch wirklich spannend werden. Und ich glaube auch, dass das durchaus in einem gewissen Rahmen erfolgreich ist. Aber wir werden uns dann nicht davor verschließen, wird es in ähnlicher Weise erfolgreich. Dann wird es auch in ähnlicher Weise und sehr viel schneller, weil vorgelebt durch den realen Fußball zu ähnlichen Entwicklungen kommen. Zu Spielertransfers. Wie es ja auch schon passiert ist. Von Schalke weg zu… sagst du?
Ich weiß es gerade auch nicht. Aber es gibt die erste Transfers.
Und das ist halt auch eine Entwicklung, die ich mit Spannung beobachte. Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, was mich überzeugt hat an dieser Sache, ist, dass diese Begeisterung von den Spielern und auch von den Fans, die das mittragen, einfach wirklich echt ist.
Das ist definitiv so. Es wird auch demnächst mal im Rasenfunk noch mal ausführlicher Thema werden, denn ich finde es auch sehr faszinierend, schon seit einigen Jahren. Aber bisher ist das Engagement, dass die meisten Bundesliga-Vereine haben, vor allem eben das, was du gesagt hast. Ich nutze quasi jemanden, der eine eigene Reichweite hat, in einem hochemotionalen Umfeld als Werbeträger. Er trägt meine Farben, mein Trikot ins Land. Und dann kommen auch wieder Leute mit dem Club in Verbindung, die wahrscheinlich sonst nicht damit in Verbindung gekommen wären. Ich bin gespannt, wann oder ob da ein Switch irgendwann stattfindet. Also wenn man zum Beispiel mit Angestellten des FC Bayern über das Thema E-Sport spricht, da kannst du dir vorstellen, klingelt das Telefon an jeden Tag mindestens einmal und irgendeine tolle Agentur oder irgendein Spieler beratet, gibt es ja schon alles in dem Bereich, schlägt denen vor, dass sie was gründen sollen. Dann redest du mit denen darüber, als würden die jetzt sowas wie den FC Bayern Basketball nochmal neu gründen. Also eine komplett eigenständige Abteilung, wo es dann auch eigentlich nicht mehr wichtig wäre, ob der E-Sportler hier aus München umgekehrt kommt oder ob das nicht der Kleine in der Rannisch ist, den man sich jetzt eingekauft hat. Letztlich werden jetzt viele wohlwollend und nicht wohlwollend mit dem Kopf nicken. So funktioniert der FC Bayern ja heute schon, wenn man sich ganz ehrlich ist. Aber es ist ein eigenes Thema, das werde ich demnächst noch mal lernen.
Ich habe da auch ein paar Sachen gehört. Ich glaube sogar in Podcasts – ich bin begeisterter Sportpostkars-Hörer – warum sich zum Beispiel die TSG Offenheim ganz explizit dagegen entschieden hat und diese Gedanken gegenüber Überlegungen.
Die Bayern ja bisher auch. Die haben da gute Gründe für.
Auch das finde ich hoch interessant und hoch spannend. Für uns ist es tatsächlich wirklich eine Form gewesen, wie jetzt gerade beschrieben, warum wir das machen. Und nach dem ersten halben Jahr kann man sagen, genau das tritt eigentlich ein, warum wir das machen wollen.
Genau. Wie es ist weiterentwickelt, kann man Ihnen nicht sagen, aber viele spekulieren darauf, dass E-Sports in einzelnen Disziplinen – FIFA ist da jetzt noch nicht gemeint – aber mal olympisch wird und das halt nicht vollkommen ausgeschlossen.
Nein. Also wenn man es aus den athletischen und herinsportlichen Gründen sieht, könnte es schwierig werden, wenn man es rein von Reichweite, von Vermarktungsmöglichkeiten sieht, wobei man ja aber auch weiß, dass die olympischen Spiele ein hochgradig, sagen wir mal so unkommerzielles Event sind.
Ja, da geht es nur um den Geist des Sports.
Genau, richtig. Also nein, da teile ich die Meinung, auch wenn ich es selbst sehr abstrakt finde, aber das habe ich mir auch wirklich in diesen ganzen Jahren jetzt antrainiert, über solche Sachen oder für solche Sachen einfach offen und neu zu sein.
Genau, man glaubt auch einfach nicht, welcher Aufwand dahinter steht. Und wenn wir so etwas wie Darts alle feiern, da steckt auch – die sportliche Leistung bedeutet auch viel Training. Und genau dasselbe machen die E-Sportler auch. Ich lese immer sehr, sehr viel Kritik von Fußballfans gegenüber E-Sports, eben mit dem klassischen Argument, das ist ja überhaupt gar kein Sport, die sitzen ja nur in der Konsole. Und ja, stimmt, die rennen natürlich nicht durch ihr Gegend, aber unterschätzt man nicht den Aufwand, den die betreiben. Und das ist von der Konzentration, von der Koordination her vergleichbar mit so… Eigentlich ist es für mich wie Darts noch neuer und digitaler.
Ja, das kann man…
Die trainieren auch Teile ihres Körpers, genauso ist es mit den E-Sportlern auch, die trainieren auch genauso viel. Es geht um Präzision und sie spielen es in einer Halle, die total ausflippt und müssen sich da konzentrieren.
Ja, und sechs bis acht Stunden Training, Vorbereitung sind überhaupt keine Seltenheit. Das schaffen Fußballer tatsächlich selten.
Doping leider auch nicht mehr, aber das ist jetzt wieder ein anderes Thema. Das Doping einfach überall, naja gut, ein anderes Thema. So, jetzt haben wir E-Sport auch schon abgehakt. Ich würde noch gerne kurz mit dir über das ganze Thema Digitalisierung und wie sich auch generell der Fußball verändert hat sprechen. Ich habe da auch gerade über den 1. FC Nürnberg schon einiges gehört, kenne da auch ein paar Leute, mit denen ich schon häufiger darüber gesprochen habe. Es ist nicht hinweg zu diskutieren, dass die Digitalisierung auch den Fußball sehr verändert, und zwar in allen Bereichen. Was Trainingslehre angeht, was Scouting angeht, was Spielbeobachtung angeht, was Ernährungspläne angeht, überall wird es digitaler. Und auch all das, was mit dem Verdienen von Euros zu tun hat, wird digitaler. Die Fanshops müssen digitalisiert werden. Wer heutzutage keinen mobil optimierten Fanshop mehr hat, der braucht gar erst antreten im sportlichen Wettbewerb der Fanshops und so weiter und so fort. Und so wie in jeder Industrie ist auch im Fußball das eine Transformation, die unter großen Schmerzen geschieht, weil in der Regel man sich dafür externes Know-how holen muss und auch die Bereitschaft haben muss, sich darauf einzulassen. Wie siehst du denn die Entwicklung? Jetzt mal für den 1. FC Nürnberg gesprochen.
Ja, ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich hauptberuflich aus einer Branche komme, die diese digitale Transformation auch unter Schmerzen absolviert hat.
Was ging das in der Musikbranche nicht einfach so geschmeidend?
Ja, aus völlig anderen Gründen. Nämlich, sie wurde jahrelang negiert und dann wurde sie quasi torpediert und dann lasst alle Hoffnung fahren, weil der Kunde im Endeffekt sich, wenn er denn die technischen Möglichkeiten hat, sich nicht vorschreiben lassen will, was und wann und wie er etwas zu konsumieren hat, was schlussendlich dazu führt, dass wir heute in einer – im digitalen Bereich zumindest – eine Streamingwelt leben, die ganz fantastische Sachen macht. Gerade haben wir einen Newcomer aus Augsburg, zwei junge Leute, die mit ihrer ersten Single einfach mal so um die 170.000 Streams haben, was man vor zwei, drei, vier Jahren überhaupt nicht für möglich gehalten hätte, nur weil der Song da jetzt halt einfach mal hoch gepusht wurde bei Spotify. Aber im Endeffekt ist halt das, was dann dahinter klemmt, es ist immer eine Entwicklung gewesen, die nicht aus der Musikindustrie kommt, sondern tatsächlich immer von dritten. Sei es Apple, sei es alle anderen Dinge, die revolutionär waren im Musikgeschäft. Und das ist etwas, was mich immer so ein bisschen umtreibt, weil ich sage, für mich hat das immer noch so eine andere Bewandtnis. Und deshalb habe ich für mich ganz persönlich, soweit es mir möglich ist, ich bin jetzt kein digitaler, absolut affiner Mensch dahingehend, dass ich sage, ich wüsste jetzt, dass wir das und das und das und den nehmen machen, ich bin hochinteressiert, den nehmen müssen, ich bin hochinteressierter Mensch, ich höre da auch viele Podcasts dazu. Da gibt es ja so einige Spezialisten, die alle immer unglaublich gut aussehen auf den Bildern. Ist dir das schon mal aufgefallen?
Nein, wir haben keinen. Das ist vielleicht der Grund, warum der Rasenfunk keine Bilder verwenden.
Deshalb ist es mir auch wichtig und deshalb finde ich das auch sehr gut, dass der Vorstand das von sich aus in extremer Maße angestoßen und auch gepusht hat. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von jetzt die digitale Transformation durchzuziehen, sondern zu sagen, ok, Analyse, Bedarfsgruppen innerhalb des Vereins zusammenzustellen und dann erst mal zu definieren, was bedeutet für uns die digitale Transformation. Es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, ja, dieses Digitale – wir waren gerade beim Thema, das E-Sport Zeug halt – das ist auch legitim, es gehört am Ende auch ein bisschen damit dazu. Aber tatsächlich ist es etwas anderes gemeint und zwar die Übersetzung der klassischen Vereinsarbeit in allen Bereichen in die digitale Welt und zwar nicht um der Digitalisierung willen, sondern zum Nutzen der Bedarfsgruppen, zum Nutzen des Vereins. Und da ist Smart Data, da ist Big Data, du hast gesagt, die Fanshops zum Beispiel, das Ticketing, ganz klassisch, dass du quasi Print-at-Home machen kannst, dass du trotzdem damit mit der S-Bahn fahren kannst, wie so zum Stadion. Diese kleinen Dinge, die jeder versteht, aber für uns ist halt auch Big Data sehr intensiv und sehr wichtig. Wir arbeiten da mit einem großen Hersteller zusammen, durch unseren Finanzdirektor, sind wir da in so einer Spezialkruppe, unter anderem auch mit dem FC Bayern München in der Entwicklung und Statistik und so. Das ist auch ein ganz großer Vorteil. Und da geht es eben wirklich darum, Daten zu sammeln, Daten so aufzubereiten, dass sie dir in den verschiedensten Bereichen helfen. Also das Klassische, was man zum Beispiel von anderen Unternehmen auch kennt, ist die direkte Kundenansprache, die richtige Kundenansprache, auch das Aussteuern von Sortimenten, zum Beispiel Category Management im Fanshop, diese ganzen Dinge. Auf der anderen Seite ist es sehr im diagnostischen und medizinischen Bereich, zum Beispiel. Und dann wiederum das zu verknüpfen mit dem sportlichen Bereich, sprich in die Mannschaft rein. Gesamtheitliche Bilder für den Trainer zum Beispiel zu machen, den einzelnen Spielern auch Dinge auszuspielen für das nächste Spiel, Vorbereitungen auf die nächsten Gegner und solche ganzen Geschichten. Und das ist im Endeffekt gemeint mit der Digitalisierung. Und du hast ja zum Beispiel schon angesprochen, das Scouting zum Beispiel zu effektiv, dass da quasi in ein System eingelagert wird, wo man dann quasi auch seine verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, die viel zitierte Schattenelf, die ja jeder Verein hat, Schattenelf bedeutet, also quasi die Spieler, die man möglicherweise holen könnte in der nächsten Saison. Solche Dinge, das ist ja auch immer so ein geflügelter Begriff. Und das ist im Endeffekt die digitale Transformation. Das klingt jetzt alles immer sehr einleuchtend und sehr einfach. Aber ich habe gemerkt, dass es gerade im Fußball, wo es teilweise auch noch auf hochprofessioneller Ebene sehr eicharisch, sehr anti-digital zugeht, man durchaus auch die eine oder andere Überredungskunst braucht, um den Leuten zu erklären, das ist nicht mehr Arbeit für dich, sondern dann ist unglaublicher Nutzen für den Verein. Und da sind wir aber, glaube ich, auf einem guten Weg, weil unser Vorstand das sofort wirklich Arbeitsgruppen eingeführt hat. Und nicht im Sinne von, so, wir digitalisieren jetzt, sondern Leute, erzählt uns doch mal, wie ist der Arbeitsalltag, wie sieht das aus, und da wird sich Pöa Pöa vorgearbeitet. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau das richtige Argument. Und für mich ist das irgendwie auch so ein Kernthema, auch wenn ich nicht Teil dieser Arbeitsgruppen bin, auch wenn ich persönlich viel zu wenig weiß über Abläufe und über Strukturen. Also ich weiß, was man draus lesen kann. Ich weiß, ich kenne den Vorteil, den ich mir erhoffe für den Verein. Aber ich habe das eben einmal mitgemacht, was passiert, wenn so eine Entwicklung komplett von einer gesamten Branche verschlafen wird.
Das wirst du nicht noch mal erleben.
Nein, das möchte ich nicht. Tatsächlich.
Sind das dann solche Themen, über die dann im Aufsichtsrat auch viel diskutiert wird? Also allein wir könnten jetzt hier schon eine halbe Stunde über Digitalisierung sprechen. Und wir sprechen ja noch gar nicht darüber, dass dafür dann noch Budgets freigegeben werden müssen. Da wird es ja dann eigentlich mal knackig. Also man kann mit den Leuten immer ganz tolle Wolkenschlösser bauen. Das erlebe ich in meinem anderen Beruf auch immer mal wieder. Da gibt es auch einige Konkurrenten, die damit ihr Geld verdienen. Aber wenn es dann an die Umsetzung geht, dann wird es sehr, sehr viel schwieriger und auch an das Bezahlen. Sind das so die wesentlichen Themen, über die gerade gesprochen wird bei euch im Aufsichtsrat?
Ja, das ist sicherlich auch eins der Themen, über das dadurch, dass wir ja wissen, dass es gerade fortschreitet und in dem Arbeits- und Entwicklungsprozess ist, eher berichtet wird. Aber dazu gibt es dann natürlich auch immer die eine oder andere Nachfrage tatsächlich. Und auch vielleicht den einen oder anderen Tipp, man hat dieses oder jenes gehört. Wie gesagt, es gibt ja vielfältige Informationsquellen dafür und das wird dann auch immer aufgenommen. Und das ist schon ein Thema, das aber jetzt quasi so die klassischen Aufsichtsratssitzungen nicht beherrscht, sondern wirklich ein Thema, abseits dessen ist mal so ein Vier-Augen-Gespräch oder mal nach dem Spiel solche Themen aufpassen. Oder übrigens, da ist was Neues, da habe ich was. Und wir müssen sagen, dass wir da auch großes Glück haben, dass wir inzwischen eine Struktur im Verein haben, wo es nicht so ist. Oder sagen wir andersrum, wir haben eine Struktur im Verein, wo Hinweise, sofern sie irgendwie auch merklich nützlich sind, sehr positiv aufgenommen werden. Und das ist einfach eine Atmosphäre, die halt dann auch es leicht macht, mal diesen oder jenen Tipp zu geben, anstelle zu sagen, ah, sag ich jetzt lieber nichts, weil wenn man findet, das ist wirklich irgendeiner blöd. Das ist auch im Endeffekt so ein Teil der, ja, wenn man so will, im Endeffekt der Vereins- und Unternehmenskultur, wie du sowas führst und wie du sowas anlegst. Und das wird natürlich von oben vorgelebt, definitiv.
Und hängt ja auch wesentlich ab von dem Zahnrad, was ihr noch gerade definiert. Bevor der 1.
Da wissen die Kollegen noch gar nichts davon, dass es dieses Zahnrad, das zu definieren ist. Weil das ist so meine eigene grafische Idee. Aber es ist im Endeffekt schon so, dass das ganz klar vor drei Jahren ein Weg der Konsolidierung angestreht und bestritten wurde, der irgendwann mal darin münden muss, dass du eine Idee eines Vereins entwickelst. Der mit diesem Konzept ein tragbares und belastbares Konzept wirklich rauskommt. Und in dieser Entscheidungs- und Entwicklungsphase befinden wir uns gerade.
Weißt du, was ich mir wünschen würde für dieses Zahnrad? Ich würde mir wünschen, dass da nicht nur eine sportliche Perspektive draufsteht, wie wir es vorhin beim SC Freiburg genannt haben, sondern dass da auch noch Werte draufstehen, im Rahmen derer man das erreichen will. Oder man dann eben sagt, wenn sich der Fußball bis dahin so verändert hat, wir alle wissen ja nicht, vielleicht kommen ja noch 15 Raber Leipzigs. Und dann ist in den Top 20 zu bleiben vielleicht gar nicht mehr möglich, wenn man nicht bestimmte andere Werte über einen Haufen wirft. Das fände ich schön, weil das ist das, was viele Vereine vorgeben, gemacht zu haben. Unter anderem ja hier auch der FC Bayern mit Samir Samir, hat da ja auch mal ein ganz tolles Leitbild entwickelt, dass da zwölf Kerntesen drin stecken. Und in den entscheidenden Positionen, die dann getroffen werden müssen und wo man sich dann positionieren kann, erlebt man immer mal wieder, dass da dann ein Auge zugunsten des wirtschaftlichen Erfolgs dann doch zugedrückt wird.
Ja, die Frage ist, inwieweit kann man sich es leisten, es nicht zu tun.
Ja, aber genau, das ist auch keine triviale Frage. Das ist das, worüber wir vorhin schon diskutiert haben. Ich glaube aber, wenn man sich darauf einmal verständigt hat, dass es um so grundsätzliche Werte geht, es geht mir jetzt nicht darum, dass man da reinschreibt, wir wollen nie mehr als 20 Millionen für ein Spiel ausgeben, wäre völlig unprofessionell, so was reinzuschreiben. Aber dass man zum Beispiel sagt, die jugendlichen Spieler sollen immer eine Rolle spielen, es soll immer eine feste Bindung zur Region geben, die Mannschaft soll in der Region verankert sein, solche Dinge. Und die Umstände, das kann sein, dass diese Verankerung in der Region wird sehr wahrscheinlich in 15 Jahren komplett anders aussehen als jetzt gerade, aber sie ist genauso wichtig. Und wenn dann später vielleicht aber irgendwann mal eine Entscheidung zu fällen ist, bei der man sagt, okay, da würden wir aber ein ganzes Stück weit uns von der kompletten Region entheben, zum Beispiel es kommt ein Investor, der Investor, dem bis dahin der 1. FC Nürnberg gehört nach der Ausgliederung, alles ist schiefgegangen und dann sagt er, so jetzt zieht er aber um nach Ingolstadt, dann könnte man sagen, nein, Moment mal.
Wo zieht denn dann Ingolstadt hin?
Ach, das weiß ich doch nicht. Die sind bis dahin Bayern 2.
Ja, das sind sehr destruktive Gedankengänge.
Ja, nein, du weißt ja, dass ich ein Negativbeispiel aufmache. Aber ich finde den dahinter stehenden Gedanken eigentlich wichtig. So wie der Wirtschaftliche nicht ohne den sportlichen Erfolg geht, so finde ich, sollte man in dem, was man sich als Sportverein für Ziel setzt, nie einen sportlichen Erfolg ohne ein moralisches, ein zu hartes Wort oder ein zu hohes Wort eigentlich zu hochtrabend. Aber man steht ja als Verein für etwas. Es gibt ja einen Grund, warum Sportvereine auch eine Rolle haben in der Gesellschaft, in der Region usw. Und ich finde, das muss man einmal zum Papier bringen, und zwar mehr als nur, dass man sagt, mir sein mir, das ist mir zu wenig. Weil das wird nämlich immer nur hervorgeholt, wenn es gerade mal passt.
Ich verstehe, was du meinst. Und mit belastbar und tragfähiges Konzept meine ich auch, dass das jetzt keine schönen Worte sind. Bei uns wird ja auch ein Leitbild vorgegeben und Leitbild gelebt. Aber es ist im Endeffekt schon so, dass dieses Modell dann nicht beim ersten Windsturm oder bei der ersten Böe sofort umgeht und sagt, ja, das haben wir ja alles nur so hingesagt, also jetzt müssen wir das ganz anders machen. Und da gehört die regionale Verankerung und auch dieses, den Club wieder erliebbar machen. Jetzt also auch so ein geflügeltes Wort, das gehört für uns schon dazu, dass wir uns genau darüber Gedanken machen. Weil wir halt auch glauben, oder das ist meine persönliche Meinung jetzt, für mich ist dieser Weg auch verhältnismäßig alternativlos, diesen Verein weiterzubringen und weiter zu treiben, unabhängig davon, was auf finanzieller und wirtschaftlicher Ebene, auf gesellschaftlicher Ebene, auf Ausgliederungs-Ebene irgendwann mal passieren wird. Das, was wahrgenommen wird, ist das, was vor dieser Mauer, der Rest der passiert irgendwo in Rechenzentren oder sonst irgendwas oder in irgendwelchen Gesellschaftsversammlungen. Aber das, was vor der Mauer ist, das, was für die Menschen erliebbar ist, das kannst du ja trotzdem nach deinem Gusto ausgestalten. Da ist meine ganz persönliche Meinung, dass du dann schon diesen Ansatz brauchst, dass in der Region, in Nürnberg hat ein großes Hinterland, ganz traditionell. Also ich bin jetzt aus Kulmbach, ich fahre 110 Kilometer nach Nürnberg und ich bin kein Einzelfall. Teilweise von Hof, von überall her bis runter.
Sogar aus Würzburg?
Ja, ein ganz großer Teil unserer Fans kommt aus Würzburg. Und das ist schon ein Einzugsgebiet, das ein bisschen außergewöhnlich ist in dem Bereich. Aber es ist halt eine lange gewachsene Fan-Kultur und Fan-Tradition. Und das wirklich auch wieder in den Vordergrund zu rücken. Jetzt setze ich noch mal an und jetzt mache ich den Punkt, weil ich glaube, wir haben gar keine andere Chance, uns anderweitig zu definieren. Wir werden nie einer dieser Weltvereine sein, der von zehn Jahren sieben oder achtmal in Europa spielt. Ich glaube, diesen Traum müssen wir auch so ein Stück weit abschreiben. Und selbst wenn wir mal Sechster werden, reicht es nicht für einen Europapokal. Und dann brauchst du etwas, womit du dich auch wirklich definieren kannst gegenüber anderen. Ich glaube, dass diese Abgrenzung – klingt jetzt negativ, aber ist nichts anderes als wirklich gegenüber anderen – sich einen Vorteil dahingehend zu verschaffen, dass man hört diesen Namen und man verbindet immer sofort XYZ. Und der 1. FC Nürnberg stand jahrelang auch zu schlechten Zeiten immer für sein riesengroßes Hinterland, was übrigens sogar der FC Paul Breitner in seinem Buch – Ich will kein Vorbild sein – das wurde mir irgendwann in den 80er-Jahren auf den Geburtstag geschenkt und da steht auch drin, dass der 1. FC Nürnberg ein riesiges Hinterland hat.
Ja, und dann hat Casper sogar seine zweite Platte danach benannt, wer hätte das gedacht? Nein, die dritte war es. Ist das nicht – glaubst du, dass du in fünf bis zehn Jahren noch mit demselben Elan solche Diskussionen führen kannst oder besteht, wenn man in diesem Fußballgeschäft länger involviert ist, nicht die Gefahr des permanenten Frustes, der dann im schlimmsten Fall Inszenismus überschlägt? Denn du sprichst jetzt ein großes Wort gelassen aus, nämlich wir werden nicht achtmal Europa League spielen oder international spielen in den nächsten zehn Jahren. Ich glaube, das ist etwas, da geht jeder Verantwortliche mit. Aber selbst die kleinen Träume werden ja in der aktuellen Entwicklung des Fußballs immer unrealistischer. Also auch ein Pokalsieg für den 1. FC Nürnberg ist immer noch möglich. Aber ich würde nicht allzu viel Geld draufsetzen, dass das unbedingt wirklich in den nächsten 10, 15, vielleicht sogar 20 Jahren passiert. Und eigentlich ist das ja etwas sehr Frustrierendes, denn man liebt das Spiel, man liebt seine Mannschaft. Aber diese Mannschaft tritt ja in einem Wettbewerbsumfeld an, in dem es etwas zu gewinnen gibt und irgendwie möchte doch jeder Fan auch mal etwas gewinnen. Und dann reicht es auch nicht, dass dieser Gewinn ist, hey, wir sind nicht abgestiegen oder wir sind jetzt wieder Zehnter geworden. Das hat man jetzt auch an verschiedenen Beispielen, finde ich, schon ganz gut ablesen können. Da ist Mainz 05 ein ganz tolles Beispiel. Mit einer irren Euphorie gestartet und auf einmal nicht mal mehr in der Europa League des Stadion ausverkauft.
Ja, also wenn du mich so, also die Eingangsfrage war ja, ob ich mit demselben Elan noch dabei bin. Das kann ich dir tatsächlich nicht mal versprechen für September oder Oktober, wenn die nächste, also meine Zeit endet turnusmäßig. Ob ich mich noch mal zur Wahl stelle, das kann ich heute auch noch nicht sagen. Ich weiß nur, dass es mir gerade unheimlich viel Spaß macht, dass sich dieser ganze Verein in einer Aufbruchstimmung befindet. Auch natürlich durch die sportlichen Ergebnisse beflügelt momentan. Da, wo wir jetzt hier sitzen, sind wir gerade Tabellen dritter. Aber das kann ich nicht versprechen. Es hängt aber auch mit dem, was du dann nach dieser Frage gesagt hast. Es hängt für mich auch ein bisschen davon an, wo sich der Fußball ganz allgemein hin entwickelt. Ich habe ja einen sehr euphorischen und auch sehr eigenwilligen Ansatz dieses gesamtheitlichen Fußballs, wo sich alle Bedarfsgruppen treffen und zu einer Einheit werden und sagen, dazu sagen wir alle Ja. Dann ist erst mal fünf Jahre das Arbeiten an diesem großen Ziel. Abseits irgendwelcher möglicher Störgeräusche oder so. Ich glaube, das wäre meiner Meinung nach sogar ein Punkt, wo ich dann sagen würde, ja, dann könnte ich dir heute schon zu sagen, dass ich noch in 20 Jahren Lust drauf habe. Aber dieser Ansatz ist natürlich auch ein sehr unausformulierter, er ist ein sehr euphorischer und er ist wie gesagt einer, der mir aufgrund vielfältiger momentaner Diskussionen und Handlungsstränge nicht sehr realistisch erscheint. Das ist leider so. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber im Endeffekt schon so, dass es dann wichtig ist, wie sich der Fußball oder wohin sich der Fußball entwickelt. Ich habe das vorhin schon gesagt, auf der einen Seite haben wir sehr große Themen zur Fanunzufriedenheit, das ja so thematisch von einem kleinen Teil, vermeintlich kleinen Teil, der aktiven Fansinnen getragen wird, aber von der Meinung her, von einem sehr großen Teil, vornehmlich auch der Stadiongänger, das merke ich auch in Gesprächen bei Fanclubs draußen oder ganz allgemein im Stadion. Das ist übrigens keine Meinung, die Kurvengänger explizit für sich haben oder nur Gegenrate. Auch Haupttribünenleute in der Loge sehen diese Entwicklung durchaus ähnlich. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir aber – ich habe es vorhin schon erwähnt – Steigerungsraten. Jetzt mag ich nichts falsches sagen, aber mir ist diese Woche alleine die zweite Liga, die im Zuschauerbereich Steigerungsraten von bis zu 30 Prozent hat, obwohl Stuttgart und Hannover die Liga verlassen haben, also zwei sogenannte Dickschiffe. Das alles spricht im Endeffekt momentan für den kommerziellen und hochkommerziellen Ansatz. Ich muss da jetzt aus meiner Interessenlage auch ein bisschen für die vermeintlich kleinen Vereine und momentan in zweitligesten wie dem ersten FC Nürnberg sprechen, dass ich sage, wenn diese Entwicklung durchschlägt, werden Vereine wie wir wahrscheinlich schlechte Karten haben, genau das, was wir gerade anfangen, umzusetzen, zu definieren. Boom-Branche, möglicher Fall von 50 plus 1, da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen. Investoren und alles drum und dran, das ist alles richtig. Aber andere Boom-Branchen müssen ihre, in Anführungsstrichen, Verlierer nicht mitschleppen. Im Fußball kannst du nicht einfach die 10, die es halt nicht schaffen, wegstreichen, sondern du hast ja immer einen Spielbetrieb, wo du gegen 18 oder 36, oder wenn du die Profi-Ligen zusammenzählst, 56, ne, 55 abzüglich Bremen 2, Mannschaften, die in diesem Spielbetrieb arbeiten müssen.
Aber werden da nicht die 10 schlechtesten einfach irgendwann durchgereicht?
Aber wer kommt denn nach? Also sagen wir mal so, es gibt ja auch einen anderen Fall. Würde sich heute noch mal ein großes Unternehmen entscheiden, ähnlich wie einem Verein im Osten Deutschlands in der vierten oder damals sogar fünften Liga zu übernehmen, mit dem ähnlichen Budget, mit der ähnlichen Prämisse, mit der ähnlichen Ausrichtung. Und viel Kapital bedeutet gar nicht mal unbedingt, dass man dann noch tolle Arbeit leisten muss. Das passiert, weil sie halt auch viele Spezialisten haben dann ohnehin bei diesen Vereinen. Aber man kann sich auch ganz viele Fehler erlauben, über die dann immer wenig spricht.
Aber wenn der Fußball weiter so boomt und es da weiter Geld zu holen gibt, dann werden das natürlich noch viele Unternehmen machen.
Ja, ganz genau. Und dann wird es halt spannend. Das ist genau das, was ich erzählen würde. In dem Moment, wo sich jemand nochmal mit einem ähnlichen Modell in der fünften oder vierten Liga engagiert, was vielleicht bald nicht mehr möglich ist, sondern man kann gleich in die dritte, zweite oder erste Liga gehen, in diesem Moment, wo sich ein großer Investor nochmal entscheidet, wird er automatisch einen Wettbewerbsvorteil haben vor Vereinen wie Gladbach und wie Mainz, wie Freiburg, egal in welcher Liga er anfängt und egal wie lange es dauert, bis er in der ersten Liga ist. Weil der ursprüngliche Gedanke eines erfolgreichen Fußballvereins, den Bayern ja – das fällt mir natürlich schwer, das zu sagen, aber den Bayern ja vorzelebriert – ist, wirtschaftliche oder Vereinsinterne Entscheidungen bedingen sportliche Entwicklung. Also Vereinsentwicklung bedingt sportliche Entwicklung. Sportliche Entwicklung bedingt dann automatisch, mehr oder weniger automatisch sportlichen Erfolg. Sportlicher Erfolg bedingt wieder Vereinsentwicklung, Vereinserfolg, wirtschaftlicher Erfolg. Und dann geht dieses Rad immer weiter. Und wenn du im Endeffekt von außen dir quasi so ein Finanzdoping holst, dann musst du dieses Rad nicht weiter drehen. Das heißt, du bist irgendwo in dieser Kette nicht mehr darauf angewiesen, auf deine eigene gute Arbeit, sondern du fängst irgendwann mal an mit Summe X und baust dann da drauf auf. Und das ist so ein Wettbewerbsvorteil, den kann man nicht negieren. Auf der anderen Seite, ich habe überhaupt keine Prognose, wo das jetzt alles hinsteuert, gerade 50 plus 1 und gerade Öffnung für Investoren. Ich weiß nur, dass sich der Fußball dann meiner Meinung nach sehr verändern wird. Und damit einhergehend wird wahrscheinlich auch dann so die, ja, wenn du mich sagst, noch mal im Elan in sechs bis acht Jahren, das wird wahrscheinlich einen maßgeblichen Einfluss darauf haben. Ob es noch Spaß macht, sich zu engagieren.
Willst du noch über 50 plus 1 mit mir diskutieren? Hast du die Energie noch?
Jaja, gerne.
Also mal, wir klammern mal einige Dinge aus, ob 50 plus 1 mit EU-Recht vereinbar ist, ob 50 plus 1 mit EU-Recht vereinbar ist, ob 50 plus 1 nicht sowieso schon gefallen ist, dass 50 plus 1 ausgehört wurde für Einzelfälle. Ich denke, das eine kann man ausklammern, das andere kann man als Tatsache gerade hinnehmen. Und das, was die Diskussion rund um 50 plus 1 so interessant macht, ist, dass wir immer über Zukunftsszenarien sprechen, die niemand sehen kann. Und jetzt würde ich auch nicht für mich in Anspruch nehmen, zu sagen, ich hätte hier eine Kugel des Nostradamus und wüsste, wie es in Zukunft läuft. Und ich halte aber bestimmte Szenarien für wahrscheinlicher als andere. Und wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass nach dem Wegfahren von 50 plus 1 vermehrt Investoren, wo auch immer die herkommen mögen, in den Fußball strömen. Ich denke, das kann man auch als gegeben annehmen. Es wird – bestimmte Vereine werden da sehr schnell auch schon fast schon magisch einen Plan aus der Schublade ziehen, so als hätten sie sich vielleicht sogar schon länger mit diesem Szenario verfasst. Also es wird mehr Investoren geben, die werden mehr Geld reingeben und davon werden wir nicht nur Investoren haben, die eine emotionale Rendite daraus ziehen, sondern Investoren, die damit Geld verdienen wollen. Damit ist das Invest an einen sportlichen Erfolg gekoppelt, der in einem Umfeld stattfindet, in dem klar ist, nicht jeder kann sportlichen Erfolg haben. Dann ist doch eigentlich sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wir irgendwann an eine Situation kommen, in der es wieder einen Unmut geben wird. Diesmal sind es dann nicht die Fans, die sagen, dieses Spiel ist uns komplett entwachsen, sondern dann sind es die Investoren, die irgendwann sagen, Moment mal, was kann ich denn dafür, dass mein Verein wegen dem Depp von Sportdirektor abgestiegen ist und jetzt muss ich in der zweiten Liga spielen? Nee, dafür habe ich nicht 300 Millionen Euro gegeben und dafür habe ich auch nicht der DFL bei XY geholfen. Das ist doch eigentlich ein sehr wahrscheinliches Szenario und dann kommen wir vermutlich in eine Situation, in der wir entweder eine Verfestigung des Ligenbetriebs haben, wie es in der Premier League mit den Parachute-Payments gemacht wird, dass du, wenn du absteigst in die zweite Liga, als Belohnung dafür erstmal 200 Millionen Pfund, die Summe ist jetzt ausgedacht, aber so weit weg ist es glaube ich gar nicht, ja gut 40 Millionen reicht, um die Ohren gehauen bekommst. Oder wir sind vielleicht sogar bei einem festen Ligensystem, wo du irgendwann sagst, naja gut, dann machen wir halt irgendwie jetzt Liga Nord, Liga Süd, Playoff-System, ihr könnt nicht absteigen, dann kann jeder mal gewinnen.
Ja, du sprichst das Szenarien an, die je mehr man sie durchdenkt. Und ich denke da ja auch zum Beispiel, weil man ja manchmal so mit Private Equity Leuten, also aus der Investmentbranche oder Family Offices quasi öfters mal spricht, auch aus einem anderen Grund, nicht beruflich, dass du schon bei solchen Menschen grundsätzlich ein Denken vorfindest, das ganz logisch sagt, Return und Invest. Jetzt hast du auch etwas richtig gesagt, und das ist vorhin mit meinen 56 bzw. 55 Profivereinen auch so ein bisschen gemeint. Das kannst du nämlich fortführen. Wir nehmen mal tatsächlich diesen Fall an, dass alle diese Vereine Investoren haben, dass alle diese Vereine Top-Leute haben, die beste Transferpolitik machen, auf allen Ebenen hochprofessionell arbeiten. Trotzdem wird es nur einen Meister geben, trotzdem werden nur vier oder fünf, je nachdem, wenn der sechste Platz dann halt mal zur Europa League zählt, nur ihre europäischen Ziele erreichen, zwei werden trotzdem absteigen und von diesen 55 oder 56 Mannschaften werden mehr als die Hälfte rein mathematisch ihre sportlichen Ziele verfehlen. Das Ganze passiert im zweiten Jahr, noch mal mindestens der Hälfte dieser Hälfte, wahrscheinlich wieder mehr. Und im dritten und im vierten Jahr ganz automatisch. Und dann ist dieses Szenario, das du jetzt beschließt, für mich gar nicht so unrealistisch. Denn wir haben jetzt über 50 plus 1 gesprochen, das ist jetzt gefallen in deinem Modell. Welche Personen werden denn dann zu diesen DFL-Tagungen, auf denen Dinge beschlossen werden wie das Liegensystem, wie Auf- und Abstieg, wie Geldverteilung, wer wird denn dann dahingeschickt? Doch schätzungsweise Menschen, die von den Investoren quasi an die Spitze gesetzt wurden, die im Sinne des Investors handeln. Das ist ja alles völlig legitim und das ist ja alles nicht zu negieren. Und dann ist dieses Szenario zum Beispiel, den Auf- und Abstieg irgendwann mal abzuschaffen. Auch wenn das jetzt nur sehr weit weg ist. Aber das ist aus einer Investoren-Sicht, der nur Return-on-Invest zieht, der nur Input-Output zieht, der nur sagt, ich muss so schnell wie möglich meine Anteile vervielfachen. Dem ist dieses ganze regional verwurzelt. Irgendwie Spieler aus der Region, irgendwie aus der eigenen Jugend, müssen immer so und so viele Spieler durch. Dem ist das völlig egal, weil der ein völlig anderes Ziel hat. Und das Problem ist gar nicht mehr die Leute, die diese Ziele erreichen, sondern die Vereine, die diese Ziele dauerhaft verfehlen werden. Und da sehe ich schon das große Problem. Und da kann man auch viel mit Befürwortern oder Gegnern von 50 plus 1 reden. Ich muss für mich ganz sagen, da bin ich auch ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dass 50 plus 1 ein elementarer Bestandteil ist, zumindest in Deutschland den Wettbewerb aufrechtzuerhalten, die Chancen für kleinere Vereine aufrechtzuerhalten und nicht umgekehrt. Weil ich aber auch, und da muss ich auch ehrlich sein, Teil der Vereine bin, die nicht unbedingt europäisch und international denken müssen. Da mache ich es mir auch sehr einfach.
Was aber ja auch die Mehrheit der Vereine ist.
Tatsächlich, ja. Aber da mache ich es mir sehr einfach. Was heißt, da mache ich es mir sehr einfach? Ich habe eine andere Sichtweise und ich habe eine andere Idee zu 50 plus 1 oder eine andere Meinung. Und deshalb ist das Szenario, das du da gerade beschrieben hast, das ist dann wirklich, ich glaube der Kollege Rettich hat irgendwie, dann haben wir keine Rangliste, sondern eine Forbes-Liste mehr. Das hat er so eins zu eins. Das ist im Endeffekt ein sehr schönes Bild. Aber wenn das spannend wäre am Ende für die Leute, dann wäre es okay. Ja, das bedingt ja aber auch, dass wir uns komplett in diesen klassischen Entertainment-Bereich. Das ist wirklich nur noch so. Aber dann schauen wir uns die erfolgreichsten Ligen an der Welt, die im Entertainment-Bereich verankert sind. Das sind die amerikanischen großen vier Ligen. Eishockey, Baseball, Basketball und vor allen Dingen Football, als die wahrscheinlich erfolgreichste von allen Ligen weltweit. Ich glaube auch so im Umsatz ist sie, glaube ich. Interessant, die haben auch interne Probleme zu Hause mit Zuschauern, während die Auslandsvermarktung boomt. Und dann schaut man sich das System an und sagt, diese Menschen haben eigentlich kapiert, wie Entertainment funktioniert, nämlich indem der sportliche Wettbewerb aufrechterhalten wird. Draftingsystem, Salary Cap und im Endeffekt ein geschlossenes Ligensystem. Und beim Football, anders zu den anderen Spielen, hast du immer total auf Highlight ausgelegte Spielpläne, weil du ja nie ein Jahr drauf immer gegen denselben spielst. Das sind ja immer so unterschiedliche Kreuze.
Nur innerhalb von vier Jahren.
Genau, richtig.
Und wenn du mir jetzt sagen würdest, der Fußball als Spiel bleibt so, wie er jetzt ist, und wir führen aber so ein Nichtabstiegssystem, Salary Cap und so weiter ein, würde ich sagen, sofort gekauft. Meine Sorge ist aber, geht aber da dann schon wieder weiter. Vielleicht bin ich da aber auch einfach Bedenkenträger. Vielleicht sollte ich da so meine Visitenkarte drauf schreiben. Max-Jakob Ost, Bedenkenträger und Podcast-Moderator.
Ich guck mal, wie einen Job im Verein für dich haben.
Oh, Bedenkenträger, da sind die meisten Jobs schon vergeben. Meine Sorge ist aber, dass das vor dem Spiel nicht halt gemacht werden wird. Das kann man ja jetzt schon ablesen an aktuellen Entwicklungen wie dem Videoassistenten, der ganz eindeutig aus der Sicht des Fernsehzuschauers gemacht wurde und nicht aus der Sicht des Stadionbesuchers.
Und das ist dann das, wo ich dann sage, ja gut, dann bin ich aber auch nicht, hier Zugeständnisse zu machen bei 50 plus 1, mit der Sorge, dass es so kommt, dass dann irgendwann, wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, 55 Investoren haben in den professionellen Ligen. Und dann kommt irgendwann so ein festes System, weil dann, glaube ich, geht es als nächstes nämlich ans Spiel ran und dann wird das Spiel noch weiter so durchmonetarisiert, dass da neue Erlösquellen rauszuholen sind. Aber ich weiß selber, dass ich da sehr viel im Konjunktiv bin. Vielleicht wird es auch noch eine 50 plus 1 Sendung geben. Ein bisschen warte ich ehrlich gesagt darauf, dass mir diese Entscheidung abgenommen wird. Da muss ich nicht eine 5-Stunden-Sendung zu diesem Thema aufnehmen, was so unglaublich kompliziert ist, aber irgendwie eigentlich auch nicht. Eigentlich ist das ein klares Meinungsthema. Das ist, als würde ich dir eine Suppe hinstellen und würde sagen, schmeckt sie dir oder schmeckt sie dir nicht. Genau so redet man eigentlich über 50 plus 1.
Ja, bis zu einem gewissen Grad vor allem, weil die Intuition, 50 plus 1 mal einzuführen, tatsächlich wirklich von den Verbänden oder sogar von der DFL kam, um genau diese Dinge zu verhindern, die man jetzt teilweise, aber aus der Branche schon ein bisschen propagiert. Das macht es auch so ein bisschen schizophren auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber ein Thema, das halt auch wirklich ausdiskutiert werden muss. Ich habe das schon mehrfach jetzt gesagt. Ich bin ein sehr offener Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr interessierter Mensch daran, verschiedene Sichtweisen und auch Meinungen da einzuholen. Und diskutiere da auch gerne drüber. Aber zu 50 plus 1 habe ich für mich ganz persönlich meine Meinung eben auch durch dieses Gespräch und durch dieses lange Überlegen gefunden. Der Videobeweis und ganz allgemein diese Thematiken, die deuten ja auch in eine gewisse Richtung hin. Ich muss jetzt ehrlich sagen, aus der Warte der Zweitligisten, aber ich habe auch schon ein Bundesligaspiel in dieser Saison gesehen, wie man dort mit dem Stadiongänger umgeht, ihn im Zweifel lässt. Das spricht schon sehr stark dafür, dass man sich ganz wenig Gedanken gemacht hat, wie das denn live wirkt. Weil ich ein sehr positiver Mensch bin, der immer glaubt, dass die Leute immer alle nur das Beste wollen, auch wenn sie anderer Meinung sind als ich. Fasse ich doch das noch mal unter Anfangs, wie ihn zusammen, und da vielleicht entwickelt sich das ja. Beim Rugby habe ich zum Beispiel mal gesehen, dass dort der Schiedsrichter anhand des Leinwandbildes entscheidet. Das heißt, jeder sieht das. Wobei man aber auch sagen muss, dass der Umgang mit dem Schiedsrichter beim Rugby ein Elementar anderer ist als beim Fußball. Was vielleicht auch mal so eine Idee wäre, vor allen technischen Hilfsmitteln das vielleicht irgendwie mal zu propagieren und mal irgendwie in Bahnen zu lenken. Weil das fasziniert mich wirklich ganz ungemein. Dass wenn da für alle offensichtlich ist, dass das eine Fehlentscheidung ist. Ja, das ist der Schiedsrichter, Punkt, Ende. Alle gehen weiter, alles in Ordnung. Und die andere Geschichte ist aber auch ganz klar, dass dieses Live von diesem Stadion, was uns ja als Fußballfans auch wichtig ist, tatsächlich immer ausdifferenzierter und immer schwieriger wird. Ich weiß nicht, thematisch zu erfassen. Ich mache mal ein Beispiel. Noch vor drei Jahren hätte ich dir Brief und Siegel geschworen, dass wenn wir dreimal am Stück gewinnen und dann noch in Fürth das Derby – das muss ja in dieser Sendung mindestens einmal gesagt werden. Ich glaube, ich habe es schon gesagt. Nach 25 Jahren das erste Mal wieder gewonnen haben und dann ein Heimspiel bei strahlendem Sonnenschein an einem Samstag Mittag für zweite Liga-Verhältnisse – gut, die Anschlusszeiten – gegen einen nicht ganz unattraktiven Gegner Arminia Bielefeld für die Zweitliga-Verhältnisse. Dann hätte ich dir vor drei Jahren auf den Kopf zugesagt, mindestens 3000 bis 4000 Zuschauer Überschnitt. Keine Frage, keine Diskussion. In dieser Saison ist genau diese Situation eingetreten und wir hatten ungefähr unseren Schnitt erreicht.
Der bei wie viel liegt?
Ungefähr 26.000, 27.000. Das ist im Endeffekt – und wir hatten das Derby aber noch nicht, das muss man dazu sagen – dass hoffentlich auch genauso siegreich gestaltet wird. Aber gut, das ist schon etwas, wo ich dann im Kleinen immer drüber nachdenke, welche Systematiken und welche Mechanismen funktionieren eigentlich nicht mehr. Da kannst du jetzt viel ins Feld führen. Wenn du die Fans fragst, die weggeblieben sind, dann sagen die, Anstoßzeit, Samstagmittag. Och, ich wusste nicht. Dann sagt der Junge, du setzt dich eine halbe Stunde ins Auto bis zum Stadion und du weißt ganz genau, ausverkauft wird es nicht sein. Du wirst schon noch eine Karte bekommen. Und ja, dann natürlich auch, wie angenehm es ist, ein solches Spiel inzwischen von zu Hause auszusehen. Und da ist mir neulich mit dem Kumpel, mit dem ich auch so lange ins Stadion gehe, ist mir eigentlich so gekommen, so weißt du, wie sich unser Verhalten im Stadion geändert hat. In den 80er- und 90er-Jahren, als wir so als Buben da ins Stadion sind, das war am Anfang noch die Zeit, wo die Sportschau nur drei Spiele gezeigt hat. Und ein aktuelles Sportstudio, da war man nicht mehr wach, da musste man ins Bett. Oder wir waren noch vom Auswärtsspiel unterwegs. Außer, eine schöne Zeit eigentlich. Na nicht nur eigentlich, das war eine schöne Zeit. Und dann haben dich am Montag in der Schule oder auf der Arbeit die Leute gefragt, ja, war das ein Elfer, wie hat denn das ausgesehen? Du sagst ja ja und nein, weil meistens hast du ja eh, genauso wie heute, relativ wenig gesehen, weil sie ja sehr weit weg war. Aber die haben dich gefragt. Heute, wenn irgendetwas passiert, was auch nur ansatzweise in Richtung, oh, war das ein Elfer, war das ein Freund, WhatsApp oder du kriegst sie schon. Und so hat sich unser Verhalten geändert, dass du im Endeffekt als Stadiongänger faktisch keinen, selbst wenn du nur am Spiel interessiert bist, kannst du einem Fußballzuschauer am Fernsehen schon keinen Vorwurf mehr machen. Im Endeffekt, dass er nicht ins Stadion geht und sagt, hier habe ich doch alles, hier sehe ich das besser. Und dieser Effekt ist im Endeffekt auch durch meine Eltern bestärkt worden, an völlig anderer Stelle. Die sind beide große Biathlon-Fans, wenn man das so nennen kann, und fahren einmal im Jahr auch zu Biathlon, irgendwie nach Rupoling oder irgendwo nach Österreich, und nehmen da die Stimmung mit. Und nehmen da Faszinosum. Da hast du natürlich auch durch Highlight-Präsentationen volle Tribünen. Und dann sind da Norweger mit ihren Elch gewein und toll. Und dann trinkt man noch einen Glühwein zusammen, was weiß ich. Aber die sagen ganz klar, einmal im Jahr reicht, weil ich will ja sehen, was passiert. Ich sehe ja im Fernsehen wesentlich besser, was passiert.
Und das, obwohl der Biotlon ja auch schon hinsichtlich sowohl Besuch vor Ort als auch für Fernsehen optimiert wurde. Früher sind die viel länger durch den Wald gefahren und haben viel seltener geschossen. Gibt ja jetzt mehr Schießen.
Das ist tatsächlich auch eine spannende Aufgabe für die Vereine, wie sie das im Endeffekt umkehren. Und das ist gerade halt auch eine Aufgabe für Vereine, die im Vergleich zu ihren aktuellen Zuschauerzahlen sehr, sehr große Stadien haben.
Ja, interessantes Thema. Chris Mensch, wir haben über viel gesprochen. Wir haben über dich als Aufsichtsrat gesprochen und noch über ganz, ganz viele andere Themen eigentlich. Ich fand es sehr, sehr interessant. Da ich weiß, dass du den Rasenfunk auch hörst und da du vermutlich einen ganz anderen Blick auf den Fußball hast als ich, auch wenn wir uns in vielen Themen sehr einig sind, über welches Thema würdest du dir denn noch wünschen im Rasenfunk? Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Also eins liegt mir natürlich am Herzen. Vielleicht gibt es ja mal eine Rasenfunk-Ausgabe über die zweite Liga.
Wenn ich es hauptberuflich mache, dann kommt das, ja.
Und ansonsten muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich höre ihn gerne. Das war jetzt nicht als Fisch in den Kopf, aber als Compliments gemeint. So ist das ja auch entstanden. Und ich glaube, dass es dem Fußball auch ganz gut tut, dass wir solche Formate haben. Und deshalb bin ich auch sehr gerne gekommen, weil ich glaube, dass wir da draußen ganz, ganz viele am Fußball interessierte Menschen haben, denen die klassischen Informationsmedien vielleicht aufgrund der Aktualität, aufgrund der Gleichförmigkeit auch vielleicht ein bisschen der Meldungen, die dir auch rausgegeben werden. Das müssen wir auch mal sagen. Wie Bilder und wie Dinge rausgegeben werden, dass da manche Medienhäuser wenig Chancen haben, noch irgendwas dran zu ändern, was beizumischen. Und da glaube ich, dass es halt solche Formate geben muss, die ganz wichtig sind dafür, dass man auch links und rechts mal seinen Blick und die auch den Informations- und den Wissensdrang von ganz klassisch interessierten Fußballfans auch ein bisschen stillt und mal neue Themen, neue Ideen aufmacht.
Aber du hast jetzt keinen konkreten Themenwunsch.
Ein Thema hätte ich tatsächlich gehabt, hättest du diese Sendung nicht schon gemacht. Und das ist wirklich das Thema zur Depression im Fußball. Da bin ich sehr neidisch, dass du Rolal Dreng kennengelernt hast. Ich habe nur auf meinem Hörbuch Spieltage eine Signatur von ihm, eine Unterschrift.
Ja, war auch eine sehr wichtige Sendung. Aber da kommen noch ein paar andere, die auch noch wichtig sind. Da gibt es so einige Flecken im Fußballbetrieb, über die irgendwie nicht so häufig gesprochen wird.
Da freue ich mich sehr drauf und da lasse ich mich dann überraschen. Und die Sendung zu 50 plus 1?
Ich drücke mich ein bisschen davor, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Dieser Riemen zu Raba damals, da ist eine Vorbereitung reingegangen. Das ist schier unglaublich. Und ich weiß, dass 50 plus 1 eigentlich noch härter wäre, von der Gästeauswahl bis hin zu meiner Vorbereitung und Vorbereitung der Gäste. Und vor allem bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass man da zwar nochmal viele Dinge erklären könnte und viele Aspekte sagen könnte, an die nicht jeder gleich denkt, wenn er an 50 plus 1 denkt. Aber man wird nicht zu einem befriedigenden Ergebnis kommen. 50 plus 1 ist noch sehr viel konjunktiv. Und derzeit tendiere ich fast dazu, das Jahr 2018 noch abzuwarten. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass wir am Ende des Jahres in der Frage viel weitergekommen sind, was einfach das Schaffen von Fakten angeht. Und vielleicht ist es dann auch sinnvoller, es dann drüber zu diskutieren. Na ja, Chris, ich danke dir sehr herzlich. Das hat großen, großen Spaß gemacht. Das war Chris Ehrenberg aus dem Aufsichtsrat vom 1. FC Nürnberg.
Danke dir ebenso.
Aber du bist nicht bei Twitter. Ich könnte dich jetzt nicht verlinken.
Nein, nein, nein, tatsächlich nicht. Ich bin nicht immer bei Facebook.
Wie könnten dir die Leute Feedback zukommen lassen, wenn sie dir Feedback bekommen?
Am einfachsten an Ehrenberg, also meinen Nachnamen, atfcn.de. Da weiß ich, dass es den Fußballbezug hat und da würde ich das dann auch bekommen.
Gut, sehr gut. Dann macht es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.